okay we'll open up the public hearing on
House Bill 531 and hear from the prime
sponsor Jerry Stringham good morning
representative Stringham
good morning chairman thank you for the
invitation I am Jerry Stringham I
represent uh Lincoln and Woodstock I
served on the Ways and Means Committee
from 2018 to 2020. so I had some
background in our sin taxes I my
background includes degrees from MIT in
the Harvard Business School after uh
several years as a medical device
entrepreneur I spent the last 25 years
as a strategy consultant to medical
technology companies
um I'm also joined on this bill by
representative Tom Schamberg who's uh
who's over here as well he's my
compatriot in out of the box thinking
and if it's helpful you can think of
this bill as a Tom and Jerry Bill if you
like
this bill is largely a taxation bill
because it doesn't propose new
regulation so it was certainly geared
that way but I'm happy to bring it here
but hope it reaches Ways and Means as
well the bill is divided into three
sections the first discusses and and
proposes to change the process
for the cigarette tax secondly something
similar for The Vaping and e-cigarette
tax and then finally addresses a
committee to discuss the tobacco
settlement funds all of these were part
of discussions uh from several years ago
uh let's start with the cigarette tax
um
a few observations a cigarette tax rate
is set by the legislature currently it's
a dollar seventy eight uh cross-border
sales is a significant factor over 50
percent of our sales comes from uh
residents
generally from New England but outside
of New Hampshire
uh the demand uh the the marketplace the
demand is very elastic uh based on
pricing and tax rates so paying
attention to that has significant
impacts on on what kind of revenues we
generate
uh so lower prices and lower taxes
generally generate more sales
our rates are the lowest uh in the
region which is primarily us and our
three contiguous states is kind of a One
Marketplace
um in the 2018 to 2020 uh ways and means
we are testimony from groups like The
American Heart Association and ACS
American Cancer Society that keys to
limiting cancer and heart deaths was a
combination of three factors regulation
Taxation and cessation
uh tax uh tax changes should be
considered uh uh at the time
um you know we looked at you know our
closest competitor and price or tax rate
which was Maine which was slightly
higher than us about 11 and still the
case I spoke to two main reps at the
time
um uh one was pushing for lower taxes so
that they can compete with us in their
border area and the other uh seeking to
raise funds and had a bill that way
um you know part part of their
reluctance to raise taxes in in Maine is
uh the impact that it would have on
losing sales to us
uh an epiphany occurred to me while
reading New York Times article last
November about how we handled online
gambling in the state and
um and how how uh you know essentially
our take was established and I'll I'll
read a quote today 31 States permit
Sports gambling online the gambling
industry press states to set tax rate
low in sports betting warning that it if
the states pushed rates too high sports
fans would turn to the black market to
place bets on unregulated sites These
Warnings turned out to be misplaced this
is again still quoting some States
including New York and New Hampshire
ignored the industry's advice and
installed the highest rates on betting
they have seen bets placed at a higher
rate per capita than low rate states in
fact New York has seen such a high rate
of betting that has collected 546
million dollars in the first 10 months
of 2022 which is 50 of the entire online
Sports gambling take for states in the
country
uh
New York Times didn't get in entirely
right because we didn't really set a tax
rate for online Sports gambling what we
did was we allowed our Administration
to go out and get the best deal rather
than us micromanaging the rate of
Taxation
we used our our terrific Lottery
Commission and Charlie McIntyre uh to go
out and work a deal and on a voluntary
basis the amount that we that we take
from our on online gambling uh partner
is turns out to be right about where New
York is and way above where the
legislature set in the rest of the
country
so
um you know so there's precedence for uh
us
maintaining control over this process by
uh by engaging with with with the
administration but allowing their
full-time expertise to make decisions
sometimes day by day I mean if you think
about it even something like hard liquor
how much how much tax is there in a
bottle of Jack Daniels that changes
based on market conditions and uh and
it's set by The Liquor Commission not by
us as a legislature but the take we to
take we get
um you know is in some ways you could
think of as a tax
so
I think I think the the success in the
online gambling and it was it was
certainly uh a heavy process uh and and
where we come out in this article is a
surprise even even the ways and means
members uh that uh uh that we did such a
better job and I know Charlie is uh
Charlie McIntyre is presented to Vermont
who's
um uh proposing online uh gambling
legalization there based on our model
um
so for cigarette tax uh it's another
form of of a syntax and I certainly you
know if we get the same amount of money
I'd rather get money from from a tobacco
than say business profits or some
something that we're
uh that doesn't have an externality
associated with it but what it does is
it guarantees uh that we're the low low
tax uh uh state in the region so if
somebody in Maine is thinking they're
going to undercut us they won't and
they'll they won't try but it allows the
tax rate to change uh based on local
market conditions without new
legislation or legislative approval we
can still still manage the process
through through annual uh oversight
uh so that's uh that's kind of a
background on the on the cigarette tax
the second address is uh E-cigarettes
are vaping
um keeping in mind again the three
criteria of of uh regulation cessation
and Taxation uh the bill we passed a
legal regulating vaping also occurred in
2018 to 2020. the primary goal was to
regulate what was a Health crisis uh and
it was quite rampant among our young at
the time
um the tax rate
um is a bit complicated as as the fiscal
note would say depending on what type of
product it is but it was largely put in
as a placeholder
and in some cases it's
um it needs to re-examination for
example the eight eight percent uh of
wholesale cost that's less than uh what
we uh what we tax a tuna fish sandwich
for uh right now in New Hampshire
um it's it's a relatively uh smaller
piece it's less than one two hundredth
of what we collect in cigarette taxes at
the time but I think it's time to
reassess this tax and and perhaps uh uh
this bill proposes a similar structure
of of allowing Administration to work
within confines
of finally the third section deals with
a committee to understand the use of
tobacco funds this was originally a bill
that was uh supported and forwarded by
Edith Tucker in ways and means
in particular the tobacco settlement
funds uses
um
our uses
compared to its legislative mandate
would be helpful to study you know
working for a tobacco company is an easy
however in some of the states the use of
tobacco settlement funds is quite a bit
more creative for example in North
Carolina
uh they have a program called Golden
Leaf the Golden Leaf fund is supplied
over 55 million dollars in in-state high
quality education grants
um this information provided by this
report I think would see as a foundation
of what we're doing compared to what the
Mandate or Direction was at the time and
whether they're suitable other
opportunities for these funds so to
summarize part one and two propose a
methodological change so it still makes
this a a low tax state it provides a
mechanism
that doesn't leave too much money on the
table since since
syntaxes are generally uh somewhat more
desirable it's basically a market forced
fee set on a regular basis by the
experts that we've hired to run our
government rather than the legislature
itself
I also think that this market-driven
process should be considered for other
potential syntaxes that may come up like
this afternoon
thank you
I'll be happy to take any questions any
questions from the committee members
so uh
oh I'm sorry yes representative Speer
I received some letters from some big
some small vaping stores they seem to
think that raising the tax that eight
percent is going to hurt them
can you comment on that because they
seem to think that that's going to bring
it to the point where they won't be able
to stay in business it's not low enough
they say
and I'm not making judgment one way or
the other that they you know they feel
it's not low enough that anybody would
come across the state to come to and
they say 50 of their sales is from out
of the state
yeah I mean I think the the e-cigarette
and vaping tax situation is more
complicated than cigarettes because of
the way that they're they're done and um
and I think the mechanism of how uh how
customers decide which product to
purchase by state is somewhat different
um so uh and also the revenue piece is
is a lot smaller right now I do think I
do think those taxes were put in as
placeholders and I do think uh both the
mechanism of how it's set and what they
are
um
uh needs needs to be updated because it
was definitely it was definitely thrown
in uh as a placeholder at the time I see
and the other half of the question is
for the question you may inquire thank
you well I'm sorry you may inquire
further question oh I'm sorry I'm new at
this
uh I noticed that cigars aren't taxed
as much as cigarettes I mean and they
cause as much problems as cigarettes
what what is that about uh well premium
cigars is addressed in another bill I
think going directly to Ways and Means I
see uh with another sponsor
um
you know just 10 seconds on it we do
know a lot of people buy premium cigars
via uh online that creates other other
complications and issues that would need
to be addressed with that specific
product there are small scars that
they're that are taxed like cigarettes
though
representative petusic uh thank you Mr
chair uh on the charts that are on uh
from dra
the uh pack of 20 tax rate from New
Hampshire Etc has anything been taken
into account the lack of total revenue
because of the tax rise per pack
that we lose back to Massachusetts or
Maine
are you oh well I I think the fiscal
note he's looking at the old fiscal note
that came in the bill the the numbers
this is yeah that's in the bill it's in
the bill but I just had passed out to
everyone a new fiscal note okay so I I
don't know if it's different but that
maybe that's what it still doesn't
know how much we're going to lose
on total revenue based on your tax
increase per pack
yeah you're saying that if um if we tax
it more that's going to suppress demand
and sales of New Hampshire cigarettes by
some amount this this figure here based
on the zero to eight percent range and
calculating it that way is based on on
no uh reduction in demand we're still
the low low tax state I I personally
would
would um
uh you know lower those numbers a little
bit because
you know if if we're but if if indeed
the state sets the rate higher so
there's no guarantee they're gonna going
to raise the rates um
um appreciably under this further
questioning Claire thank you Mr chair
and would you believe that you know
there is going to be a revenue drop when
the people go back to Massachusetts or
Maine and buy the cigarettes there for
basically the same price uh it's not
going to be the same price because
Massachusetts uh charges way way more
than anywhere we would go at this point
so thank you
Representative Vincent thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question so we have this chart in front
of us that talks about the New England
uh tobacco tax amount by state and by
type
um and it shows uh bordering state let's
just use the first one Maine they're
charging two dollars um per pack on
taxes did that take into consideration
uh the sales tax or sales tax uh I think
it's five percent of me or does that
apply to taxes that exempt yeah the the
way the bill is written it would um you
should use it says to use the sales tax
because Maine charges five and a half
percent sales tax so that would be 211 I
actually
um uh
um I'm somewhat indifferent of whether
you do that or not
um so
um so if you didn't use it it would be
two dollars if you use the sales tax
it's 211. so it's more in in New
Hampshire it's 178. thank you thank you
Mr chairman representative Ammon
thank you Mr chair thank you for coming
and testifying
um question use the word micromanagement
I just wanted to zero in on that word
um by giving the agency the ability to
set the tax rate
is there a process where the public can
be involved in helping to Define that
that rate the way it is here now when we
have a bill introduced
um how would that process work
well right now the the
um the rates a dollar 78 and that's it
what what this bill proposes to allow
the administration to work within a
range without
um having to go to the legislature uh so
but they could not either go above or
below that range without coming back to
us and asking us for uh for new
legislation and of course at any point
we could uh do the same
so
um so make sure I understand here the
current statute
is that the legislature
sets the dollar amount
that's my understanding and that and
you're saying well it's just dollar 78
well I can say here on this committee uh
it's been 30 cents a gallon for beer for
a very long time and over those years
we've had bills in to
raise it and we had a hearings and
process and
the bill dies so I guess what is wrong
with that system
why you know I I guess you could say is
does it happen every year
uh like the commissioner is supposed to
make a change every year uh
theoretically it could even in the
halfway through a biennium if someone
put in a bill to raise the severe tax
we could theoretically still raise the
beer tax yeah I mean you can't raise
cigarette taxes too quickly because of
the way that stamp distribution I mean
you buy these stamps and it takes a
while to filter out the old ones and
bring in new ones so practically
speaking there are time limitations of
how quickly Administration could make a
change
um the
um I guess the the premise is I think
our desire is to be the low tax state
and to take advantage of the elastic
demand that comes with that but
um uh it's
um you know if if the circumstances
change locally and we still meet that
objective then we've done as a
legislature what we want to do
and I think it also provides a
disincentive for anybody else to try to
undercut us
so so can the commissioner just
unilaterally change six months into a
year because some other state changed
their rate
um well this talks about a once a year
process that's what I see where where
they examine uh what the what the local
rates are and and whether a rate is
warranted much like in online gambling
uh the the uh the contracted rate with
with our pervert preferred uh supplier
could change and we could be having a
different rate which generates revenue
for the state and then you know in that
case we're getting way more than we ever
would have gotten if we had sat around
the table and tried to come up with a
fair price that we were going to offer
so that that's uh but right now that
that Center on the table happens in ways
and means when they set the the budget
and and it seems have been working
pretty well for how many years now a
long time right I mean you're you're i i
i i I'd say it's great that you're
thinking out of the box and thinking
you're something creative but to take
something away from the legislature and
give it to a commissioner with some
guidelines uh it it seems that an ass to
me that that something the legislature
would want well and you know if I was in
Ways and Means which I'm going to be in
finance I'm in finance this term but I
would still feel like we had control
over it because we could set the range
and monitor the process and and pass
bills as necessary uh and and uh but
still still allow uh for market-based
changes uh without uh uh you know
frankly voting for tax increases and
easy either uh or so
um but this this States really what what
our our goal is for these taxes which is
um
you know to bring to uh
you know not not get uh uh you know not
not be having a tax rate that's way way
below our neighbors and um uh is still
moving forward okay great thanks any
other questions the committee seeing
none thank you very much for your
testimony thank you
okay let's see what do we have here uh I
have
three cards in opposition and one card
uh neutral why don't we do a neutral
Nancy
representing the American Heart
Association
good morning chairman hunt members of
the Commerce and consumer affairs
committee for the record I am Nancy
Vaughn government relations director for
the American Heart Association here in
New Hampshire and I am very pleased to
be able to be here today while I am
taking a unique neutral stance on a
tobacco tax bill
I don't at this point I'm just I'm not
quite sure I understand all of the um
the concept here but I wanted to at
least share some information with this
committee as you can see I have provided
a lot of Light reading for you so this
is you know peruse
some of this information comes from the
American Heart Association some comes
from the campaign for tobacco-free kids
which I urge you to um you know look at
their website and pull up even more
information on Tobacco taxes and the
impact on health and things of that
nature I do have written testimony and I
was trying not to read what I have I do
want to thank the sponsor for bringing
this bill forward I can't remember the
last time we had a bill on Tobacco
taxation in New Hampshire I was just
thinking about that I don't know it has
been about 10 years since we have had an
increase to at least the cigarette tax
several years ago there was a tax put on
electronic cigarettes and we do have a
tax rate on other tobacco products also
called known as otps which are generally
smokeless tobacco products and
and so the the American Heart
Association always supports substantial
tax increases in in our states
um and by substantial I mean a dollar a
pack is really our our minimum point at
which we encourage increasing taxation
um the reason is because tobacco use is
the leading cause of preventable disease
disability and death in in New Hampshire
as well as the rest of the country when
you raise the tobacco tax at a
substantial rate there are public health
benefits such as reducing and preventing
tobacco use
predominantly amongst youth is really
our Focus to help prevent that addiction
from starting
savings on health care costs from
tobacco-related diseases and a source of
funds that states can put towards their
tobacco prevention and cessation
services at the state level
and we have not put tobacco tax revenues
directly towards these efforts we have
not put any of our MSA dollars directly
towards these efforts we do have funds
from the state budget for prevention and
cessation services and another dollar
amount that went towards cessation for
youth who are now using electronic
cigarettes at an incredible rate and we
appreciate that but it's still about 3.6
percent of what is recommended to have a
meaningful decrease in in tobacco use if
we could even have 15 percent of the CDC
recommendation which would be about 2.5
million that would be terrific
um one of the other reasons why tobacco
tax increases are are great for reducing
use among youth is that they are very
price conscious when we increase tobacco
cigarette taxes which we have in the
state we are now down to about 5.5
percent of high schools students use
traditional cigarettes but 33.8 percent
are now using electronic cigarettes
which we don't have a very meaningful
tax rate on and I'm not here to push a
tax rate change with this group just to
provide information on why it's
important for our Organization for
particularly for protecting Youth
and these tobacco products cigarettes
electronics cigarettes other tobacco
products contain nicotine which is the
addictive agent within tobacco products
particularly for for youth
there's also the health care costs that
I mentioned in New Hampshire we have
about 847 million dollars annually that
go go towards tobacco-related illness
and that is a huge dollar amount and
only less than a million dollars going
towards tobacco prevention so again why
we would love to see an increase to a
tobacco tax in the near future
we will continue working towards what we
call the tobacco and came in game to end
all tobacco use and nicotine addiction
and just wanted to add that particularly
for the question that came out when
States raise their tobacco taxes by a
small amount eight percent or something
along those lines you will see a
reduction in revenues in your tobacco
tax revenues because it does not keep up
with the natural decrease of people
using tobacco products so if you do it a
one dollar tobacco tax increase you will
always see an increase in those revenues
even if you lose some some business for
the um the reduction that people are
purchasing to tobacco products at so
again I don't want to take up too much
time
I am always here for you if you have any
questions about tobacco or any other
things that cause heart disease and
encourage you to you know reach out to
me if you ever have any questions or
need materials or resources
and that sums up my testimony
great would you believe I remember the
time where we we'd lowered the tax in
hopes that we would get more of those
out of state revenues that didn't show
up and wasn't that a great
trial of what happens when you decrease
tobacco taxes and again it kind of goes
to the point of why you need a
substantial increase when that 10 cent
decrease went into play it was supposed
to encourage more people to come to New
Hampshire the tobacco industry itself
raised the price of tobacco of
cigarettes nine cents a pack
following that 10 cent decrease so the
state did see a decrease in revenues and
the price stayed the same for the people
purchasing the tobacco products so yeah
so would you believe the take home is
it's best just to leave the thing alone
and not mess with it no it's always best
to increase it by at least a dollar a
pack and and also I just want to add for
that other tobacco product tax rate of
we have 65.03 percent of the wholesale
value of of otps is the tax rate on that
Maine has a lower tax rate of 43 percent
I believe on their otps so this is
another concern that I have for the way
this bill is set and obviously relying
on other states to help set our tobacco
tax rate is not the New Hampshire way
necessarily it's a little tacky isn't it
so
um yeah so again I encourage tobacco tax
increases meaningful levels great thank
you very much thank you Victor
foreign
okay
Pages here I'd like to read uh I know
you're kidding I'm just kidding
members of the committee I don't know if
I'm using yeah you want to be real close
okay
thank you for hearing my testimony good
morning everyone
so I'm here uh representing myself my
small business and I'm with the New
Hampshire Vapors Association
and I'm hoping to offer a little food
for thought
pardon me if I'm stating the obvious
if it ain't broke don't fix it
cross-border sales are great
Massachusetts continues to shoot
themselves in the foot
as usual thank you for the business
but they created a much larger problem
and this time it's a little more than
loss of Revenue
The Vapor Products Black Market
Massachusetts is absolutely massive
and it's much larger than all of New
Hampshire Vape products sales combined
so instead of competing with legitimate
businesses we're competing with the
black market
if we increase prices right now tax
it'll just stimulate the black market
cost will go up here
people will decide to save a tank of gas
instead
sounds familiar right
I can't imagine why anyone would
consider raising prices right now
so
in relation to the bill from what I read
and what I understand
I think it's a good idea to not let
neighboring politicians
set the standard and decide what's right
for New Hampshire
they make a lot of mistakes
passing bills like this
will allow those mistakes to annually
compound
and that's a nightmare
so let's not play Follow the Leader off
the fiscal cliff
let's do what Massachusetts is doing
let's do what Maine and Vermont is doing
I don't think it's a good idea
if there's one thing neighboring states
are good at
it's losing Revenue to New Hampshire
let's keep it that way
I think what's best for New Hampshire
right now is to kill the bill
thank you for your time
thank you
I think we're all set thank you uh so
amazingly the Department of Revenue
Administration wants to
speak on the bill
yeah come on
foreign
so theoretically they are neutral yes on
this legislation
good morning my name is Keen Ming Wong
Texas policy Council for the dra
good morning my name is Lauren
O'Sullivan I'm a senior Financial
Analyst at the dra
and uh just to re reiterate uh the dra
does not have a position on this bill we
are here to answer uh questions we heard
that there were some questions on the
the fiscal fiscal note that we prepared
however we do also want to point out
that we do see some if the bill is to be
passed we do see some challenges in
terms of administering such as uh when
we see
some very some neighboring states taxed
the products differently compared to New
Hampshire so we do see a bit of
challenges okay how do we compare that
and find which way how would we price
the tax to set the tax rate
um and if this legislation was passed we
would hope that there was some
clarifying language to be inserted into
the build for that as well and and as
was mentioned earlier in the one of the
testimony that uh the the tax rate
setting is done on an annual basis
um so probably uh additional like
researching what other tax or other
states are doing and um having to to set
that
on a timely basis might be also slightly
um challenging
so the devil's in the details here
any questions from the committee members
one more comment was
that uh that the bill required that the
the commissioner uh
uh sort of instruct on the current use
the current usage of the funds from
nicotine taxation
um the department currently does not
um
does not have that function and we
normally once we collect the
the tax revenue that revenue is passed
on to the state treasurer and um
probably our suggestion is to consider a
a different agency who's more uh adapted
equipped with uh with the reporting on
the usage of the nicotine taxation so
that's section two of the bill is it yes
that's right yeah okay
I could see that being problematic okay
any questions from the committee members
see none thank you very much thank you
okay uh rich regario
the guts oh that's a z right okay see I
should have looked at it he didn't put
to make a little line to the Z
good morning
yeah you got to turn your mic on
hello talk close perfect my name is
Richard regazio
um I was born and raised New Hampshire
I'm a third generation retailer and my
son and daughter will be fourth
generation even though they went and got
their doctorate they're back in the
family business and uh my my business is
uh East-West Distributors which is a
little tobacco Niche
um that uh one of the few people that
still can stamp cigarettes in New
Hampshire a lot of them moved out of
state we employ I also own 10 smoke
shops we employ roughly 100 people 90 of
them live in New Hampshire
um I
I oppose this because I think it gives
up our freedom to control our pricing I
don't think that's the right way to go I
don't want to be the test State
um the business has always been a roller
coaster in the state with tobacco tax
but right now we're on the top of the
roller coaster uh thanks to Charlie
Baker in Massachusetts for doing what
they did when they come over for
cigarettes
now because they you know they ban
flavors
they buy beer they buy they go buy gas
I'm up 30 percent and if I'm up 30 the
state's got to be up
more you know what I mean the same so
they're pretty close and I just oppose
it because I think it we lose our
freedom to control pricing and we rely
on other states
and I've doubled my vehicles I've
doubled my employees I've never played
employees as much as I do today and I'm
able to you know so that's a good thing
I create jobs and um you know I'd like
to keep on expanding uh if it's it's a
vulnerable area that you never know
what's going to happen and also when
Charlie Baker raised that now you have
all these Massachusetts retailers coming
over which is providing more revenue for
the state
example the town of Seabrook had five or
six smoke shops and now we have like a
dozen they're now trying to stop another
one from opening up because it's only
like a mile where they have to sell so
it's it's been a revenue generator for
the State of New Hampshire I don't think
we should be the test state for this
bill
any questions
see none so you know Charlie Baker is my
birth brother we were both born on the
exact same day so you know should be so
mean to him all right well I call him
the best government I ever had
even though he's not my Governor but
thank you very much thank you okay one
more card uh uh Burch Scott
Brett Scott
when you cross your t's together that
looks like an H yeah so my name is Brett
Scott I'm the owner of Smokers Haven we
have 17 retail locations throughout New
Hampshire and Maine and play over 140
people
I also represent the New Hampshire
Vapors Association which is comprised of
local small business owners such as
myself throughout New Hampshire
the proposed legislation would
substantially increase select tobacco
and nicotine product taxes especially
that of vaping which would be nearly a
400 percent increase
uh by changing the tax to be slightly
lower than surrounding states it would
leave New Hampshire vulnerable to other
state legislation changes and lawmakers
that we do not elect the Department of
Revenue Administration has stated that
over 50 percent of tobacco sales in the
state of New Hampshire are out of state
buyers by increasing the tax so
drastically the incentive for
out-of-state buyers should be lost and
there is not as much of a tax advantage
over surrounding states worthwhile
enough to make the cross-border trip
consider other Commodities if you can
get fuel on your way home but the next
town over is five cents cheaper would
you drive out of the way to save five
cents
now if you could save a dollar per
gallon would you take the slight
inconvenience to save fifteen dollars on
your fill up
reducing the incentive for consumers to
spend their money here in New Hampshire
not only will hurt these businesses
directly likely resulting in closures in
hardship due to lessened demand and an
already competitive market but also will
impact other businesses in nearby areas
that benefit from cross-border consumers
coming to these areas that then stop
shop spend money and support unrelated
other local businesses the importance of
out-of-state buyers in this industry
cannot be ignored the impact of reduced
demand directly affects the state's tax
revenue and local businesses for the tax
structure plays a pivotal role in
enticing consumers to save money by
making the trip to purchase these
products here in New Hampshire compared
to their home state
I hope you will consider the impacts
that such legislation would have on New
Hampshire and oppose this legislation
okay
everybody got it thank you I do have
written testimony as well the clerk will
appreciate that thank you okay that's
all the cards I have uh online we had
one person opposed
uh Julie Smith uh the blue sheet uh we
have one person support the co-sponsor
Tom and the rest are in opposition and
they represents AFP and H New Hampshire
Grocers Association New Hampshire retail
association Altria client services and
Reynolds America are all in opposition
with that I will close the public
hearing
thank you
next one
still talk to Jim at all
right
thank you
it's amazing
okay we'll open up the public hearing on
279 and hear from representative Mooney
good morning representative Mooney
good morning Mr chairman and good
morning to members of the committee for
the record my name is representative
Maureen Mooney I'm from the town of
Merrimack that's Hillsborough County
District number 12. I'm the prime
sponsor and I'm testifying today in
support of House Bill 279 increasing the
penalty for on-premises licensees over
serving alcohol known as the Elizabeth
croak law
House Bill 279 is introduced on behalf
of the croak family of Merrimack who are
present today the bill is known as the
Elizabeth croak law in line one of the
bill
tragically Elizabeth croak of Merrimack
lost her beautiful and full life at the
age of 20. to an intoxicated driver in
April of 2021.
the bill does The Following
first
it increases the existing fine from
twenty five hundred dollars in Liquor
Commission rules
to seventy five hundred dollars
for quote serving an individual who is
visibly intoxicated
or who are reasonable and prudent person
would know is intoxicated and such
intoxicated person directly causes the
serious injury or death of another
person or persons
secondly
it changes the license suspension
to up to 30 Days quote up to 30 days
as opposed to 10 consecutive days in
Liquor Commission rules
third lastly
it requires the publishing
of the reason for the license suspension
so it would have to be posted on the
establishment's door if a license is
suspended the following verbiage quote
closed due to mandatory suspension by
the New Hampshire Liquor Commission for
over serving of alcohol in accordance
with RSA 179 colon 5.
I've worked closely with the Liquor
Commission on the language of this bill
they do have some proposed amendments
minor but important ones of which I have
absolutely no problem with that I can
distribute their suggestions
I think they'll talk about it after my
testimony one of which for example is
the publishing of the notice that it be
on exterior doors exterior doors as mine
only says doors
certainly amenable to that
with that I ask that you pass this to
become the Elizabeth croak law formally
and I'll conclude my testimony thank you
Mr chair and members for your attention
representative Vinson has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
Testimony taking my question so
um what's the magnitude of the problem
what is what is uh how how many
violations are per year
I'm gonna
for accuracy I'm going to defer that to
the Liquor Commission it could give you
a good answer thank you
okay
representative Sullivan
thank you Mr chair so I'm curious how is
it
when I read the bill it seems a little
subjective on how you decide who this is
reasonable but Prudence yeah that
somebody maybe is too drunk or
overserved but
like what is that standard so I mean I
I my my cousin she manages a barn in
North Conway and she well a restaurant
not so much of a bar but they serve
alcohol and she says that you wouldn't
believe how often they find uh like beer
cans or nips in the bathroom and so you
know if I'm the bartender in that
situation and I have served somebody
two drinks and I think they're fine but
then they came in and drank a few to
save money
back in the bathroom or in the parking
lot before they came in you know at what
point do they
at what point are they like not
responsible for something that they
actually can't control or another
example would be what if they took a
Xanax or a couple of Xanax before it
came coming in which was another example
she gave me when I called her to talk
about this bill she said that actually
happened where people had taken Xanax
came in they had one drink became a mess
they didn't quite understand what was
going on they found out later that they
the person had taken Xanax and they had
that in the system and interact with the
alcohol so I could see it in that case
it didn't go bad but I could see that
something like that happening where
the restaurants held accountable for
something that's really not their fault
so how does the bill deal with something
like that
thank you for the question and it's an
excellent one I had the same thoughts
coming up with this bill and working
with the croak family on it which is by
the way is going on almost two years
I would answer that question by saying
this first of all I would direct you to
current law RSA 179 colon 5 Roman one
that's standard
who a reasonable and prudent person
would know is intoxicated is already in
current law
my bill relates to the fines and to the
publication
and the suspension
not the standard
standards already there
that's the first part of my answer the
second part is to inquire with the
Liquor Commission they're the experts
let's face it and see what their
thoughts are with regards to what makes
that standard and how it's enforced okay
thank you
okay representative Terry thank you Mr
chairman uh forgive me if I've missed
this in Statewide news broadcasts or
articles
um but what what's the the driver here
in on on the desire to uh to stiffen uh
the penalties
um have have there been violations and
and you believe that the bar needs to be
raised for violations and also for
deterrence purposes uh what why this why
now
thank you for the question
I would say that the um impetus for the
bill
is the croak family and their personal
experience with this
and their journey through the process of
watching uh The Liquor Commission
enforce the current laws
and in my discussions with the croak
family whom you'll hear from this
morning
they have expressed to me concern
that the fine was not enough
that publication was not adequate
and that suspension timing was also not
adequate
following please further questions so
this is essentially the family the
affected family to which you to whom you
have already made reference and not any
particular incidents where there have
been violations and it is the it is the
opinion of of some that the bar should
be raised this is this is the family
only correct
and and and the opinion of others who
may be supportive of this for whatever
reasons
yes I've only worked with the family in
the Liquor Commission on this film
however I know that an incident was
highly publicized just as recent as last
Thanksgiving
very similar to this one I've not worked
with that family nor have I followed
that family's Journey
like I have the croaks
thank you
okay oh representative
yeah thank you for taking my question
the thing I keep thinking about is a
person who comes into a bar and maybe
has 10 vodka tonics and there's no
visible
signs of alcoholism they go out and have
a have a an accident where somebody gets
injured or killed and I mean this is and
as an example another example I I was
talking to my colleagues about it I'm
five feet tall if I have literally like
a quarter glass of wine I I'm
intoxicated which is why unfortunately I
can't drink very much so I mean how do
we deal with it should there also be a
cut off limit I mean does it make common
sense that somebody shouldn't be
drinking 10 vodka tonics and then going
out and driving even if they're not
visibly intoxicated
certainly a good question a good concern
again I would defer to The Liquor
Commission my bill my work with the
croak family has been on the fines and
the penalties that they have experienced
in a very personal way
but your questions are very valid I'm
curious myself
but I would say let's ask those that are
most familiar and have enforced current
law
related to these fines and penalties and
determinations of the standards and the
like and get their opinion on it
representative Ammon
thank you Mr chair and nice to see you
representative Mooney
um in your testimony you stated that
current law is 10 consecutive days for
the suspension
um and the bill says the bill says up to
30 days so my question is
does this allow for suspension of fewer
than 10 days which is current law
and is that judgment call left up to the
department thanks
okay thank you representative for the
question once again a good one I
referred in my testimony to Liquor
Commission rule 603.3
and yes I interpret it as you say up to
30 days
that could be 10 that could be less my
interpretation is it's a Max of 30 but
no more than
okay representative Cole
thank you Mr chair
just to touch on the subject a little
bit more I'm looking under the
methodology and then the first offense
says 10-day suspension and then a second
offense it says 30 to 60 days in my mind
that would make it mandatory
30 to 60 days in a second offense
so does this bill take the teeth out of
it
if you don't mind me asking what exactly
are you looking at the methodology here
on the back page
says as it stands right now
10-day suspension 2500 fine
and then the second offense five
thousand dollar suspension 30 to 60 days
for second events
to me that would seem mandatory
those are actually up too
those are up to
yeah that's up to
okay I've been counseled that someone
may have a better answer than I could
give thank you though for that uh
question thank you
great thanks
so uh before I commit commission I think
we'd like to hear from David and Lynn
good morning and I'm very sorry about
your loss
I gotta figure out how to work this
um never done anything like this before
just have to keep the mic pretty close
okay if you notice you can't see my
mouth can you hear me okay now
um
my name is David Crowe
from Merrimack New Hampshire this is my
wife Lynn
and on April 15th
2021 we lost our only daughter
we have four children and Elizabeth was
our youngest she was 20 years old
she was killed by a drunk driver
who was traveling Northbound on the
southbound side of every Turnpike
he was traveling 80 miles an hour and my
daughter was heading southbound where he
hit her head on at Mile 16.6 she died
instantly
she had three older brothers
James
Matthew and Nathan
my daughter Elizabeth loved life she was
a confident mature 20 year old woman
with a larger than life personality that
spread love and joy to everyone around
her
Elizabeth was a graduate of Bishop
guertin High School
with many accomplishments
she was a honor roll student
involved in numerous clubs and
activities Bishop curtain varsity
basketball team
at the time of her death she was a
sophomore at University of Massachusetts
majoring in kinesiology
with an interest in medicine
on Wednesday April 14th
between the hours of 6 and 6 30 a group
of individuals in their mid-20s
from Windham New Hampshire entered a bar
or excuse me entered a restaurant
well-known restaurant in Windham New
Hampshire
multiple bottles of wine were set on a
table
with new no supervision
it was reported that the deceased
defendant involved in the head-on
collision had consumed a bottle of
Joshua Joshua Cabernet per witness
statements
at approximately nine o'clock
the group arrived at another restaurant
located in Windham New Hampshire
just off the highway
bartender knew this group they visited
this restaurant often
the gentleman that killed my daughter
was a two beer a night drinker
a social drinker
by the time he had arrived at this
restaurant he had already drank at least
a bottle of wine
the bartender who knew this defendant
served him three mixed tall drinks
one was a vodka and soda
one was a vodka with Red Bull
and one was a Captain Morgan and Coke
each one of those drinks had two shots
of alcohol in it
80 proof
the bartender looked at this individual
and said how are you getting home
she then served him
a green tea shot
which had a half a shot of Jameson
Whiskey
and a half a shot of peach schnapps
she was asked in the investigation how
she measured these strengths
and she told the investigator she she
would free pour a six second rule
the human body metabolizes a drink an
hour
which is an ounce and a half
a shot
a five ounce glass of wine or a 12 ounce
beer
the bartender that night served this
gentleman
a total of 60 ounces of 80 proof liquor
plus a shot
in 90 minutes
at 11 44
there are numerous requests to the state
police that there was an erratic driver
on the road
and to be on the lookout
as a hazardous operator
roughly 15 minutes later he would pass
through the Bedford tolls
and proceed to turn his car around
traveling north in the southbound lane
narrowly missing head-on collision with
another woman
before hitting my only daughter's car at
80 miles an hour at Miles 16.6
my daughter died instantly with a car
fully engulfed in fire
toxicology report of the defendant
indicated blood alcohol concentration of
0.224
or almost three times the legal limit
The Liquor Commission report States
aggregate aggravating factors of failure
to train employees in liquor education
classes
failure to take advantage of classes
offered by New Hampshire Commission
failure to monitor the amount of alcohol
served to a patron negligent service of
alcohol beverages person to RSA 507-5
semicolon 4.
serving and defending four drinks in
less than 90 minutes
I lost my only daughter
The Establishment received a 2500 fine
and a loss of liquor license for 10 days
on November 21st the bar and Grill's
response to their license suspension was
we will be on holiday in over November
22nd to December 1st
reopening December 2nd with regular
business hours
our hard-working staff has been in it
seven days a week all summer long and is
looking forward to this time
we hope you understand
see you upon reopening thank you for
your support
happy holidays to you and yours
they showed no remorse
no one was held accountable
or prosecuted
the bartender fled town shortly
thereafter and she now lives in New York
they turned a tragedy into a time of
employee celebration
my daughter Elizabeth's life was special
my daughter's life mattered
she had her whole life ahead of her
a bright light who always thought of
others gone forever
she was supposed to graduate this May
5th from the University of Massachusetts
I will never see that day
I will never have the opportunity to
escort her down the aisle
I will never have the opportunity to see
her have children
only memories remain
foreign
ask you to support this bill
thank you very much for sharing that
with us and is it possible that we can
have that text when I'm sure it's in the
permanent record yeah I just need I I
need to make some copies okay it's fine
representative Burroughs
thank you again for sharing your story
and and um
um I I'm so sorry to hear this story
it's it's pretty it's pretty horrific
um my question for you is this bill
concentrates on somebody visibly
intoxicated and going back to the point
I made earlier
given what you said with the amount of
liquor that this this young man had over
a 90-minute period would you
would you think it would be helpful to
have an amendment into the bill to also
monitor amounts
um because the bartender this in the
particular in this instance it seemed
like it was one bartender and knew
exactly how much was being consumed
I think it's just a combination of
things I mean training has to be there I
don't you know in none of the employees
there were trained
I mean the bottom line is it's the
responsibility I mean it's a licensed
establishment it's their responsibility
to make sure that any Patron that leaves
that building is not intoxic is not
intoxicated and they they did not follow
through with that
follow up for the question so again do
you think particularly in this instance
that there should have been a limit set
by The Establishment or or whatever that
no you've had you've had your limit
we're shutting you off even if the
person wasn't visibly intoxicated
I would leave that up to the Liquor
Commission I don't have an answer for
that
thank you for coming in
appreciate it Mr chairman oh we I
believe I can direct my question to you
so do I understand that licensing is
required but training is not required
under state law uh training is required
that's why that violation of of that was
why that when the penalties was was
livid because they had failed to do the
training had employees properly trained
and the maximum under the law we we've
already heard is 10 days and 2500
correct thank you
thank you very much
okay chief
and Danielle Elston
for the record
um as most of you know my name is Mark
armaganian I'm the chief and director of
the New Hampshire Liquor commission's
Division of enforcement licensing with
me here today uh again as most of you
know is Deputy Chief and deputy director
uh Danielle Elston
um
first and foremost and I I can say
a couple things here before testimony or
within testimony
um I commend the croak family this was
so brave coming up here today
um with that in mind uh representative
Mooney and and her colleagues you guys
uh you folks uh who who are giving the
opportunity for this family and us to
come before you to tell you what we
believe are shortfalls
there were a lot of great questions that
some of you saw me nodding in the back
we can answer every one of them and and
probably give you some more insight on
top of that please with us I know this
group has never been bashful
um
nobody's going to be slighted by your
questions please ask us the toughest
questions you have because this is so
compelling of an issue and such a
horrific incident that occurred that we
need to do something about it so thank
you for that moment
um
uh this this issue has been so
compelling David and I met over the
phone and and had talked a handful of
times uh all ending in a very emotional
SOB
um those of us who even don't have
children can really relate to what this
family has gone through
um
I will read you a position paper that
I'd like to enter
um uh as that and also
um we have worked diligently with uh
representative Mooney
um on some of the things that as we all
know in this commission this title 13 is
a permissive uh title if it doesn't say
it it doesn't exist it it you can't do
it so so with that in mind
um there were things that just needed
they were defined there were terms that
were defined that we needed to just
for a lack of a better term cleanup but
the liquor commissioned wholeheartedly
uh 150 percent uh supports this bill
um
and increasing the penalties for
on-premise over serving
um again I commend uh representative
Mooney and the croak family uh for for
just being brave and and bringing this
to attention this shortfall of
accountability on the part of licensees
and death resulting and serious bodily
injury which are defined in statute
uh in these in these cases the proposed
changes on existing which you have
brought up on existing legislation
um will create the deterrent needed to
ensure that we are doing everything
right to keep our communities and the
industry safe while protecting as you
have heard me say before our vulnerable
age group
the citizens of our state
rely on us to make sure when they are
traveling the highways and byways of
this great state or they're residing in
their communities that our servers are
serving correctly our serving
responsibly and those that are consuming
are doing that in the same fashion
at that point our training segments that
we offer that you've heard me testify to
time and time again
um are are just that and and they are
very extremely robust and robust Tool uh
a means of not only talking about those
mitigating and aggravating factors that
we have to take into account while we do
these investigations but looking at what
outward signs of intoxication which I
know was brought up
um which which is a
um a uh a built-in defense to the Statue
um so we'll we'll talk about all that as
we as we continue on here and Danielle
will give us a a great oversight of that
um
in conclusion with
um what we look at when it comes to
Lizzie's case
um when I walked in the door I I worked
half of my career at State Police those
28 years that I was over there working
homicide and I always said to the people
that worked under my command we work on
behalf of the victims of this state
somebody has to speak on behalf of them
they're not here to speak on their
behalf we are in doing that as we walk
into this horrific incident that
happened with Lizzy
we see a driver driving the wrong way on
the highway we
have a head-on collision that
was so horrific with a fire that
there was there was no way of either
party surviving that crash at 80 miles
an hour the deterrent and and rightfully
so somebody brought up to turn the
deterrent needs to be there to hold
these people responsible we have
6400 licensees in this state
and Danielle will talk about it but last
year numbers wise
three
we held accountable under this statue
that came into this there for the most
part the majority is doing it right but
we have to keep in mind that there is
that small percentage that might not do
it right that we have to have that
deterrent there to hold them accountable
but in the in the interest of fairness
and in the interest of doing a thorough
investigation that will for a lack of a
better term weed out these the issues
that were rightfully brought up about
again mitigating circumstances and
aggravating circumstances outward signs
of intoxication because we're not
talking people that are are are trained
like police officers behind the counter
of a of a bars serving
um we're talking lay people we're
talking about our neighbors and uh what
is built into the law is that outward
signs of intoxication average outward
signs of intoxication if they are not
being readily seen that is a defense
and and rightfully so or wrong
wrongfully so it is the way the statute
was written so
um with that in mind I I'd like to to
offer Danielle the opportunity to speak
on this this is an extremely emotional
um uh circumstance it's an extremely uh
emotionally for me to testify on this
because I can easily plug my family into
this every day of the week same age so
it really hits home so I appreciate the
time that each and every one of you are
giving to this uh listening and and
again I can't uh thank representative
Mooney and and her colleagues
um who who really cared enough to put
pen to paper on this to bring it in
front of this commission and thank you
very much
good morning I'm going to try to uh
rapid fire answer some of the questions
that came up during the previous
testimony because I know there was
several different ones
um so in terms of how many licensees
affect you heard the chief in 2022 there
was three three licensees that would
fall under this seven in 2021 since 2008
there's been a total of 26 cases that
have resulted in serious bottle Lindsay
or death 15 of those were death
resulting
in terms of the statute in the language
as it sits right now the statute is
currently the standard is visible signs
of intoxication or a reasonable
imprudent person would know was
intoxicated in that reasonable imprudent
person standard we consider rate of
service in our investigation what were
the drinks sold what was the size of the
drinks what was the alcohol content in
the drinks how fast they were served and
how fast they were consumed those are
all things that are investigated and
considered when we're doing these
investigations and that falls the rate
of service falls under the reasonable
important person standard in terms of
the circumstances that that you had
brought up that individuals might be
bringing alcohol into the establishment
or taking you know
um intoxicating medication prior to
those are also things that are
investigated in our investigations so we
do in most of these cases conduct close
to what a 24-hour background would be
from a police department standard we
look at what they consumed prior to
going there are they taking medications
the effects those medications could have
we look at their regular behaviors we
talk to friends and family as to how
they normally acted were they acting
differently in the establishment so all
those are are considered in the
investigation of if somebody was visibly
intoxicated or that a reasonable
important person would know is
intoxicated and we have had
circumstances where on face value it
would appear that the establishment did
over serve the person but the
investigation concluded that they had
you know been drinking at a prior
establishment and or taken medication
which then the establishment wasn't held
accounted accountable because we
recognize that the visible signs were
not not from their rate of service or
the service of alcohol but from the
medication that they took
these are all things that are also
addressed in our server and management
training those trainings are provided
monthly throughout the state they're
also available online to all licensed
establishments they're free of charge so
we the majority of that training
addresses visible signs of intoxication
and the reasonable imprudence person's
standard
the amendment that you have does address
first offenses and then multiple
offenses after that so currently in rule
you're corrected as the first offense is
the 10 consecutive days with the twenty
five hundred dollar fine and then it
moves to a 30 to 60 day suspension the
amendment increases it from to a minimum
of 30 days
for the first offense but allows for up
to revocation for multiple offenses
um did I miss any any more questions
that I I don't I hope I covered them all
we'll start with representative Sullivan
since that was his first question thank
you um so
I do have a question on one scenario
that we haven't talked about is so what
happens if you have a bar that has or an
establishment that has multiple bars in
it and so therefore you have a bartender
on one side a bartender or another maybe
there's a third or fourth bar I mean
I've been to larger cities anyways where
there's seven bars within one
establishment and so theoretically if
you went to each one of those seven bars
I'm sticking up thinking of a specific
one I've been to in my past in Chicago
which obviously wouldn't apply here
being New Hampshire but if you had a
similar type of place in the state of
New Hampshire and somebody goes to each
one of those bars and gets one drink is
there a way for a bartender to be held
accountable if they thought they were
maybe giving that person the first drink
and it's a busy bar and you know they
don't have a chance to really examine
them because there's three or four
hundred people in there so they're just
going as fast as they can and that
person's now had their seventh drink or
maybe they've gone and had two drinks at
each bar and so everybody thinks oh this
is just their second drink second time
I've seen them I mean it seems like that
would be over serving from The
Establishment perspective but how would
they really monitor something like that
and and how would you guys deal with
that
so yeah there's possibility that the
establishment could be held accountable
for the over service of that individual
um we tend we have we recommend
responsible business practices but we
don't manage or regulate the way the
licensee runs their business so if a
license you choose chooses to have
several bars that is a situation that we
would bring up to them but it's up to
the licensee to determine the best way
for them to manage their establishment
so that somebody does not get over
served but there is a very likely
possibility that the more the larger
your establishment is the more the more
bars you have the more points of service
that you have that there is the
possibility that an over service is more
likely so if someone were to go into the
establishment and go to Every bar in
Rapid Fire and and you know be served to
drink and they at some point become
visibly intoxicated or the rate of
service was Nest that a reasonable
person should have known then yes it is
a possibility that the establishment
could be held responsible for that
representative Terry
thank you
um
I was the one who questioned and about
deterrence raising the bar for
deterrence I'm also concerned about
plugging holes
that may exist and as I'm listening to
all of this I'm hearing that number one
the the the bartender
fled to New York is is that is that
correct and I'm wondering
um are there and even in regardless of
whether you know that's to be the case
are there tools that you have in your
toolbox
such that you can make the the person
this individual would you hypothetically
been able to make that person
accountable
for the actions that she took uh on that
evening and more broadly
um in response to the question that I
posed to the chairman the chairman
responded to me that training is
required as a part of Licensing
do you have the tools to enforce
penalties upon institutions
establishments if they are found to have
not
completed training requirements for
their employees and is there such a
range so that you have the opportunity
because we can't we can't uh legislate
for every particular situation but is
there a range such that you could
administer a fine or actually in a
situation like this have considered
revoking the license of the
establishment because the owner of the
establishment did not follow through and
require that the employee actually
receive the required training
thank you
So yeah thank you for your question um
right now as the statue is in regards to
training a member of management has to
attend training prior to the license
being issued that is the only statutory
requirement for training for licensees
so the licensee can designate uh what
themselves or a member of management to
attend a training within 45 days of the
license being issued there is no
requirement for employees of the
establishment to attend training
well
for the question in in light of the
statistics and uh that you have cited
and the particular cases over the last
several years do you believe that that
might be a useful tool in your toolbox
to be able to require that
establishments required training of
their employees I I think that's a great
question representative and I I can't
tell you how much I appreciate it uh it
creates another conversation
and and a very good one
um I'd I'd like to hear about the impact
on industry but anytime there are
legislative mandatory uh uh hard decks
let's call them
um uh that that fortifies a training
element to do it right I think that's
good business
um we in the last six years
um that that's our platform I know you
know that
um we we have been successful in doing
business that way
um
as you know also that as we as we're
looking at the statutes that are in
title uh 13 that and rule that there are
some that we we want to make better and
this is one of them uh when I walked in
the door and I walked into a case on the
Seacoast uh involving one of our license
establishments that was three years old
at the time
um and you ask yourself why three years
because prosecution criminal prosecution
had asked us to wait on our
administrative role
um we we weren't doing business like
we're doing it now we were doing it to
our administrative ability
uh which is a preponderance of the of
the evidence and not by the way of
Beyond A Reasonable Doubt because I felt
coming from the traditional world of law
enforcement that we were going to end up
in court a lot and and if we were and if
we had law enforcement throughout this
state Municipal law enforcement and
State
uh buying into the way we were doing
business then we were going to have to
do business and ultra high standard and
do our due diligence in investigating
every possible means of how something
either went right
or how it went wrong it's not always
negative like this case
and and there have been several
establishments that we have cleared of
wrongdoing when it looked like they were
doing it wrong and they weren't because
of
prescription medication or
non-prescription medication being on
board
uh of the the target of the
investigation so
so yes I a long way to get to your
answer but yes
um I believe so
thank you okay representative uh post
has a question
my question was thank you very much and
thank you Mr chairman
um my question was answered
um but I have a follow-up to that why is
it up to 30 days why isn't it the 30
days right off the bat because that's a
huge deterrent to have your
establishment closed
for that long though those were those
thank you for your question
representative
um
amongst as you know how these go
um a lot of conversations I could tell
you a lot of conversations went into
what you have before you and what what
is proposed uh by representative Mooney
um that was one of the things that was
spoken about uh in our conversations
um I don't know if we're there yet to be
quite honest about it uh totally
transparent but this is a very firm step
forward in doing business right
and and that deterrent is is real
um if the deterrent of 30 days up to 30
days is out there I believe that our
licensees who aren't doing business
right and I'm I I will attest in any
court of law or in front of any
committee that a majority of our
licensees do it right and and I'm very
humbled and proud of that because
they've very quickly bought into what
what we have spoken to them about that
that training and and education is
Paramount and and good and reasonable
and responsible service
um
but with that in mind those were
conversations that were brought up uh
during during talks over this bill and
and we felt that this was a solid step
forward
I can't follow up okay so who makes the
determination of how many days 10 days
15 days 20 days
great question representative so
um we look at the mitigating uh of
course and aggravating factors
um in determining what time we were
going to select for uh imposing
accountability uh in any case
um and and I don't know why this part of
the process gets lost sometimes there is
due process in all of our cases so even
though we are pushing for let's say we
do 30 days a licensee has due process
and can go into our hearing process in
front of our hearings
officer and and plead their case of why
they believe that we we went too high
let's say or or you know the the
accountability or the what they did
wrong doesn't equal the accountability
that they've been afforded
um with that in mind again it's good
business
allowing our our business partners to
have that ability to come in and state
their case
um and and that happens on not often
um because we don't have these cases
often but we are prepared for those
cases as often as they may happen and I
hope they happen zero uh but we're we're
prepared to handle those
okay representative Gibbs
thank you uh can you tell us what the
penalties are in neighboring states for
over serving alcohol
we can find that out for you I don't
have that information readily available
for you um Massachusetts is not a
controlled State
um so their penalties are typically
regulated by the local
licensing boards
um but Vermont
um is a controlled State and we'll have
something similar as well as Maine so we
can get the we can get that for you
thank you all right so I remind the
members we will be going to subcommittee
on this bill all right representative
Ammon is next
thank you Mr chair thank you for your
testimony and taking our questions
I just want to be clear for the record
are you promoting or uh
talking about the amendment that's
before us yes okay
um so this is your position on what the
bill should look like correct all right
so my question has to do with um
uh allowing latitude to the Department
comparing current statute with what
you're proposing here
and going back to the methodology
section I think representative Cole
pointed out
there's three different tiers to the
penalties in current statute
um
the first one is a fine of 2500 10 day
suspension that's the first offense
correct the second offense is 5 000 and
a suspension of 30 to 60 days
so 30 to 60 that gives you that Latitude
correct correct and then the an
additional offense so a third offense
would be
revocation of the license correct so you
stated that the title is a permissive
chapter
so if if you're if it states what the
department is allowed to do you can't do
anything else besides that so
those are three tiers the third one is a
mandatory revocation and the current or
in the amendment that you're proposing
it talks about a fine of seventy five
hundred dollars so from
2500 first offense
5000 second offense now it's a mandatory
7 500 for each offense is that correct
am I reading that right correct
and then it says up to 30 days so you
your discretion is 0 to 30 days
of suspension
which is different
and then it says up to revocation so
according to this language there could
be ten offenses and revocation still is
not mandatory wherein current statute
it's mandatory on the third offense is
that is that correct in the plane
reading
and I'm choosing 10 as a number you know
as a yeah in plain reading correct you
are correct in that
um
the so 179 57 uh requires that
aggravating and mitigating factors are
taking into account during the issuance
of penalties and or suspensions
so
um that is the that's the those are the
factors that are are included when we're
looking at what those penalties would be
so part of the issue you have with your
first offense and that that is the
penalty no matter what doesn't matter
what your aggravating factors are it
doesn't matter what your mitigating
factors are everybody's getting this
that's fine and then but also the
closure of the business those are part
of the same correct correct so in the
current one that you're reading the 10
days and 2500 that's the penalty right
no matter what doesn't matter the
circumstances doesn't matter the
mitigating factors the license does
doesn't matter to the aggravating
factors a license C has it doesn't allow
for anything other than the 10 days and
the 2500.
um so the idea of this is that this
allows for those aggravating and
mitigating factors to be taken into
account with a maximum of 30. anything
after that
um because again for us it's concerning
if you're going to have a second offense
that results in serious bodily injury or
death that would allow us to again
assess the situation the case specific
facts account for those aggravating
communicating factors and determine are
we at a point where they can continue to
operate or is revocation necessary at
this point so just back to my
hypotheticals for the question please
you could say no
but I guess a
can you shut the business down
is it in the statue that you can just
shut it down can you just pull their
license because you just say this is so
egregious
I don't see that in here no
all right so clearly this statute needs
to be fixed
okay everybody all right clearly we need
to fix the statute so we are going to
work on it but we're getting a little
behind on the time and I'm a little
worried that that we're not going to
solve everything at this moment at this
hearing but I think what we've got is we
know there's a problem here and we've
got to fix this
okay representative McAleer do you agree
I agree but I would like to make a
comment if I could this is a would you
believe this is actually a would you
believe and it goes along with
representative Terry I actually queried
a bartender recently about any training
that they had and uh she looked at me
like what are you kidding me I asked if
management had ever said anything about
this and the answer was no and the other
answer was well it gets so busy in here
we got you know five or six different
waitresses waiters around
um it would be very difficult to monitor
so my feeling is that this uh this could
be a deterrent or should be a deterrent
to get management to uh to talk about it
at least and not and actually I really
think it the training should be
mandatory for for bartenders thank you
okay we all said everyone
all right we will close the public
hearing and uh I would say a note that
um
uh the over overnight we had two in
support and three opposed
and uh the blue blue sheets is uh
everyone is in support that includes
representative Boyd Kate fry from new
Futures Elizabeth sergeant from
Association Chiefs of police and
representative Cahill and representative
let's see all right with that I will
close the public hearing
and give everybody a moment here so that
we can
reset for our next public hearing
okay
foreign
you can do it later John
John do it later
okay we'll open up the public hearing on
House Bill 612 from and hear from
representative patusek
good morning Mr chairman and members of
the Commerce and consumer affairs
committee for the record representative
John petusic uh Rockingham 13 Derry New
Hampshire
HP 612 I'm presenting for a constituent
the constituent's daughter is supposed
to be here to uh
uh give you information on this this
bill will a allow wine manufacturers to
give a bottle as a sample into certain
conditions two changes the fee and tax
structure and wine sold in the state and
exempts a certain volume of wine from
taxes for home use
uh
this is being presented for Mr Mike
Apollo of Apollo Vineyards and his
daughter Kristen I believe is should be
here to testify
so thank you for your attention great
thank you
so uh once you also while you're over
there making your card out make a card
out for her
yes so you can then come up and testify
yeah yeah just hand it hand it just hand
it to the first person yep you're good
get into the hot seat which I assume it
must be very warm by now
and hold the mic close to you
hold that mic close to you there you go
all right you're on good morning my name
is Kristen Apollo Stacy and um here to
justify for my dad
um and Apollo Vineyards and I'm really
shaky really oh sorry okay
um thank you for hearing my testimony
today I could be not I could not be
there in person so I asked my daughter
Kristen to read this testimony I'm
asking that you hear and understand when
the open minds towards supporting local
farming
I realized some education is in order
because the Taxation and fee structure
levied on wine producers is spread
across multiple rsas many of my
Representatives who I've discussed this
legislation were unaware of implications
of the current law
one of the details is a fuscated in the
current law by calling an excise tax a
five percent fee in the RSA
currently wiring rates are paying five
percent on Top Line Sales to The Liquor
Commission and we're required to add 8.5
meals tax anything consumed at the
winery both food and wine tastings this
sets attacks on the glass of wine at
13.5 percent a five percent portion
amounts to a hidden sales tax in 2012
the Department of Revenue stated started
demanding meals tax on wine samples
consumed at The Tasting Room this was
without any legislation or recourse to
the wineries now required to pay it
the current state of Taxation on wine
producers is unsustainable if you want
to grow the wine industry in the state
only one Vineyard and Winery in the
state of New Hampshire of which I'm
aware has been produced purchased from a
founder two other wineries closed when
their Founders decided to move on one
Vineyard is was torn out this is a tough
sell point for people wanting to enter
this business
the brewery business by contrast is
thriving the state because they're taxed
at a reasonable level does this mean we
should tax breweries more definitely not
they are providing full-time employment
for hundreds of people by eliminating
wine catering and restaurant jobs I
would estimate between 50 to 70
full-time employees are employed in New
Hampshire wineries many of these are
owners themselves I am one full-time
person I'm the only full-time person at
my Winery
also by contrast no significant raw
materials for beer or beer are grown in
New Hampshire planting of wine groups
are expanding every year the founders of
several of the largest wineries in the
state have paved the way with wine
Styles and grape varieties that they can
grow here and support viable businesses
all of the varieties on my farm are
grown without chemical sprays in fact
the winery was just recently recognized
by the first sustainable craft beverage
Winery in New Hampshire by nhdes due to
the environmental practices
some of this inequity between beer and
wine has come about because the current
rsas for the wine industry are spread
across multiple sections of RSA 178 the
fee and tax Schedule should be
rationalized and made Equitable for
similar alcoholic beverages taxes should
be less listed as taxes the RSA 178
colon 8 5 fee is actually an excise tax
for example a 750 milliliter bottle of
beer at 11 alcohol sold by volume at 13
produced in a brewery in Dairy is taxed
at six cents a 750 milliliter bottle of
wine at 11 alcohol
sold at 13 is taxed at 65 cents
the wine is grown on the same property
as the winery by the way wine is taxed
at a percentage of bottle price beer is
taxed by volume you can see the more
than 10 discrepancy in the tax and the
graphic
shown here
our most current expensive wine at
thirty dollars a bottle has a 1.50
excise tax on it
I would like to refer to RSA 425 colon 2
the Granite State Farm to Plate food
policy and principles quotes agriculture
in New Hampshire represents a vital part
of both States rural and urban economies
and the larger Food Systems that
connected with the state's local and
Regional economies and the public
another quote support of local food
economies is vital to Public Health and
our of our residents and viability and
liability of our communities
this legislation has gone to Great
Lengths to support New Hampshire dairy
industry while significantly
significantly taxing the New Hampshire
wine industry both wine growing and
dairy businesses are agriculture
the tax structure in place for wine is
weighing down on emergency emergency
emerging businesses
the wine is wine is known worldwide as a
prime prime Agricultural Product most
able to reflect the place in which it
has grown it's a source of Agriculture
tourism that brings thousands of people
into our state these agritourists spend
money in restaurants fueling stations
and other shops and yes they stop at the
New Hampshire liquor and wine outlets as
well as they are here
several New Hampshire wineries including
mine have recognized International
medals on wines grown and produced here
we are getting recognized
I estimate The Vineyards planning
planned this year in Rockingham County
should increase by 20 or more Acres the
founders of several of the older
existing wineries have paved the way by
figuring out what will grow here and
what we'll sell is wine
our best producing grape and dairy
produces 5.5 tons of grapes per acre
grapevines are perennial plant that
sequesters carbon in the soil it's a
clean and green business the public is
thirsty for locally grown wines
I'm actively working with fruit farmers
to plant varieties of grapes that can
turn into wines increasing production
means more jobs for both farm and Winery
lower carbon usage for wine production
and the development of full career
Fields within the state carbon usage is
decreased with great when grapes are
grown to where they are turned into wine
in other states wine excise Texas is
levied volume in California that's still
wine is taxed at 20 cents per gallon and
30 cents per gallon for sparkling wines
Federal excise tax on the line for small
producers is only 7 cents per gallon for
still one my annual federal excise tax
bill for wine is only about 20 percent
of my current annual New Hampshire
excise tax
um
having current limits of consumption on
the RSA are not constructive we are now
required to have food in order to serve
more than a single glass of wine by the
glass we have 15 wines on our menu we
legally serve two ounces of each wine to
a single person as a tasting this is 30
ounces of wine more than a bottle we
would never do such a thing
our staff is trained not to over serve
customers and turn away intoxicated
people arriving at the winery it is the
responsibility of each owner to ensure
the rules are followed the key one being
that customers are not overserved
customers often often arrive at our
Winery that have already been to served
elsewhere we turn them away offered to
call them an Uber and produce or produce
a designated driver
if you read our Google one star reviews
you'll see how unhappy some of them are
the limits should be reasonable ones
two six ounce glasses of wine or a
bottle for two people nearly identical
pores of wine for a couple on a date
for people enjoying a farm setting such
as ours this makes them repeat customers
I realize I haven't touched on some of
the issues within HP 612 and also
believe that others should be discussed
to summarize my request call a tax
attacks in the RSA excise tax is
currently called a five percent fee nhlc
auditing web page uses the term tax on
their web page
elimination of the double taxation on
samples and e-wine served by removing
the excise tax paid to nhlc in favor of
the meals tax
allow for couples or larger groups to
enjoy a bottle of wine at the winery to
be at a parody with neighboring states
especially Massachusetts
drop the excise tax on wine make it
Equitable to the Brewing industry even
50 cents a gallon is much lower than we
were paying five percent on Top Line
Sales as a hidden sales tax Lord the
lower the number the better
exempt why I'm removed from the bond for
family use to be parody with fertile or
law federal law
other changes that were not included in
the current draft of the bill
please rename wine manufacturer to
winery in the rsas one must per ferment
wine in the state in order to bottle and
sell it this is different than liquor
manufacturers which is a very different
sort of business
example of fabrizia brings in vodka and
makes limoncello New Hampshire law is
only a place that I can find that calls
Winery wine manufacture
Federal regular Regulators call my
Winery a winery everyone else in the
world a winery is a winery
move all fees and taxes into the wine
law RSA 178 colon 8 labeling them
appropriately by supporting this
legislation you will be helping to
support New Hampshire farms and families
thank you Mike Apollo
you made it you need it good job
any questions yeah so I just want to let
you know that uh it was very intriguing
to read this is for someone who's been
around here a long time and to uh we we
have actually in the beer industry you
know we have Nanos which are not fewer
manufacturers you know beverage
manufacturers they're a nano so clearly
uh a a farmer who's making wine and has
no idea intent to bottle it and have it
sold through the Liquor Commission in
the first place okay then you are in my
mind you are a nano
two all right well why Nano and so I
would say that we would definitely want
to address this issue and and uh
thank you for bringing the bringing it
to our attention thank you for your time
today yeah
great thank you thank you okay now
Liquor Commission
well I'm sure we'll agree with just what
I just said
thank you Mr chairman committee members
again mark armagedian Chief and director
of Liquor commission's Division of
enforcement licensing with me here today
is Lieutenant Matt Culver who is in
charge of our administrative Services uh
who has oversight of Licensing
thank you chairman and committee members
again my name is Matthew Culver I'm a
lieutenant with administrative services
for the New Hampshire Liquor Commission
division of enforcement and Licensing
certainly we appreciate this bill coming
forward in in the testimony provided by
Apollo Vineyards
um we are very committed to the
Partnerships with our licensees and
looked at having all of these issues
addressed
um to give you a uh systematic approach
here to the impact that these changes
would have
um starting first with the language of
changing uh the sample size from the
five ounce to six ounce
a standard uh 750 milliliter bottle of
wine is approximately 25 ounces so with
increasing this to the six ounces for
two people that's two glasses of wine
per each person that's 24 ounces that's
an entire bottle of wine there and I'm
sure that was the intent of increasing
it from the five to six ounces
in addition to that the next section
here which states the full unopened
bottle wines of groups of two or more
persons of legal drinking age
that's increasing the number of bottles
of wine that can be served to uh
individuals of groups of two or more
with no limit on that so
I think what should be examined here is
by the legislators is the intent of the
sampling
right so what this essentially is doing
is making a wine bar
instead of a sample the intent always
was interpreted of the samples for B to
be promotional to be able to sample the
product before buying it
we're moving away from that in this
legislation into a a wine bar now I will
keep uh everybody informed here with as
Provisions that already exist in the
statute that each wine manufacturer has
an option of obtaining an on-premises
license which is a restaurant license
this would alleviate that they wouldn't
be required to get the on-premises
license right which has the requirements
of uh food requirements in in such they
would just be able to operate
a wine bar under these the provisions of
this statute this change in the statute
moving along in the changes um starting
with the notwithstanding uh any other
provision allow open and unfinished
bottles of wine provided this is
referring to the transportation of the
uh open bottles of wine
and this is standard language that
exists in other statutes it's just a
legal way of being able to transport
open bottles of wine
moving on to paragraph four uh in
reference to the status in the uh the um
fee changes
um We examined the 2021 figures
relative to the revenue and in 2021
for the wine manufacturers
uh the division collected
three hundred thousand three hundred
sixty seven thousand ninety five dollars
in in Revenue
um for
the wine that was produced based on the
existing language of the uh
five percent of the sales
if the proposed tax structure was in
place for the same time frame the taxes
that would have been collected during
the same time is 47 790.
so that's a reduction of approximately
87 percent in revenue or
three hundred and nineteen thousand
dollars
continuing on with the wine sales
consumed on the premises under paragraph
three shall be exempt from the tax and
subject to the uh meals and rooms tax
under RSA 78a
if this was enacted it would equate to
approximately another one percent or
thirty six hundred dollar loss in
Revenue
and finally the addition of paragraph
nine
where wine manufacturers May exempt up
to 100 gallons per year for a household
with one person and up to 200 gallons of
wine per year for a household with two
or more people
from the tax
based on the 2021 figures this would
affect seven out of the then 47
licensees wine manufacturers that we
have
and would equate to another loss of
Revenue of approximately 449 dollars
I would be happy to answer any questions
that the committee members may have
I think we're all set
anybody else would like to testify on
how spill
fix 12.
see none but we'll close the public
hearing
from 612 and as I've said before this
will go to subcommittee
okay
blue sheet had nothing on it okay
thank you
next up uh I guess we're all done with
liquor
all right uh house bill 459.
thank you
okay yeah
good morning and welcome
good morning Mr chair and members of the
Commerce Committee uh for the record I'm
representative Tony Kaplan uh Merrimack
eight which is the towns of Henniker
Bradford and Warner can you hear me okay
yeah
um did you I'm sorry did you fill out a
pin card I did not no I'm not okay
sponsored I didn't yeah no sponsors have
to fill 11 cards so yeah so when and
when you're done just make sure you had
a pin card so we get in the file sorry
about that thank you I didn't realize
that
um anyway HB foreign 459 is intended to
correct an overly broad exemption to our
consumer protection act
which has weakened consumers rights to
redress from harm and hurt New Hampshire
businesses who do not seek to gain an
unfair Market advantage through
deceptive practices and fraudulent
Behavior
the exemption to the consumer protection
act enacted in 2002 led to a weakened
enforcement regime in New Hampshire
which resulted in scandals such as the
frm Ponzi scheme
uh costing consumers millions of dollars
in our state its reputation as a place
to do honest business
the ambitious sweep of the 2002
exemption effectively made our consumer
protection act unenforceable by private
citizens and the State against the host
of regulated Industries not only banks
and other financial industry players but
car dealers predatory payday lenders
foreclosure scams and others
from 2002 onwards the only recourse of
victimized consumers harmed by one of
the Exempted Industries has been to make
complaints either directly to the
Attorney General's office
or to the banking commissioner or some
other government agency
in Hope and wait and pray for them to
take some kind of action
previous to the consumer act exemptions
in 2002 industry was subject to
enforcement actions not only by the
state but also by private citizens
bringing suit for harms against them in
the courts and recouping their attorney
fees from the guilty parties
this bill HP 459 seeks to return New
Hampshire to that atmosphere of
increased enforcement by allowing our
state agencies the Attorney General's
office once again to take enforcement
actions and to allow private citizens
harmed by corporate Bad actors to seek
redress in the courts on their own and
not have to depend on Big Brother to
come to their rescue
as written HB 459 would empower the
agencies and the AG's office to issue a
right to sue letter to harm consumers
with legitimate cases thus saving the
state money enhancing the enforcement
regime against unscrupulous actors and
empowering private citizens
to seek Justice on their own terms
however uh
recently a defect in this bill as his
pre as is currently drafted was brought
to my attention uh this bill as drafted
would release private citizens from the
exemption and allow them to take
enforcement actions but it would not do
the same thing for the state and its
agencies
so in the interest of Simplicity and in
order to empower the state once again to
enforce our consumer protection act I
would like to offer an amendment
to the bill as it now stands and get it
to your committee before you meet on
Executive session for this bill and that
would simply be to repeal the exemption
in other words to
get rid of all the italicized language
and just strike Roman numeral one
from the bill as it now stands in other
words
the activities that we're most concerned
with would no longer be exempt
from enforcement action by the state or
by private citizens
thank you
okay so you you do realize that the
entities that are exempt have the same
powers of restitution
that the consumer protection act has
can you can you can you powers of
restitution in other words the purpose
of the consumer protection act was to if
a consumer's been harmed or that they
get their money back right
okay yes is the triple damages but
notwithstanding the whole thesis was get
your money back so those Exempted
entities
all four of them now have the same power
restitution they can make the consumer
whole they can get the consumer get
their money back
yes I understand that but from my
understanding they cannot use the
consumer protection act as one of their
tools no they have their own statute
each one of them has it in their statute
right this ability to make the consumer
a whole I understand that
so what's the problem
we have a consumer protection act which
is unenforceable well the consumer
protection act was designed to pick up
where these that those individual
Apartments didn't have already have so
the idea of the consumer protection act
is all those other things other than
banking Insurance utilities and
securities
have some way to make the consumer whole
but that when it comes to those four
entities
the consumer all has to do is call the
commissioner
and the commissioner will make them
whole
and doesn't need the consumer protection
act to make them whole
he has his own neck or the she excuse me
yeah I mean I I'm not a lawyer so I'm
not going to debate the legality of of
how the consumer protection act is
enforced I mean that that might be or
might not be I know we have a consumer
protection act and it's unforceable at
the moment and by the Attorney General's
office and the other Regulatory Agencies
when they want to go after uh payday
lenders when they want to go after car
dealers when they want to go after
financial advisors who have acted
fraudulently okay so they'll be just
clear because I was in the room when it
happened
the car dealers are carved out only to
the extent of when they'd fill out the
paperwork for you to get your car
financing
but otherwise they are absolutely under
the consumer protection act is this a
question or are we having a debate eyes
called would you believe okay no I
wouldn't believe
okay
represent Phillip
so I suppose as somebody who's worked
with the Attorney General's office in
consumer protection and also in the
Bureau of Securities regulation doing
Securities enforcement
would you believe that there are
different statutes for different
Industries and that the state's
Securities regulation statute allows for
the Bureau of Securities regulation
under the security statute
to go to the Attorney General's office
under the security statute to seek for
prosecution under the state's security
statute and that the carve out under the
states
consumer protection act is not such that
it allows people to get away with
Securities fraud it simply means that we
prosecute those who get away who commit
Securities fraud are prosecuted under a
different code it is not that we allow
for Securities fraud to happen in the
state it's that you are prosecuted
simply under a different part of the
state's statute that having investigated
Securities fraud in the state I have
seen this part of the statute that it
occurs under similarly auto dealers in
this state are not allowed to engage in
fraud that auto dealers in the state
engage in two types of behavior one they
could sell you a lemon in which case
they are prosecuted under the state's
consumer protection act two they engage
in financing and if they give you dodgy
financing instrument then they need to
be prosecuted under a separate part of
the state's statute so we don't allow
people in the state to Simply run
rampant we have different parts of our
code that address different types of
behavior and the consumer protection act
largely addresses when people engage
into various conduct largely related to
the sale of products
one of the problems with the consumer
protection act that you do address here
is related to the inability of consumers
to address nefarious conduct with
regards to security is the insurance
industry banking instruments because
consumers are unable to bring actions
with regards to for example Securities
products if my Securities broker does me
wrong I can't bring a private right of
action which arguably is something that
needs to be addressed which we perhaps
could address it's been brought up a
number of times in the state and there
are pros and cons to that I guess this
is a would you believe everything that
I've just said but and I would believe
you said it excellently too but that's
where we're at right now and perhaps we
should be focusing on the private right
of action elements rather than redoing
the entire State's consumer protection
act which is a
which would be wildly difficult
would you believe well yeah I would
believe all of that and uh obviously
what what we can agree on is that
there's a problem with consumer
protection act whether it's uh whether
you're talking about private citizens
and their right of action or are you
talking about the state I mean uh yeah
the state has as tools as it's at its
disposal and private citizens do not
under the consumer protection act uh and
that's something that needs to be looked
at that that's what this original Bill
intended to address
um so I've been kind of whipsawed back
and forth between people who say the
state has has the right to enforce uh
the consumer protection and and those
who are saying that that the state has
other tools so
um I don't know where the truth lies
probably in between but I do I do I
would believe what you just said
thank you
thank you very much that was an
excellent conversation
okay uh thank you and we will be doing a
subcommittee and but this is an early
Bill all these bills we're doing today
are early bills so they we have to take
action very quickly so if you really do
have an amendment that you would think
we should take up you want to get it to
us
like as soon as possible yeah very soon
thank you okay we have a tons of cards
here on this bill
and uh but we'll start out with uh with
Brandon Garrett who is uh the uh New
Hampshire Department of Justice uh who's
in charge of the consumer protection
statute uh and I think it's most
appropriate we start with you Brandon
with uh telling us what you think of
this bill sure
make sure you have that mic close
everybody hear me okay
morning Mr chairperson members of the
committee my name is Brandon garad I'm a
senior Assistant Attorney General chief
of the consumer protection and antitrust
Bureau at the Department of Justice here
today to oppose HB 459
for certain reasons and given you know
given the comments about a possible
amendment I just want to be really clear
on the opposition from the Attorney
General's office is to the bill as it
was
filed for certain reasons and you know I
will speak to what those reasons are
I'll also speak to what the Attorney
General's position would be uh if this
bill were amended as was just discussed
um so but first you just you know I I
did an orientation for this committee a
number of weeks ago I know some of you
are new to the consumer protection World
um to speak a little bit about currently
how this exemption interplays with the
work that the Attorney General's office
does
we are the primary recipient of consumer
complaints in the state
um and we receive complaints daily
um across all Industries in the state
but some of the most frequent sources of
complaints as in fact I would be willing
to say the most frequent source of
complaints is against car dealers
another extremely frequent source of
complaints that we receive
um are against insurance companies and
we do often receive complaints against
Banks although I'm not sure that I would
characterize the complaints that we
receive as being complaints about unfair
interceptive Acts or practices so to
speak but we do receive a number of
complaints against Banks as it currently
sits the exemption to the consumer
protection act takes unfair and
deceptive acts of practices that are
committed by those who are regulated by
the banking commission the insurance
department the Bureau of Securities
regulation or the Public Utilities
Commission
outside of the confines of the consumer
protection act
so the rights and remedies that the
Attorney General's office has to respond
to consumer complaints
to go to court to get an injunction to
seek restitution to charge a crime to
see jail time if appropriate
all of that conduct is currently
Exempted from 358a which is New
Hampshire's consumer protection act so
the overwhelming majority of complaints
that we receive that are regulated by
those various state agencies are not
looked at by the Attorney General's
office but are instead referred to the
banking Department the insurance
commissioner or the Bureau of Securities
regulation
the this limitation
um poses real problems for the Attorney
General's office which I will talk about
shortly and has frequently and continues
to impede our ability to effectively
investigate and prosecute unfair and
deceptive Acts or practices within the
state
um but the purpose so I I want to speak
to the purpose of this bill and where
the objection is to the bill as it's
currently worded because the Attorney
General's office does not object in any
way shape or form to legislation that
would allow private rights of action to
be free from the exemption in fact I
think that makes a lot of sense
currently the exemption was designed to
apply to
um
State not having you know dual
enforcement by you know multiple state
agencies but in doing so it took a tool
out of the hands of you know private
actors in this state who you know might
use the provisions of the consumer
protection act to try to you know get
Justice for a grievance that was
suffered against them this is this
private right of action option under the
consumer protection act is critical
because the Attorney General's office is
only able to take cases where the most
serious cases of unfair and deceptive
Acts or practices where you have
widespread consumer harm or you have
significant consumer harm we rely
heavily on the people of New Hampshire
in smaller cases the cases that we can't
take
to use the tools that have been given to
them under the consumer protection act
to enforce their that statute on their
own you know if it's a simple issue that
they can litigate themselves we support
that and we strongly support them being
able to do that so the purpose of this
bill
I think the Attorney General's office
would be in support of however there's
significant concerning language
regarding the Attorney General's
responsibilities and frankly I won't
speak for the other state agencies but
the responsibilities that other state
agencies would inherit if this bill were
to be passed in its current language
which is that when a consumer alleges a
violation of 358 A2 by an agency or
entity identified in the section the
appropriate government agency as
determined by the Attorney General May
issue a right to sue letter to the harm
consumer if the complaint is in question
is deemed to have Merit by the
appropriate agency
this is simply not realistic or
enforceable in any real way the number
of complaints that are made for
violations of 358 A2 are astronomical uh
both and this would as I read it cover
both complaints that are made in the
form of a formal complaint to the
Attorney General's office and also you
know
private rights of action that are
currently being brought the Attorney
General's office would be required to
determine for every single complaint
that was filed who the appropriate state
agency would be in order to for that
state agency to then review the
complaint to determine whether on its
Merit
that case Justified a right to sue
letter that would need to be generated
and sent to the consumer the resources
that it would take to to do this would
be astronomical and I think that this
lacks sufficient Clarity to really give
these Attorney General's office or the
state agencies that we are tasked with
determining as the appropriate state
agencies to really have an understanding
of what they would be required to do
Under the statute because looking at
every single complaint to determine if
it has Merit Merit is an extremely uh
general term it's
often not something that you can
determine just by looking at the face of
a complaint in order to determine
whether something has Merit that usually
requires an investigation it usually
requires interviews it requires
subpoenas the review of documents you
know some sort of diligence in order to
determine you know whether what the
consumer is saying is true or not in
order to make a merits-based
determination of a complaint
and to expect that the Attorney
General's office and the other state
agencies involved here are going to be
able to realistically do that sort of
analysis is simply unrealistic
so that's why the Attorney General's
office is opposing the bill as it's
currently worded
um but I I do think that it's my
responsibility as chief of the consumer
protection act to to note that you know
this
consequence of the exemption
um is just one of the many consequences
that the state faces as a result of this
exemption uh private rights of action by
citizens are being precluded by this
exemption and it's a real problem uh
similarly the Attorney General's ability
to meaningfully investigate consumer
protection act violations is being
impeded by this exemption and my office
has over the years on a number of
occasions spoken out against this
exemption in its entirety
um the other agencies that are involved
it's correct that they do have tools at
their disposal
to get restitution
um they do not have the same abilities
that the Attorney General's office has
to go to court to file for a meaningful
injunction in Superior Court to bring
criminal charges when appropriate and to
secure widespread protection for New
Hampshire's consumers in those cases
oftentimes what the way it works is the
agencies that are the primary Regulators
are responsible for doing the initial
review and if they determine the unfair
and deceptive Acts or practices have
occurred and the Attorney General's
office should get involved and should go
to Superior Court to bring in action
they can refer it back to the Attorney
General's office for prosecution but the
reality is is that that is not happening
and we see regularly people coming in
filing complaints against insurance
companies mostly against car dealerships
and you know retail installment sales
contracts which are regulated by the
banking industry
they file complaints with us and we tell
them that we've referred their complaint
to the appropriate agency and they say
well the we spoke with the agency and
they're not taking any action and we
have to tell them that our hands are
tied we have no further ability to do
this unless this agency looks at it and
refers it back to us and we're simply
not seeing those referrals
it certainly makes sense to make sure
that we don't have redundant enforcement
of consumer protection laws but the
State's Attorney General's office should
be the primary enforcer of consumer
protection actions in the state in order
to make sure that New Hampshire's
consumers are adequately protected
um and if there were an amendment that
repealed this or amended it to make it
more consistent with other states so the
only thing that is exempt from the
consumer protection act are those the
conducts that are specifically
authorized by the banking regulations or
by the insurance regulations so you you
make sure that you know we're not
Prosecuting someone for something that
is otherwise authorized in New Hampshire
law that's how most consumer protection
act exemptions in other states operate
to preclude the Attorney General's
office from being able to independently
bring consumer protection actions in
cases especially cases against car
dealerships who are regulated by the
banking when it comes to their retail
installment sale contracts there's a
massive amount of Consumer Fraud that is
going on in the state as it pertains to
retail installment sales contracts by
car dealerships and we feel that this
exemption has and continues to impede
our ability to effectively enforce our
laws and to protect consumers in the
state so if there were an amendment to
repeal the exemption in totality I think
the Attorney General's office would
support it and would certainly support
an amendment to this bill that creates a
private right of action or and protects
the private right of action for all New
Hampshire consumers but doesn't allocate
this responsibility to the Attorney
General's office to review complaints
make merits determinations and issue
right to sue letters
how do you take any questions so that
that's on the assumption that the
in this case the banking department has
waived off on on following up the
complaint that you're saying that we
should then empower the individual to
have right a pride of action because the
banking department has refused to assert
consumer protection that's not what I'm
saying at all I I don't think there
should be any limitation on a private
citizen from enforcing the consumer
protection act regardless of who the
state regulator is you know the consumer
protection act anticipates joint
enforcement by the Department of Justice
and New Hampshire citizens right as it
pertains to non-exempt conduct but
that's enforcement of 358a and all the
rights and remedies that are in 358a it
doesn't make sense to take away that
right for private citizens simply
because the conduct at issue that
resulted in the consumer harm is
regulated by the Bureau of Securities
regulation or is regulated by the
banking commission or the insurance
department the insurance department and
the banking Commission on The Regulators
should be able to take any action that
is within their wheel has to take and
that they deem appropriate but I don't
see any reason that it makes sense to
limit a private Citizen's ability to go
to court and seek Justice on their own
because if the if the banking commission
or I I don't want to throw any one
agency under the bus or suggest that you
know there's a problem but
citizens should be able to quickly seek
Justice on their own regardless of
whether a state agency is going to
choose to pursue action based on
violation of their statutes there's no
reason to take this out of the hands of
private citizens in any case regardless
of whether there is joint action
um by another regulator for the statutes
that they enforce this provision of 358a
the private right of action should apply
to all citizens in New Hampshire
regardless of who the conduct was
committed by that led to their financial
loss
all right representative Philip
thank you Mr chairman thank you for your
testimony
it already is the case that the Attorney
General's office has to reject cases
that is sent to it from the outside
agencies such as the Bureau of
Securities regulation because the
Attorney General's office is already
overworked and short staff is that
correct
so we cert is certainly correct to say
that we do not accept every case that is
sent to us but if we receive referrals
of unfair and deceptive Acts or
practices from our agencies in the state
from our you know brother and sister
agencies in the state we look at it very
closely and if appropriate we bring we
regularly bring actions that are
referred to us by the Bureau of
Securities regulations I'm not sure if
anybody's here today that is going to
testify but we've routinely receive
referrals and we have brought
significant criminal cases against
violators of the security statutes I I
have our unit has three trials scheduled
this year for felony counts of
Securities fraud that were referrals
from the Bureau of Securities
regulations to our office and in those
cases the situation worked great but
it's the cases that we're not seen where
the referral is not being made where we
don't even know it's happening and this
the lack of the ability on the front end
for the Attorney General's office to
look at these cases and inhibits our
ability to make sure the consumers are
being adequately protected for the
question
were the Attorney General's office
though to receive this authority to
review the cases at the first instance
that would require a substantial more
staff for the Attorney General's office
is that correct
I don't think that it is correct you
know we receive consumer complaints
against these entities regularly already
and we send them to the appropriate
agency if they're regulated by that
agency
could we with the staff that we
currently have
continue our initial screening process
and send those complaints to the
respective businesses and do a merits
assessment that would allow us to
determine you know whether significant
violations are potentially occurring
here and bring action on our current
staff I think that we could do that we
would have to shift our enforcement
priorities certainly you know because we
can't do everything but currently the
Attorney General's office is not doing
any significant work in the area of
unfair and deceptive Acts or practices
committed by insurance companies or
committed by entities regulated by the
banking industry I mean with the
exception of one case that was done
earlier this year against a car
dealership here in Concord we don't have
any unfair and deceptive Acts or
practices by insurance companies or by
anyone regulated by the banking industry
that we're currently working on those
referrals are simply not being made
okay
representative Terry thank you
just want to be clear
um with respect to your uh your
testimony
um with reference to uh colleagues in
other states
um and and other state laws it is
effectively would you characterize New
Hampshire as kind of an outlier with
respect to the issues that you have have
raised in terms of the uh the exemption
and the private cause of action
particularly so other states have
exemptions so I don't want to create the
the impression that an exemption at all
is something where New Hampshire is an
outlier but the exemptions tend to focus
on exempting conduct that is otherwise
authorized in the state so for example
if you know we got a complaint car
dealership is doing something in the
course of a consumer applying for
financing to to purchase a vehicle that
the consumer says we think this is an
unfair deceptive Act of practice the
Attorney General's office should charge
this person with a crime
if that conduct
um is something that you know we thought
this is a huge problem but is authorized
by the banking regulations or the
banking laws then absolutely you don't
want us Prosecuting somebody for
something that is otherwise authorized
in New Hampshire's law that exemption
makes perfect sense I think we are an
outlier in the sense that our exemption
is not narrowly tailored like that but
rather it simply exempts any conduct by
any business that is regulated
um and has the ability to regulate
unfair deceptive Acts or practices we
can't look at it at all regardless of
what the conduct is unless it's
specifically authorized and referred to
us by that agency
well for the question so in your view
then uh would would you say in summary
that that weakens consumer protections I
think it absolutely weakens the Attorney
General's office's ability to protect
consumers in the state thank you
representative kips
thank you
do you see it as possible that this bill
could be amended so as to allow private
citizen rights of action and provide
more appropriate enforcement authority
to your office without placing
um inappropriate and unnecessary burdens
uh on either uh the State Department of
Justice or the other enforcement
agencies
I do
um and you know there was a comment that
was made that it would be wildly
difficult
um to make these amendments and and I
respectfully disagree with that comment
I I think that all that would need to be
done is the exemption if if the
exemption is simply repealed it would it
would address the entire problem but if
to the extent we want to keep an
exemption in place for authorized
conduct you'd simply make it so that
only authorized conduct is exempt as it
applies to the Attorney General's office
and specifically include language that
private citizens are not subject to this
exemption either that would address the
entire issue for both the Attorney
General's perspective and I believe from
private citizens perspective who were
the target of this bill in the first
place thank you I think it would be some
great so we'll look forward to seeing an
amendment from you when we take it up in
subcommittee which will be next
Wednesday
happy to do that perfect okay
uh
so uh I guess we'll take a little uh
detour here uh Heather silver scene from
The New Hampshire insurance department
who is in opposition to the bill
good morning good morning um Heather
Silverstein I'm general counsel for the
New Hampshire insurance department
um and I guess
but we are in opposition for a variety
of reasons I'm speaking for insurance
and so not other agencies
um we insurance is a highly regulated
industry we had 750 complaints last year
we recovered for over four million
dollars for consumers last year our
consumer protection is even our consumer
division is even by Statute it's RSA
400a 15-e we have a consumer division uh
with seven employees when we review
consumer complaints there can be as many
as a few attorneys in the room the
Commissioners are awful often in the
room and we do legal reviews and
directors at our agency are also in the
room when we are reviewing consumer
complaints so we take it very seriously
for us the concern is like a muddying of
the waters because of we have regulatory
control over insurance issues including
unfair Trade Practices
and so that would be something that we
regulate
um complaints related to anything
regulatory for insurance including that
the other issue is um
internally I described our process and
then externally
um Mr garage touched on it a little bit
we also talked to Banking and securities
and the AG's office we meet four times a
year and this was is because of RSA 21u
which came about because of the 2002
issue that happened way back when with
the financial
um a bad player will say frm yes thank
you
um and so uh we meet quarterly and I
also every month review complaints that
um Mr Gerard sends over to our office in
case they miss them so they they refer
they refer cases to our office if they
notice that it it goes to our office but
then there's other things that wouldn't
that the attorney generals wouldn't
necessarily know goes to our office that
I could pick up that is like you know
maybe a warranty issue a 415c issue or
portable Electronics a certain
complaints that they wouldn't at the top
of their head go oh that goes to
Insurance because they're licensees that
they are not as familiar with and and
for us
um you know that's important as the
expertise is with us as the regulator
because we are very involved with our
licensees we do examinations of our
licensees we do investigations with our
licensees and
um it's important for that consistency
with our with our licensees that we
maintain that regulatory
control if you will one of the concerns
that I have with the bill is written I
notice it extends the statute of
limitations and also increases damages
to two to three times the damages if
anything were to fall under the consumer
protection act and as you know
anticipated even anticipated costs of
insurance
um companies that gets passed on to
Consumers that means higher premiums for
all of us even if it doesn't happen like
even if there weren't more court cases I
guess my last issue is when we have
consumers that come to our door
oftentimes we can help them and there's
other times that we can't help them and
they can still go to court they can have
this coverage cases which does allow for
attorneys fees if you file a coverage
case in in Superior Court if you're
having a you know dispute with your own
insurance company or tort cases like
tour cases are followed all the time so
it doesn't just because you went to our
agency for Relief and maybe we if we
couldn't provide relief because there
wasn't a regulatory violation
um that doesn't preclude you from going
to court if there is an actual legal
issue to go to court with um one of our
licensees so
great
representative Terry Mr chair uh uh to
uh which subcommittee are you going to
assign this bill
this is uh Insurance
um
I don't remember what I signed this one
too
uh it I I believe my question I I
believe I assigned this to the Banking
Committee because it's consumer you know
well then I will ask my questions if
it's not going to my subcommittee okay
thank you
so with respect to your uh your your
observing that um that costs would
increase uh under the provisions of of
this uh bill
uh is it not is it not true though that
the uh the increases that are requested
in premiums by insurance companies are
regulated by overseeing and regulated by
the insurance department such that if
you anticipate costs that don't actually
happen that there would not be some sort
of adjustment down the road to your
premiums yes there could be an
adjustment but they are allowed it could
be or would no they are allowed to
prospectively they are allowed to
increase premise on anticipation but in
fact if those costs don't materialize
then there would be an adjustment to
take into consideration that they were
not happening later
thank you okay
representative magular uh thank you um a
quick question if if this were to be
amended as uh Mr Gerard said would the
insurance department uh be more inclined
to to uh
no no
I answered my question we like
consistency
or is you
regulated Statewide but we are also
collaborate with other states through
the National Association of insurance
Commissioners and
um our collaboration you know the end we
have a model law for the unfair trade
practice that is pretty consistent with
other states
um and this is not as consistent with
other states I would say
and there is a fair amount of opposition
from insurance providers
great thank you very much thank you okay
so we don't have the banking department
so we'll have Christian Merrell from the
bankers Association
and uh
and okay yep and Kurt come on up
good morning
read this good good morning
um chairman hunt and honorable members
of the House Commerce Committee thank
you so much for allowing us to speak
today I'm Christy Merrill I'm president
of the New Hampshire Bankers Association
and with me is Rob diele Rob is
president of the Gallagher Calhan and
garchow law firm and he's legal counsel
to the association New Hampshire Bankers
represents 38 members and just about 6
000 employees I'm here today to oppose
um House Bill 459 as it's been
introduced and I can I'll get into our
opposition a little bit but just briefly
regarding the amendment that has been
proposed we would be in opposition to
that as well so I just wanted to be
clear about that as you all know this
legislation amends the New Hampshire
consumer protection act by eliminating
the exemptions for banks which has been
in place for decades and it also adds a
private right of action for consumers I
want to be really clear that while banks
are exempt from the consumer protection
act it does not mean that they are are
not subjected to these types of laws I
know that that's been brought up a
little bit but in New Hampshire statute
that is found under 383a those are the
banking statutes and that's where the
authority rests with the banking
commissioner to to address banks that
may have violated the consumer
protection act so I wanted to make that
point and additionally as you all know
banks are very heavily regulated and
Banks typically have a state federal
regulator through the New Hampshire
banking department and they all have at
least one Federal regulator and they are
examined every 18 months they now that
covet is over they will come into their
offices and be there for quite a bit of
time and they will one of the things
that they look at is consumer protection
so specifically I just want to talk
about some of those federal regulations
that Banks may be subject to the the
Federal Department of Insurance
Corporation
the Federal Reserve Bank the office of
the Comptroller of currency the federal
financial institutions examination
Council the financial crimes enforcement
Network and the Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau they all have
oversight
um I did want to just point out and not
to get too much into the weeds
but from the fdic's manual on consumer
compliance examinations in their manuals
they specifically talk about compliance
with consumer protection laws and so I'm
just going to read just a quick sentence
here that I think is really relevant to
your discussions
so from their compliance examination
manual consumer compliance examinations
are the primary means the FDIC uses to
determine whether a financial
institution is meeting its
responsibility to comply with the
requirements and prescriptions of
federal consumer protection laws and
regulations
so I think that's really relevant to the
conversation
um
this legislation would add just another
level of multi-tiered overstride
structure oversight structure and
through the private right of action and
classes of plaintiffs we just don't
believe that this is necessary given the
range of options that exist today and no
other business in New Hampshire is
regulated or subject to the kind of
oversight that applies to banking
um and I you know I don't know if it's
if there's a concern about the state's
ability to enter into class action
multi-state lawsuits there are several
of those that are happening I can cite
them but I think you all are probably
aware of that so in short we really just
don't understand what this is trying to
solve so we're happy to answer any
questions but we would ask for an
expedient to legislate and we do have
legal counsel here that can try and
answer questions as well
any questions
thank you very much
um okay now
Flash from the past from the last time
we did this issue attorney right
how long how many years has this been
it feels that way
welcome back to the conference committee
excellent
yep
turn that mic on and and hold it very
close to your face yeah it's got to be
red
is red is good here
all right thank you for this opportunity
to speak I'm going to make I'm going to
shorten up the remarks that I had
planned because the attorney uh attorney
garage spoke so well I figured he really
outlined the reasons why we need to do
something about the exemption
so I was trying to think well what
should I Salvage well you've got my
written testimony but what can I what
would be helpful to you the most Salient
item yes okay so first for those of you
who I hadn't appeared before
um Peter Wright I've been practicing in
New Hampshire for 40 years 20 years
private practice and then I most
recently worked in uh for UNH Law School
of Law as director of the clinics and I
ran a consumer and commercial law clinic
where I would teach students how to
handle cases by representing real real
individuals families who were faced with
consumer protection problems and so
um we we got to see the whole range of
problems and
I was um
I had to make note uh chairman hunt of
one one comment you made about how the
purpose of the consumer protection act
and some of the banking statutes is to
get restitution
but see it's there's there's so much
more than that often needed in a
particular case let me give you just one
quick example
it's a banking case not a New Hampshire
bank but our client was needed a ten
thousand dollar loan for to pay a
property taxes and to make some
improvements to a property she went
online she's scanning through 17 pages
of fine print where you can't go back
to double check and she does e-signature
and she got her loan which she didn't
know is she also had
a mortgage on her property a second
mortgage and she didn't really realize
that until she was facing foreclosure
now what was unfair about this loan
the interest rate
was expressed as a daily rate as a
percentage it was Point decimal point
three four two four six five seven five
three
what does that mean I read that I
thought I was looking at pie you know
the the uh the the numerical and but no
in terms what you have to do is you take
that number and you multiply it times
365 to get the annual rate now you and I
can do that but this poor lady had no
idea that her loan had a rate of 125
percent
and not only that they were pulling the
payments out on that loan daily
automatically from a checking account
could we use the consumer protection act
to help her no because this was some
out-of-state bank and as currently
worded that exemption
it doesn't just um it's not just based
on the jurisdiction of banking
Securities public utilities and
insurance here in New Hampshire it's
other other federal or other regulatory
schemes that have the power to to
enforce and redress unfair Trade
Practices
so that what does that mean well so it
means you forget about the consumer
protection act you've got to stand in
your head to try to find some other way
and we did we came up with we managed to
squeeze this loan under the small loan
act the 10th with the ten thousand
dollar limit
which says it forbids taking
um a security interest in real estate
therefore it was an illegal loan it was
a basically a felony and the illegal
loans are void so we were able to get
her to save her house
anyway so that's an example though where
the the need for Relief goes well beyond
restitution we needed uh an injunction
to stop the foreclosure and we needed a
declaration that the loan was illegal so
that they wouldn't so they would go away
and we did get that
all right I thought I might speak very
briefly about the mechanism of the
private attorney general
now that's a term of art that's used in
consumer law to talk about the power of
the individual to bring a suit
the private right of action but not just
to bring the suit but if they Prevail
they can have an award of attorneys fees
ordered by the court so it's a way to
fund individual litigation to enable
someone who otherwise couldn't possibly
um
just go up against the war chest of some
of the moneyed interests that commit
these unfair practices so you've got the
the beauty of the private attorney
general is it doesn't cost the state
anything because the costs of doing
investigation
depositions of filing the suit it's all
um yes the attorney may have to put some
money up up front but ultimately if they
Prevail because it's meritorious they
can have an award of fees and costs to
get paid back and that's the beauty of
it
cost free to the state and yet these
individual cases which can are amenable
to treatment on an on the private right
of action
um
they can't they're not going to be they
can't be pursued by banking I mean
banking
actually has um part of their form
letter when they do take a complaint and
they do prosecute it through their
administrative hearing it says we're not
representing you you may want to get
your own attorney so if they have to get
their own attorney anyway having the
mechanism for fee shifting or getting
their attorney's fees paid if they win
is so critical
and the other point that I'd like to
make that we haven't heard anything
about is you know this isn't all this
isn't just about consumers
this is about business in New Hampshire
and for those 20 years before I worked
at UNH I represented businesses you may
not believe that I represent insurance
companies and the point is this
Marketplace
will you have a much better chance of
having a
um an absence of fraud an unfair Trade
Practices if there is enforcement
of these standards
and so that's one of the benefits of
conferring upon the individual the
private right of action is they can go
after unfair trade practice and it
benefits honest business honest business
can compete better in a Level Playing
Field where everybody's going by the
rules but when you have competitors who
are engaging in false advertising or
cutting corners or doing other
unscrupulous conduct
that hurts honest business and we need
to realize that this consumer protection
act is to help business as well
and I think I will let me just see if
there's anything else well I would um
endorse the idea of amending this bill
frankly to repeal
um the the exemption as it stands now I
think it would go a long way toward
restoring the private right of action
and actually helping
New Hampshire's Marketplace
that's all I have okay
represent Philip
Professor do you see any value to the
right to sue letter from the Attorney
General's office with regards to the
private right of action
well
originally I was trying to in in giving
some input into this bill as it is
before you today I was trying to strike
a balance between I think there's been
expressed in the past a fear of
frivolous litigation and just burdening
New Hampshire businesses with uh
litigation that without Merit and I I
don't agree that that's a problem based
on this statute because if you think
about what an attorney has to commit in
order to win one of these cases the
investigation and the research and going
to court and all that you don't take
frivolous cases I you just don't you you
learn to scope out good cases with Merit
and you learn to reject and and explain
to people why you don't have a case you
just do and so that the idea of having
the AG review really a complaint meaning
a legal pleading and maybe looking at
some of the investigation behind it
before the individual could exercise
their private right was it was an
attempt to strike a compromise and then
I I did speak with attorney garad about
this before today and I realized that
they couldn't support that I I
understand that and it's one of the
reasons in my conclusion I'm saying
please just repeal this but my fallback
position I don't want to take your time
because I I know we're short on the
clock but
did that answer your question then about
you know yes thank you okay
thank you so much for coming it's great
seeing you again you too thank you take
care
okay
um
so uh we have some insurance companies
who want to come up and and uh Express
their concern so we'll start with Jim
Hayden from State Farm
and I will hope you'll be a model of
brevity
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee um Jim Hayden here on behalf
of State Farm insurance companies
um one of the nation's largest writer of
Insurance homeowners Auto life and I'm
here in opposition and I will be very
brief we've addressed this issue many
times in the past years and I've heard a
lot of testimony that relates to how the
Consumer Protection Law relates to the
laws that regulate specific Industries
such as insurance companies and you know
the discussion about this bill really
can focus on one area to really drive
home how problematic it would be if New
Hampshire passed this bill whether it's
in the form presented or in the amended
form and that is relates to you know how
it would Impact Insurance companies uh
costs and claims that they would need to
be paid in connection with accidents and
how this bill by itself
would actually have an inflationary
impact on those claims costs that would
ultimately be passed along to New
Hampshire consumers and the reason for
that is it introduces a dynamic into the
claims process that you really have to
be mindful of as you consider this bill
um so if you look in the insurance
statutes there's
um you know there there is one statute
of
45417 I recall it deals with unfair
Trade Practices and in that there's a
provision that governs a subparagraph
that governs unfair Claims Settlement
practices by insurers and so with that
statute our insurance department
monitors and regulates the behavior of
insurance companies as they manage
claims in the day-to-day conduct and you
know to the extent insurance companies
need to be criticized or brought back
into line I can assure you our insurance
department does that
um but what that statute doesn't do very
specifically is create a private cause
of action which which the
consumer protection act does have and
the reason is that if you introduce a
private cause of action into the claims
process
um you create you you create more
litigation and more claims costs
um and let me give you an example of how
that happens
um let's say that your grandmother is
involved with uh in an auto accident
with a teenage driver
um your grandmother bought her insurance
and through that policy they're not only
bought you know obligation for the
insurance company to pay them or pay the
teenage driver if the grandmother was
actually at at fault however it also
provides an attorney and a defense so
that the grandmother can protect herself
from improper claims that it was her
fault so when the insurance company is
adjusting a claim it inevitably is a
conflict between the claimant the
teenage driver and the grandmother the
insured this
under current law there's no private
cause of action by that teenager against
the insurance company
so by this by this uh by enactment of
this law you would allow a the teenager
to sue the insurance company not just
the grandmother but the insurance
company and make a claim that they're
not settling this claim properly okay
now that's problematic by itself but you
need to focus on the fact that the New
Hampshire Consumer Protection Law
provides for triple damages and
attorneys fees so now you have first a
claim against the grandmother for
causing the accident now you have a
separate claim that multiplies an
additional claim that multiplies the
potential damages by by times three plus
attorneys fees
and this is this is a dynamic that's
actually played out over time in other
states and we could learn from those
other states so in the 80s and most of
my information here is a little bit
dated but the lessons are still very
true in the 80s the California
Supreme Court decided it was a good idea
to let
um let parties Sue insurance companies
directly and they did that in the 80s uh
and in 1979 and by 1988 in another case
the California Supreme Court
recognized that by by the first case by
allowing they allow created excuse me
multiple litigation
it encourages two lawsuits rather than
one and it always is the initial suit
against the insured followed by the suit
against the insurance company
and so
the the effect of this recognized by the
California Supreme Court is that it
increased the number of lawsuits it
increased the amount of fraud
and it created uh increased uh costs of
insurance raising the California uh
personal injury claims by 50 percent
by increasing exposures for auto damage
roughly uh almost almost double
um and it basically creates a dynamic
where those additional costs need to be
built into the rating of insurance
premiums and so that insurance companies
had to raise their premiums in order to
adjust for the fact that there's this
unnecessary increase in claims costs
created by adding an additional lawsuit
to to the accident
and this is um
this is
[Music]
um
I'm trying to abbreviate here
um and this is something that happened
in California
um there's also a study from West
Virginia that's probably about 10 years
old that I'll bring to the subcommittee
and it says the same thing but let me
finish with One More Story just to just
to punctuate what I've been saying
um several years ago it could be 20 by
now because of the way we life has gone
on
um there was a company called GMAC
Insurance that sold Insurance to the
state of New Hampshire
and they made a fatal fly in one of the
in a junk mailer that came to more than
20 000 people in the state of New
Hampshire and that said that New
Hampshire Law requires you to buy
automobile insurance and everybody in
this room knows how wrong that is
however the compliance lawyer at gme
Insurance didn't see that
so those 20 000 letters were determined
by the insurance department properly
sold as to be deceptive creating 20 000
violations of the New Hampshire law
um if you pass this bill that one act
those twenty thousand letters would
result in a private cause of action
for uh for more than 20 million dollars
because the consumer protection law says
that each violation
the minimum damages is a a thousand
dollars so twenty thousand times a
thousand that's 20 million dollars so
this was a matter that the insurance
department resolved of a fine of
approximately eighty or ninety thousand
dollars so so we as you consider this
bill the question is really what's you
need to consider what's the appropriate
amount of punishment for GMAC insurance
for uh sending these letters that um
these erroneous letters so with that
I'll end my testimony thank you very
much take any questions no we're not
taking any more questions
okay uh Kurt strands and
sorry
didn't mean to throw you one of the
buses calling you Insurance when I said
all the insurance left I just realized
no offense taking Financial Services
good afternoon chairman and committee
members my name is Kurt strandsen I'm
with the Mortgage Bankers and Brokers
Association of New Hampshire
um I'll keep my testimony brief so we're
not repeating some of the prior
testimony
um since 2010 with the um Dodd-Frank
legislation there's been a very
aggressive
um unfair deceptive and abusive abusive
acts practices piece of that legislation
that's come forth
the Consumer Protection Bureau
implements and enforces Federal Consumer
Financial law and ensures that markets
for Consumer Financial products are fair
transparent and competitive
it has supervisor authority over Banks
thrifts Credit Unions assets over 10
million as well as their Affiliates in
addition over non-bank mortgage original
Services payday lenders and private
student lenders student loan lenders
the cfpb has over a thousand employees
and if you actually Google the cfpb the
first thing that comes up is how to
submit a complaint
all the disclosures in a loan package
when you come in for a mortgage has
references how to submit a complaint if
you feel you've been wrong there's a
63-page loan tool toolbox kit of
disclosures that goes out and there's
also a required list of non-profit
housing agencies in your local areas
that can assist there's an issue so
although it's not through the state of
New Hampshire federal law and all the
massive amount of federal legislation
has come post the 2008 mortgage crisis
there's a lot of different alphabet soup
of agencies that are out there to help
protect consumers if there's issues I
have no further testimony I can take any
questions
any questions
thank you for your testimony
you just stated for the record
opposing the Bill thank you
all right next up we'll have Donald
funstein from Gallagher
and uh
you have three three minutes
as you wrote down thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee my name is
Donald funstein Gallagher firm
I'm an assistant to Heidi Kroll
we represent ahip the health insurance
provider
for those of you who tap on a keyboard
or right on a screen I have a piece of
paper I want you to write one note down
please if you would
Keith
Nyan
1-800
-852
-3416
Keith Nyan n y h a n 800
-852-3416
East the tough nut
over at the department of insurance that
is in charge of consumer services
in a recent article by Anne-Marie
Timmons
well-regarded writer that I saw in the
New Hampshire Bulletin
certainly
never been accused of being a mouthpiece
for the insurance industry
in it when she was describing what a
great job the consumer protection
division is doing for the citizens of
New Hampshire Miss denying asked for one
thing
that you tell people about what they do
and they'll take care of it
second point
when I was thinking about this last
evening
I felt a little like I must have first
worked on this issue with Daniel Webster
I mean this has been here
a long time the existing law
is in the same text that it was in 2002
that was simply a rewrite of something
that goes back as early as I believe
1970 we're not taking anything away from
people by this discussion today
the lar's been this as it has been for
years
next point
going back to the Department of
Justice's resource issue
if I understood the draft Bill correctly
in the AG's position on the draft Bill
the fiscal note for the draft bill which
did not include the amendment that we
heard a little bit about
said that the AG would need three new
people
just to do what it was the original
drafted
not what
would be required as you pointed out
earlier representative to do what they
are suggesting
by contrast Mr Nye and the head of the
consumer services division
that is protecting our citizens in the
insurance field
he hasn't asked for anything
with that Mr chairman I know
I could go on all afternoon but I'll see
you at the subcommittee and thank you
very much okay thank you
one card left George russos
representing New Hampshire Association
of domestic insurance companies
thank you Mr chairman uh
on behalf of the New Hampshire
Association of domestic insurance
companies I would like to express our
strong opposition to this legislation we
came prepared to talk about legislation
that had one little corner of consumer
protection uh in play and come to find
out uh you're talking about blowing the
whole thing up and it's uh I can't
emphasize enough how a serious uh this
would be in its implications to New
Hampshire citizens if you were to
consider imposing regulation and
conferring jurisdiction on the Attorney
General
of insurance that is regulated now
comprehensively by the New Hampshire
insurance department so what you're
doing is imposing a duplicate layer of
Regulation and if you're going to do
that let me suggest you repeal the
consumer protection Provisions in the
insurance statute which amount to about
200 pages of requirements on insurance
companies because you don't need that we
don't need two masters if we're going to
be regulated by the Attorney General
then skip the consumer regulation that
we currently have by the insurance
department we don't suggest it but we do
not want to have duplicate regulation by
the two now you only have to turn down
to Massachusetts to see what happens
when you tamper with the exemption from
the consumer protection act in
Massachusetts very often you will find
the two executive branch agencies the
attorney general and the insurance
commissioner at war with each other over
Insurance regulation and
that practice is is just something that
we don't need in New Hampshire we don't
have in New Hampshire and it would
result from conferring jurisdiction
over Insurance to the attorney general
also
in in Massachusetts you've got a
situation in litigation that is
absolutely
deplorable uh wherein when there's a
simple case against an accident case or
a simple uh lawsuit uh claiming damages
routinely plaintiff's lawyers bring a
consumer protection act violation it's
in New Hampshire in Massachusetts is a
93a action and they tack it on to their
claims and uh and and pursue we don't
need that in New Hampshire so the
biggest thing when I sit and listen to
some of this testimony that strikes me
is do you not understand what the
insurance department does every day uh
that the the staff that they have
devoted to Consumer Protection
um they're doing an excellent job
and uh this uh suggestion of a need for
doing something different just implies
that that they're not that they're not
doing the job that they that they are
doing so uh if you look at it the the
conduct that is regulated by insurance
and if you take a look at nothing else
look at RSA 417
which goes on and on about the specific
behaviors of insurance companies that
are prohibited
let me also suggest a tool that the AG
would not have but that's available to
the insurance department and believe me
it's it's a it's a major uh
um source of Authority for insurance and
that is over the license of insurance
companies that's much more serious than
a fine or paying enhanced damages or
paying attorneys fees but insurance
companies are regulated by the insurance
department which in its investigatory
Powers has the authority to revoke or
suspend the license of an insurance
company in addition to imposing a fine
that's a very strong incentive to any
company that's thinking about violating
the consumer protection laws so this
bill as has been mentioned
has been proposed many times I know Jim
Hayden has dusted off some testimony
from several years ago we can update it
if we need to uh in in the subcommittee
but I can't emphasize enough what a bad
idea this would be for our state thank
you great thanks double George okay well
that's uh enough cards so we uh the blue
sheets uh has about 20 people businesses
from
uh you know Harvard Pilgrim we got Bia
uh Allstate
um
Cooperative Credit Union New Hampshire
retail association property casualty
Association American Council of Life
insurers auto dealers Anthem they're all
opposed to the bill except per attorney
right
and with that I will close the public
hearing on 459 and apologize to the
sponsor
of
465 which I know she's been patiently
waiting here and
I know how much he loves visiting our
committee and learning about all these
crazy things we do over here
I thought it would be refreshing to talk
a little trash right
the committee I know you've had a long
morning and you have a Long Afternoon
ahead of you
um my name is Karen Ebel I represent
Merrimack District number seven which is
New London and Newbury and I'm here to
introduce HB 465 which is a bill that
would prohibit
manufacturers of fabric treatments and
carpets and rugs in the state of New
Hampshire with intentionally added
pfas
this is a strongly bipartisan Bill I
know that this committee whether maybe
you're glad you don't work with solid
waste a lot even though it's very much
part of Commerce and it is affected by
the Commerce Clause
as you know the Commerce Clause bans New
Hampshire from or any state from or
prevents any state from Banning out of
state waste and about half of the ways
coming into our state at this point is
from out of state going into private
landfills I just want to give you
um uh some background of the Genesis of
this bill and the and this effort
um
you may recall back in 2019 China issued
its national sword policy which
prohibited
um uh
the United States to start to send its
Plastics and its mixed paper to China
anymore they had been the recipient of a
lot of our uh Plastics and mixed paper
for recycling which through a lot of our
municipalities and businesses into a bit
of a turmoil because that was where
their recycling was going as a result of
that I
put in a bill to create a legislative
study committee I chaired it and I just
want to tell you we discovered a lot of
things this was in 2019 and we've made a
lot of improvements since then to our
Solid Waste program in the in New
Hampshire because we were so far behind
so the first thing we did was we updated
our Solid Waste diversion goals which
hadn't been updated since 2000
we have issued a solid waste management
plan a long-range Solid Waste Management
plan which had not been done since 2003
we regrouped Des to have a planning
department their planning department in
the solid waste Bureau had basically
been wiped out by budget cuts and when
things like the national sword policy
come along or or other issues there's
actually very little support for our
municipalities and our businesses that
are operating in really a global
economy trash is obviously a very
personal and local issue but it also has
very broad ramifications the good news
is that that since 2019 there's been
some reorganization within the solid
waste Bureau we do now have a planning
department of two people one of whom is
here and they're able to work with us on
on legislation and and planning
um if that hadn't happened we'd have had
a very difficult time even updating our
Solid Waste Management plan
um this was all vital because all our
area Northeast areas states are very
aggressively pursuing
recycling measures composting measures
and progressively shutting down their
landfills and if you saw the Boston
Globe over the weekend their front page
article in their magazine was about the
landfill issues here in New Hampshire
so the the other thing that we did is we
created created the solid waste working
group which is a basically a state
stakeholder group to work with des and
the development of the uh plan and many
other issues I chair that group and one
of the responsibilities of the group is
to recommend legislation pursuant to the
plan that would help move the state
forward now one of the vital
goals of the plan is to reduce toxicity
in our waste stream
and I think I I won't spend a lot of
time talking about what we all know is
the public health disaster related to
pfas and I I want to focus on it maybe a
little differently than than we have in
the in the past
um I want to talk about Source reduction
and that is the basis of this bill so if
you think about the the way stream we
have many products that we use and they
have pfas in them they tend to go to
landfills and landfills produce landfill
leachate and the leachate many times is
not processed that goes to our
wastewater treatment plants and we now
know that the EPA Health advisories
understandably because of the the health
effects are requiring testing down to
parts per trillion parts per quadrillion
I mean minuscule
amounts and I think that's an indicator
of the toxicity of pfas
so we know that both our state and the
federal government are expanding ex and
our and our towns are expanding
extraordinary amounts of money trying to
deal with the pfas issue on the back
side
so one of the best ways that we can move
forward and this is happening in many
other states in the area is trying to
ban pfas as an additive to products
so in in um and I just want to say also
just so we understand the whole landfill
leachate process I've given you
um a handout which was basically the Des
presentation to the fiscal committee uh
that talked about this issue and the
fiscal committee requested it precisely
because of the economic concerns and if
you go to
um Page Six
you will see that based on a study that
was done in Vermont one of the um
highest
sources of pfas in our landfills is
carpeting
you also if you look at this other
handout from the solid waste Association
uh you'll see that one of the largest or
many one of the most prolific places
that we are all exposed to pfas is
carpet
um it should be striking to you that
food packaging and makeup is a huge
source of direct exposure to pfas uh
dust and then as I said carpet and then
lastly landfill leachate so what happens
is all these products are going into the
landfills the pfas is leaching out most
I mean at this point there's no real
regulation for uh the leachate to be
tested for or you know the pfas to be
taken out and so it goes into our
wastewater treatment plants the
wastewater treatment plants of course
have to take it out because they can't
release water into our systems right
unless it's has basically no pfas and so
where do you think all the pfas and
other toxic chemicals are saturated down
into when you're working with Wastewater
back into the landfill and if landfills
like Waste Management actually has a
reverse osmosis machine where they suck
all these chemicals out including pfas
it gets it into a cake and then it's
buried in the landfill so I think it's a
pretty clear case for if we want to get
toxic chemicals like this out of our
waste stream for the sake of Public
Health but also to save unbelievable
amounts of money that we're already
expending in this state we should be
looking at source reduction
so when the solid waste uh working group
looked at this we decided as initial
matter that we would Target carpets
because it's such a huge uh source of
pfas we also targeted carpets because
Maine is doing this they have a they
they're doing basically the same thing
their rule will be
effective July 1st of this year and
Vermont is doing the same thing so this
is regional
there are other states in the United
States that are looking very closely at
carpets there's lawsuits against
manufacturers of pfas they're starting
to withdraw
some of the uh the treatments but
honestly you know the federal government
isn't working really quickly on this in
the meantime we're having to deal with
the pfas in our landfills and our waste
water we're continuing to ingest them I
mean want a huge source of P fast in
Wastewater is US 97 percent of us have
pfas in our bodies because of all the
pfas we've consumed or otherwise inhaled
over time
um
so
the solid waste working group I which I
chair as I said uh recommended that we
bring forth as an initial step this bill
that would ban the sale of carpets with
intentionally added pfas in July 1st of
2025 it would necessitate some work
obviously by the um by the Des so that's
why it has a fiscal note but I I hope
that the committee will focus on the
policy aspects of this and and then move
it to finance for the for the financial
consideration and with that I'd be happy
to take
your questions I just want to say we
finally it's been a long time but the
state has a solid waste management plan
in place a lot of people don't want to
see it gather dust as it did you know
because it hadn't been updated since
2003 and it's time to take some action
and move forward on it and this would be
one very strong step and it has strong
bipartisan support thank you
representative Burroughs
thank you and thank you representative
for taking my question
um in in the the bill the materials we
have it talked about the cost of 98
000 for to hire somebody
um to manage this but it doesn't talk
about the costs to the state from the
landfill and to our health and to our
premiums from Health Care do you have
any data about what it does to us in
terms of costs well you know I was
driving thank you for the question I
mean it's a huge issue I was driving
down here this morning and I was
thinking well maybe I could call the LBA
and get sort of my idea as far as
expenditures I mean I do remember right
before covid um I I was on the capital
budget committee for quite some time and
I think we set aside something like 25
million dollars
um I may be wrong don't quote me but you
know coming through coming through
Finance there's been a big effort to to
help fund wastewater treatment plants
and you know the the federal government
will I will be cinching down its uh
requirements for testing for pfas how
much money we'll get from the federal
government to comply with those rules I
don't know New Hampshire has been very
aggressive because you know because of
the Coakley landfill and what happened
at peace Air Force Base to try to cinch
down the the testing requirements for
pfas I mean it's
gazillions of dollars not even to
mention the public health effects and
um you know you have to start somewhere
and we really felt like
um carpet was a good place to start
considering what else was going on in
the region
chair thank you for taking my question
my family has been in the carpeting
business
my whole life not anymore because we're
all dead
uh that were laying carpets
um but have you talked to the carpet
industry
um in the in the state
um I
looked into whether there were carpet
manufacturers in the state and found not
none
so I haven't engaged at that level I
mean there's obviously many people that
sell carpets
um but I don't see them arguing for the
ability to have pfas in their carpets
yeah
thanks and just a follow-up for the
question main Claire thank you for
taking so much of your time I know you
got paid millions of dollars to produce
these documents and uh I just want to
thank you for uh you're welcome for
doing everything you've done on this
issue I I just think as a state we've
really taken our eye off the ball
um and you know as I said the air the
whole Northeast is very aggressively
pursuing many many issues related to
Solid Waste you folks don't deal with it
that much in here it's it's a huge issue
as far as Commerce is concerned in
general
um and I just thought it was really
important for you to have data as you
talk about this and in the in the
document the digital document that you
got with my testimony I put more
hyperlinks in than you ever want to read
perhaps in your life but you can click
through and see the plan you can see our
new diversion goal goals as you know
they've discovered pfas and freshwater
fish there's a reason they call for it
forever chemicals this stuff is created
so tight that it doesn't bust up so the
idea of destructing it is is pretty
challenging so Source reduction on this
is the way to go
yes sorry sorry representative brazili
thank you a quick scoping question so do
you know the percentage of rugs that
would carpets that would no longer be
for sale and a list of the specific
products and manufacturers I'm wondering
how you would keep track of this well I
think that is something that Des is
thinking about concerned about because
if this bill did pass you know they
would be the ones that would have to
issue the regulations to try to
understand that I I guess I would say I
have to believe they're a finite number
of companies that make carpets
um so there shouldn't be that that that
many and under the under the bill they
have to provide certification so that
would be one way that Des could keep
track of it I mean the other thing I I
would point out is that that you know as
I said Maine and Vermont are they
they're going to kick this type of a
provision in on July 1st and we can also
learn from them because this wouldn't be
effective until July 1st of 2025. if the
if the um committee's stuck with that
effective date
yes representative Sullivan this is kind
of a tie on question you should answer
but
are we aware that there are rugs and
carpets that are currently not produced
with pfas because I mean they're
starting to they're starting to produce
them so it's not like um this goes into
effect and suddenly there's one rug or
proper adoption that we all have no okay
great thank you thank you sir one more
question
quick question uh sure representative
Terry so it uh listening uh to how
critical uh this is and how you want to
get at it and how the neighboring states
are a little further down the road so to
speak
um why is the effective date so far out
uh over over two years from now
well
that is you know obviously that's a
judgment call
um so you have well I'll tell you so one
of the concerns is for the department to
get uh it's the you know it has to
figure out how it's going to regulate it
so if we pass the law that has to
um that has to happen generate rules
generate rules sorry and make rules
that's right they have to make the rules
and then the other thing is that you
know I think in I mean you guys know
more about Commerce than I do but in any
new rule that you would pass that would
affect comment uh Commerce you'd want to
give the industry time to to come up to
speed I mean you get rid of their old
inventory yeah and and the other thing I
I would just say is it I I want to point
out that this doesn't apply to you know
used drugs and sort of the aftermarket
it applies to new rugs and the idea is
that you're really trying to get people
away from
um
uh putting pfas in their rugs and I
guess we have to learn how to clean
better so we don't have to rely so much
on all the stain resistance
I mean that's what it's all about right
it's the furniture right anyway I
remember Scotchgard yeah that was that
was highly promoted wow well in our
Gore-Tex I mean textiles makeup food
packaging scary subject everywhere thank
you very much great thank you okay uh we
do have the department here and Michael
Nork is gonna from des and
uh good good afternoon
Mr chairman unfortunately yes thank you
thank you all for your attention and
this matter and cutting into your lunch
break for this yeah I will keep my
comments uh very brief the department is
not taking an official position on this
bill but we do have a concern about the
the resources that would be necessary
however that being said we do think that
reducing pfas in the waste stream is a
very important issue it's a high
priority in our Solid Waste Management
plan as representative evil mentioned
but one of the things about this is that
it would require the department to to
basically regulate a Marketplace we
currently our Solid Waste program
doesn't regulate a Marketplace per se or
distribution of products
um but this would expand our
responsibilities to regulate uh you know
distribution and sale of carpets and
that that sort of Industry which is kind
of a new
novel thing for us
um
uh so with that being said our estimate
in the fiscal note is for one full-time
equivalent to be able to adequately kind
of stand up this new program uh do the
research necessary for how to regulate
that sector who the players are what
kind of rules would be would be
necessary so there is uh you know a fair
amount of resources that would be
necessary to do that work however the
bill doesn't make any provision for that
so that's really our primary concern the
only other thing that I wanted to
mention is that as representative evil
mentioned there are other states that
are kind of out ahead of this issue
um they're they're kind of you know
Further Along on this than we are right
now
um
and
you know there might be some some
something to be said for kind of an
interstate uh approach uh multi-state
organizations have been done in the past
for uh chemicals Clearing Houses and
things like that there is actually an
example uh that was established in 2008
called the Interstate Chemicals
Clearinghouse or ic2 and that has been
used currently it's being used for
reporting by manufacturers about
chemicals of concern and children's
products one of the things that we
anticipate may happen is that these
other states like Maine for example and
Vermont may look to work with ic2 to
create kind of a more of an interstate
Clearinghouse for this information so if
that were to be established Des might be
able to plug into that a little bit more
easily and have lower overhead and
reduce our you know expenditures
relative to having a full-time we might
be able to get away with a part-time
staff person to do that kind of work
because it would be a lot of the
research and information on who the
players are would be kind of done
through that ic2 organization so I just
want to recommend that as a potential
consideration
and with that I'm happy to be taking we
are going to have a subcommittee so okay
look forward to seeing you there all
right thank you thank you
right very very good one card left Henry
vayu from Waste Management in support of
the bill
and he's going to do it in one minute
that's all I need
um for the record my name is Henry vayu
and I'm here on behalf of Waste
Management uh Waste Management operates
the turnkey landfill in Rochester that's
where a lot of the trash uh in the state
goes to just here to register our
support
obviously uh keeping pfas out of
products on the front end
avoids us having to deal with it on the
back end uh in in the landfill and uh
with that
I'd take any questions
perfect thank you very much Henry okay
uh on the blue sheet we have 66 people
in support one opposed
and on the side overnight and then the
daytime uh we have several
representatives are in support and Des
just this doesn't take a position and
with that I will close the public
hearing
okay so uh we're tight on time 45
minutes
um
so we could but I'll tell everybody that
we're going to start at 1 30 over at
reps Hall
um I normally would never have done I
haven't been in reps Hole uh doing a
build since
I don't know you can't even remember it
was it was years and years and years ago
I did it
um so I I was not so much inclined to do
it because I thought we had a big enough
room but I'm told that there's going to
be hordes of people coming in and trying
to convince us not to pass these bills
or pass a bill so uh at that point
that's why I made the the decision that
we'll meet over there
um however I I will say that that I will
put Implement a rule I've never done
ever done which I will implement the
three-minute rule
having said that I might change my mind
if I get into the room and suddenly see
that there really isn't all these people
and the hordes didn't show up but I just
wanted everybody to know that
um uh you know what the process says and
I will keep emphasizing to that for
people not to repeat themselves but of
course if people are going to come in
and say well we should pass it or not
pass it
um you know it's kind of hard to say uh
don't repeat yourself when everybody
when you had the same but I'm sure
people have stories about why they think
we shouldn't pass it you know and
usually wrapped around children and then
and then why we should wrap it around
why are we leaving tax money on the
table so having said that I you know I'm
prepared to I don't want to get into a
position where everybody thought I was I
was mean and nasty and shut shut down
testimony but I just want you all to
know that
this is pretty straightforward in terms
of what the discussion and I wish I
could say to everybody just well just
tell us what you think is good or bad
about the two bills you know the bills
that's in front of us because it will be
taking each bill separately
um but I'm sure we're going to stray
stray from that with just either for or
against it so
um
so be in reps Hall at 1 30.
and I will keep telling everybody the
snowstorm is coming so hurry up
so tomorrow morning
um I I at this point I uh uh this what
was important about today is we got all
the bills that have to be out of
committee early
so that means we will be doing the
subcommittee on all these bills uh
Wednesday February 1st and we have to
vote them out uh the next two weeks
there we've got to vote them out so by
that Wednesday two weeks later what
first the fourth fourteenth the
Valentine's Day or the day after
Valentine's Day we have to have all
these bills we heard today
um uh out of committee and my my take on
it is to be honest with you we'll go
through the subcommittee so we'll work
on and process them but I think a lot of
them are going to really need to be just
retained because they're going to need
they're going to need a lot more work
you know even though someone can say
well this is a simple Amendment nothing
is simple and
so I would say I I wouldn't be surprised
if they canceled tomorrow
so but I I you know I would know you
know I'm I'm the last person I know a
lot of stuff but yeah right but I think
they're what they're doing is they put
it right up on this the this uh web page
right
they are texting yeah well that's right
I got the word my wife's phone call I
got a phone and I said how did they even
know that number but so they know
everything right so uh but it's not a
big deal if we don't have that day
because then I'll just reschedule all
those bills to another day so all right
um actually the clerk is going to do
that for you
give me not declaring committee
assistant
I would never expect the court
thank you
foreign
two three
so many other things
foreign
one moment
one more
that's why I don't want to sit down
and make it like I'm talking to the
house
okay good afternoon everyone
so ask everybody to take their seats
please
or if you want to if you want to gossip
uh just please go out in the empty room
so I am representative John Hunt
and I am chair of the house Commerce
Committee
I have to say that even though I've been
a legislator for 38 years only once
before I've ever done this to be up here
and I think this little dense here of
mine way back when but uh
so what are we going to do is uh we're
uh we're going to take up the two bills
in the in the order they are when you
testify through the bill Please
be aware that we we're going to try to
do a three-minute rule here and that
you'll keep your keep your points short
and brief and to the point so that we we
can get home before the snowstorm
um and I realized that there's there's
two kinds of approaches who can either
come in and want to speak about what you
whether you're for or against marijuana
legislation
and and that hopefully you can say that
in three minutes if you have uh more
attention to the two different bills I
want you to uh we take each bill
separately so I want you to please focus
in on the bill and if you want to talk
about the pros and cons of each of the
two different bills that's okay too but
please try to do it in three minutes
okay
so
we'll start off with the prime sponsor
representative Osborne
am I in the right spot
good enough that's good yeah it's great
thank you Mr chairman I've always wanted
to see you up at that Podium I gave you
that opportunity uh Jason Osborne
Rockingham 2 uh representing Auburn
uh Candia in Deerfield
um so I'll be real quick uh today
because there's a lot more important and
knowledgeable people behind me uh ready
to testify uh and I don't really want to
talk about any of the details of this
bill that's in front of you because I
know how this committee works and I know
you got your own tricks up your sleeves
and you're going to do whatever you want
anyway and I'm happy to help you do that
um what I would like to say is that what
you are looking at is a the result of a
number of months of work of an entire
Coalition of groups and Advocates every
everything from the business side to the
consumer side to the Civil Rights side
to the economic Liberty side as well as
the recovery Community people concerned
about child safety just all all of the
different uh points of view and
perspectives involved and so I hope
you'll take the time to
consider everybody's concern as we
determine a final product to put out as
we all know this house has put out some
sort of marijuana legislation basically
every year for the last as long as I've
been around maybe even as long as you've
been around Mr chairman I don't know but
maybe not quite that long
um and it always runs into a roadblock
somewhere and uh but this Committee in
particular has not had the opportunity
to take a stab at uh at coming up with a
solution and I'm really excited to see
what we can do here and um
you know it's it it's a time we get done
something done and if I could just throw
in my two cents about what I hope to see
in the final product is that we uh we
keep the barriers to entry into this
industry as low as possible so as to
keep it from being overwhelmed by uh
large corporations from out of state or
out of country uh and that we keep uh
the
uh
I guess the tax or the margin that the
state is going to extract from this
industry as low as possible so as to
prevent the the black market from being
able to maintain control and that we're
able to take this industry away from the
Thugs and gangsters and put it in the
hands of law abiding citizens so thank
you very much
well I'll take questions if you haven't
is uh any members have a question
see none thank you very much
uh I will now call on uh senator
I forget where where is he
Senator is he not in the room
oh there you are
yes okay great two senators two for the
price of one okay
thank you Mr chair good afternoon
members of the committee we appreciate
uh being welcomed into the your chamber
to testify about this important bill we
are testifying in support of the bill as
co-sponsors wanting to show the
bicameral support for this concept you
know I don't want to speak specifically
to the provisions of the bill I think
you know there are a lot of people that
are working on making sure that this is
a bill that fits New Hampshire but what
I will say is as an elected official
Senator Fenton and I are both
Millennials Millennial representation in
the Senate and that's important because
you know we have a real hard time in New
Hampshire attracting young folks it's a
real problem right we know we have an
Asian population that we need to really
think about how we are going to build a
future New Hampshire that we're all
going to be proud of and I think
legalization is not the Panacea to solve
that problem but it is an important part
of that conversation and I know that
because I spent the entire summer
talking to voters right in my district I
represent
um I apologize I did not introduce
myself Senator Rebecca Whitley I
represent District 15. that includes the
communities of Concord bow and Hopkinton
and what I know from talking to the
voters in my district that this is an
issue they care about right and I would
say you know we do know from polling
that 74 of Grant state are support
legalization 74 I would you know be
really hard-pressed to come up with any
other political issue
that has that support I would be
hard-pressed right if any you know
wouldn't you be elated if you got that
kind of support at the polls right so I
think that's important to recognize that
and then also I will say when I'm
talking to younger folks I would say
that number is even higher and so I
think we have to be you know our work in
the state house has to be reflective of
the issues that our constituents and our
voters care about and I would say
legalization is one of those
Senator Donovan Fenton district 10 and
all he can do is uh Echo what Senator
Whitley said you know we're talking
about 70 percent of the population wants
this and she mentioned a lot of young
people but also a lot of old people you
know we're a diver a diverse State and
what Senator Whitley said I want to Echo
was that you know on my campaign Trail
around my district I didn't meet a
single voter single constituent that was
against legalization this is an issue
that affects all of us and is important
to all of us and thank you for your time
folks
thank you we do have a question
thank you Mr chairman can you just uh
State your source of where your data
comes from the 70 or was it 74 you're
saying of granted stators where does
that come from
yep so thank you for the question
um the 74 number that I mentioned is
from a University of New Hampshire
Survey Center
um it was a study in February 25th 2022
by persons entitled bipartisan support
for New Hampshire marijuana legislation
representative petusic
okay I have a question on your survey
Sandra does that have a uh age breakdown
on on you know how many people by each
age group of were for it and against it
thank you for the question and they
don't know but I'd be happy to afford
the actual survey results to the
committee happy to do that thank you
okay great thank you very much
uh
representative Matt Wilhelm
minority leader
who is a co-sponsor I believe
thank you chairman good afternoon
colleagues uh I'm here today as a
co-sponsor of House Bill
639 uh build a legalized and regulate
adult use recreational Cannabis I'm a
co-sponsor of this legislation because
it's past time the granite state joined
every single one of our New England
neighbors to legalize marijuana
we Remain the only state in New England
where residents are still arrested for
marijuana possession which puts our
communities at an economic and social
disadvantage racial disparity and
enforcement of the current New Hampshire
cannabis law has negatively impacted our
state despite disproportionate levels of
use across weight across race the
unequal enforcement of New Hampshire
cannabis laws put black people at
increased likelihood of Marijuana arrest
and charge which leads to an increased
likelihood of the loss of employment
housing financial aid eligibility and
child custody
these collateral harms of prohibition
have a lasting impact on Granite State
families and communities while the vast
majority of granite Staters support
cannabis legalization
we have seen where we've been and how
it's harming communities while the rest
of our New England neighbors profit from
Cannabis legalization now after years of
discussion on the issue we know where we
need to go we know that marijuana
legalization will bring much needed
economic growth to New Hampshire
uh
data from states that have legalized
marijuana show us that job growth and
labor income increased as a result of
the Cannabis industry
uh this legislation House Bill 639 will
allow more Granite Staters to become
business owners and entrepreneurs that's
the New Hampshire way this model will
also support our retirement system with
percentage of funds from the sale of
marijuana to be credited to the New
Hampshire retirement system to help
offset the unfunded accrued
liability returning money to the
retirement system with the tax structure
of this legislation will result in
lowering rates for employers which will
only strengthen our state's economy is
clear communities families retirement
security and the economy will be
stronger once we legalize cannabis in
New Hampshire it's past time for New
Hampshire lawmakers to listen to Granite
Staters and legalize adult marijuana
possession once and for all thank you Mr
chair
great thank you any questions from the
committee see none thank you very much
thank you
chair will call on Susan Homeland
yeah
yes Susan yes sorry
thank you
thank you all for the opportunity to
test
into the states after they legalize
across the U.S we have 21 states that
have legalized in 21 29 that have not
fortunately for New Hampshire there's
other states we can look to to see how
it's going for them
in Colorado legalized marijuana has not
reduced the black market activity as
expected in 2020 Colorado law
enforcement intelligence reports stated
that there were 278 Black Market cases
in 2019.
in 2021 law enforcement disrupted an
operation involving millions of dollars
of illegal marijuana that involved 21
individuals funding money to China
in addition to that other marijuana drug
busts have included Mexican and
Colombian cartels as well as gangs from
Cuba and Russia it's estimated that for
every dollar of revenue generated in
Colorado due to marijuana it costs the
state four dollars in public health
costs through increased substance abuse
treatment increased hospital visits and
increase policy policing
after Colorado legalized the emergency
room visits due to cannabis use disorder
tripled following the five years at the
University of Colorado Hospital which is
one of Colorado's largest hospitals
hospitalizations with marijuana exposure
diagnosis
um
increased approximately 200 percent
after recreational legalization the
number of calls to poison control
exposure increased 400 percent from 2006
to 2015. the national veterans Suicide
Prevention report indicates Colorado's
veteran suicide rates are significantly
higher than the national average with an
increase of 25 percent from 2018 to 2019
alone
teen suicide rates have increased
significantly over the past year
over the past few years and marijuana is
the number one drug found in toxicology
reports
since legalization marijuana use by
children 12 years or older has risen 30
percent which is 76 percent above the
national average
Colorado is the first in the nation for
the highest percentage of adults who
need drug treatment but aren't getting
it
in 2021 approximately 10 years after
legalization Colorado is starting to
come to grips with this public health
emergency and their legislature put in
HB 1317 this bill was a bipartisan
effort sponsored by the Democrat speaker
of the house signed by the Democratic
governor Colorado's requirement now
limits uh marijuana concentrate
purchases as labeling requirements and
cracks down on underage medical cannabis
relationships with Physicians
Colorado legislatures are moving forward
with these risk excuse me risk
mitigation measures
following the warnings of many of their
health experts one health professional
the medical director of the state's
largest non-public psychiatric hospital
said quote the epidemic I'm sorry the
epidemic the epidemic of marijuana
addiction quote threatens to swallow the
lives of a whole generation of
coloradans
so let's now just turn our attention to
Vermont in 2020 two years after
recreational legalization was passed
into law the Vermont Public Health
issued the following statement quote
marijuana use is a significant public
health problem in Vermont and it is
getting worse
in 2021 the Vermont Medical Society
released a resolution to advocate for a
number of measures to include a
Prohibition on the advertising marketing
and promotion of cannabis in the state
of Vermont
a requirement that all cannabis grown
produced or sold whether through
dispensaries or retail establishments be
less than 15 percent THC it's worthwhile
to note that in our own medical
marijuana program here in New Hampshire
we actually have no limits on that and
you could go to their websites and find
Edibles that are 90 percent THC Plus 90
plus THC
uh another thing that they also did is
they put out the medical association is
requesting that a requirement they're
all written in Internet advertising of
cannabis displayed up-to-date
evidence-based warnings in large
typeface which could should include the
following conditions psychosis impaired
driving addiction suicide uncontrolled
vomiting and the harm to fetus and
nursing babies
and with regard to the relationship
between marijuana and addiction a 2021
University of Vermont presentation on
childhood mental health cited the
following approximately nine people nine
percent of people who use marijuana
become dependent that rate increases to
one in six of those who start before the
age of eighteen
and is likely that thirty percent of
those who currently use marijuana meet
the criteria for having a cannabis use
disorder
and almost three percent of 12 to 17
year olds
are already already have a cannabis use
disorder
so Vermont has you know earned the
distinction with actually some of the
highest childhood rates of using
marijuana in the United States
so other states that are dealing with
this every state that either they've
medically allowed it or recreationally
allowed it they're dealing with one of
this uh relatively new syndrome that has
emerged called cannabinoid hyperemesis
syndrome which is a severe vomiting
condition in retrospect now in a
retrospect analysis of patients who are
treated for this syndrome at a variety
of locations across the U.S it is
estimated that the cost per patient just
to be just to be about seventy six
thousand dollars per hospital visit to
treat this
with the never-ending attempts to
legalize across the states it is also
noteworthy to recognize that many
elected officials are still willing to
take a cautious approach
this past year Delaware's Democratic
governor John Carney vetoed a
legalization Bill stating that it was
quote in the best interest of the state
of Delaware especially our young people
questions about the long-term health and
economic impacts of marijuana use as
well as serious law enforcement concerns
remain unsolved unresolved in addition
to this legalization ballot initiatives
initiatives were rejected this past
November in South Dakota North Dakota
and Arkansas despite huge amounts of
money spent on the pro-legalization by
the pro-legalization lobby
and what does this all mean this means
that legalization comes with a
significant Public Health cost
that all states should consider
carefully
and I'd like to conclude my testimony by
just discussing HP 639's purpose and
finding section it stands in there in
the interest of allowing law enforcement
to focus on violent and property crimes
generate revenue for Education
preventment prevention treatment and
Recovery related to the use of both
legal and illegal drugs and for the
public purposes in advancing of
individual Freedom that's the preamble
to this bill the purpose of this bill
so I respectfully act respectfully ask
the committee members the following
thing
ask any member of New Hampshire's law
enforcement here today if they think we
need to legalize marijuana so they have
more time to focus on violent in
property crime
ask any student here today if they think
that you should generate funds for their
school if it comes to the at the price
of increased suicides teen suicides and
addiction
ask any health care and drug addiction
professional particularly those who
serve the vulnerable communities of
Nashua and Manchester
if they think we're helping them do
their job by throwing gasoline on New
Hampshire's drug problem with
introduction of legalized marijuana
I respectfully asked and I also
respectfully ask that no one in this
legislature hide behind the banner of
individual freedom
when considering marijuana legalization
especially since we all know everyone in
this room that it's about money because
that's the main selling point
the public deserves to have an honest
discussion on this topic and we
and they deserve actually to to have the
public health aspect of this discuss
just as much as we want to discuss the
revenues
the public also deserves for this bill
not to have been slipped quietly and
quickly into the Commerce and consumer
affairs committee instead the criminal
justice committee it is noteworthy that
the Bill's sponsor I believe is a member
of this committee as well
lastly the public deserves each one of
you to include my own rep Hollis rep
Karen calabra who's not here today
to do the right thing for the health of
Grant Staters because your decision on
this bill will have a direct impact on
us all thank you and thank you yes sir
representative Herbert has a question
um thank you uh chairman hunt
um thanks for your information
a lot of people are concerned myself
included that
um
being in an illegal act
a lot of uh young men and women are
being thrown into jail
and in effect their Futures compromised
because they
smoke some weed
so I I was just wondering any of these
states that have made it legal have they
come up with any kind of well they don't
arrest them anymore I guess but uh was
there any effort to try and uh reinstate
and make it uh you know putting kids in
jail uh or is there an answer to some
sort of compromise where uh
you know either either your kid goes to
jail
can't get a driver's license which takes
five years to get
sure okay I mean I've seen that or uh uh
smokes weed and and you go through a
whole lot of medical issues which I'm
aware of too I'm just wondering if
there's is it just that bipolar is it
just either or
well as you're aware if States you know
make it legal then obviously
you know the numbers look great for
arrests because arrests go away but I I
will say that it it's sort of a null uh
Point here in New Hampshire because it
is decriminalized
so I'm not sure if you have
yes sir
further question you may inquire thank
you
um I was not aware of that uh and I'm
getting old so
some of the information I have might be
dated but but I know that uh
maybe it's too late for those kids but
uh I know that they've had their lives
severely damaged because of being
arrested and put in jail in some cases
yes sir and that's a valid point and I
will say though that you can add that to
any number of things kids do all kinds
of stupid stuff you know I have four of
them myself
um any number of things they could they
could vandalize something they could
they could drive recklessly they could
smoke pot they could do all number of
things so your question I I appreciate
it but I do think that it could apply to
a number of things that
kids do in their youth
there's another representative Bilo
thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking question um
uh and could you provide that written
testimony to the committee yes ma'am I
will I will send it to you via email and
um just a follow-up where does the data
come from all the information so
everything I have in my everything I
have cited here in my information I've
included as hyperlinks so you can all go
to it yourself and verify the
information I'm giving okay thank you
okay next up is Representative Vincent
thank you Mr
chairman question so this is my opinion
I'd like to know if it's yours also
don't you think right now that the black
market and I'm not sure if you can
answer this question on one of the other
speakers right now is running the
so-called pod operation in outside sales
which is other states are actually
running it and they're doing it anyway
and and your your question sir is that
the black market is running the pot
sales right now maybe putting even a
greater risk on the people or the
citizens the youth or whoever is using
the state they're putting a greater risk
um and I hear the so-called gateway drug
uh and I just want to say that if you're
going to a black market dealer who's
selling pot
and maybe they sell another drug that's
illegal such as coke or heroin wouldn't
they be at greater risk than to buy it
in a controlled environment
controlled by the state versus going to
the black market
and risking
other type of illegal drug pushers or to
the to the individual I understand what
you're saying and I would love to think
that if legalization happened that
nobody would go to a black market but
Colorado's data shows us that that that
doesn't it doesn't happen I mean it just
doesn't the black Market's always going
to beat your price
they're always going to beat your price
you put any amount of tax on this and
they're going to beat your price it's
not going to I mean it's just a function
of fact so that's proven out in in every
state that's been doing this so I I
would love to do anything to keep kids
away from the black market but but
legalizing doesn't solve that problem
um you know I wish it did but it doesn't
and and I will know that I actually work
for the Department of Oklahoma Emergency
Management I work remotely for them and
they've had an issue with marijuana
because they legalized it medically and
they have a lot of farmland and they
didn't put any limits on how much you
can grow in Oklahoma right now is the
number one state for
um supply for the illegal black market
and not only are they number one uh
supply for this they actually have
overnight in Oklahoma introduced
Russian Mexican and Chinese cartels uh
into into their farmlands and the way
that they're legally laundering money is
they're they're reselling the Farms
every couple months or so they're just
washing their profits it's a legal way
to wash their profits it's a it's a
shame and a crime what's happening in
Oklahoma I talked to emergency managers
on an everyday basis and uh they tell me
about what's going on in their
communities so I wish that the black
market wasn't always one step ahead but
it is
thank you thank you sir representative
Burroughs
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
um it's a two-part question and it kind
of goes along with what Representative
Vincent was saying
um in Colorado you talked about the
increased rate of people going to the
emergency room from marijuana do you
know what percentage of those were from
the black market because they weren't
controlled
no ma'am okay that's not it that's not
data that that the Colorado hospitals
okay collect and my second question
further question you may inquire thank
you Mr chair my second question is I
think you may not have this data but I'm
wondering if we might be interesting to
find out what's the rate for ER visits
in terms of alcohol and opioid use
relative to marijuana I don't know but I
I do know that um I know sometimes in a
lot of these discussions we try to make
these equivalencies to alcohol
and I would actually just caution you
that making an equivalency to alcohol
doesn't negate your responsibilities to
deciding marijuana on its own health
impacts
thank you thank you
representative Yemen
thank you Mr chair and good to see you
nice to see The Honorable
I just have a question you were talking
about the black market there's a reality
in our state with the white Market in
surrounding states
so if you pay attention
for instance about a mile south of the
Manchester of the mall in Nashua
um there's a marijuana shop and there's
a steady stream of New Hampshire license
plates in and out of that shop all day
long so that's not a hypothetical with
the black market that's a reality with
the white Market what would you what
would you suggest that we do with that
border should we have the police stop
people and and search their vehicles
because they're coming back across the
border with uh how do we handle that
situation if we keep New Hampshire a
Prohibition state
well I understand that it's a you know
it's a Canon
and to to speak to your to answer your
question
um
I don't know I don't know how to to do
that I just know that when states
legalize
it tends to give the green light to
their youth
that increased use is okay
and the health impacts of those are
significant
so I know that it's it's somewhat of a a
mixed bag saying well we're not going to
legalize in this little island of New
Hampshire and we're all surrounded
but I'm just going off the science I'm
just going off to science and just doing
my best
as I mentioned earlier I have four kids
all I've done their whole lives is just
held back crazy
and I that's all I'm trying to do here
today
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you sir thank you for be a time to
go uh it's important to hear the both
sides okay Tim Egan
thank you Mr chair good afternoon
committee to me again former
representative from Sugar Hill I'm the
chair of the New Hampshire cannabis
Advisory board and the New Hampshire can
trade Association I'm here today
as a chair of the state's leading trade
group
for the campus industry and we're
pleased to support House Bill 639 which
is a bipartisan leadership effort of
Representative Osborne representative
Wilhelm which will move New Hampshire
into the realistic world of adult use
cannabis legalization and regulation of
cannabis is essential to New Hampshire
in a variety of ways we're losing
Revenue due to our current Antiquated
laws with legal adult use cannabis now
available in Massachusetts Vermont and
Maine we are seeing New Hampshire
consumers leaving to spend their money
elsewhere the average states are finding
economic success with cannabis in 2013
in 2023 Vermont is projected to find 15
to 20 million dollars in their first
year Maine in 2022 found 58.5 million
dollars in sales revenue and 65 million
dollars from direct and indirect
spending by businesses and employees
associated with the industry and
Massachusetts grossed three billion
dollars in the last four years from 2018
to 2022 so it's easy to see why League
legalization and regulation of cannabis
is good for our state's economy but
that's not the only reason I'm here to
talk with you today
New Hampshire can reclaim and share in
this new Revenue generation generating
industry by
approved by and endorsed by almost 80
percent of our residents
and it's an industry that is focused on
young people in a state where we are not
attracting young people
not just folks that are interested in
enjoying their cannabis but those that
want to work in the industry in
agriculture in retail in
creation of Edibles so it's a job
creator
and we're also seeing an industry that
is built on small business entrepreneurs
and agriculture an industry that is
poised for growth but is being stifled
an important part of this legislation is
the fact that it will allow small
businesses Private Industry to be
developed here in the state we pride
ourselves as being a pro-business state
a small business State and that's an
important part of this legislation
we can't ignore that this bill was
designed
by a bipartisan Coalition looking at
Best Practices from a variety of states
and creating a bill that is best for New
Hampshire
and speaking of best practices data from
the National Youth risk behavior survey
says that every every state that has
regulated legal cannabis has seen
reduction in underage use
the aforementioned illicit or black
market
right now if a young person wants to get
cannabis in New Hampshire they can we
don't know what they're getting what's
its potency how it was grown a regulated
market will allow independent testing of
cannabis grown in our state we'll be
able to understand what potency levels
people can get access to now you can go
into a New Hampshire state liquor store
and say I'd like 70 proof vodka or 100
Proof vodka without regulation we are
not able to do that with canvas
it's an important part of this
legislation is independent testing and
Regulation and control so that we're
protecting
our young people and we're protecting
our adults who make a decision to enjoy
that
lastly an important part of our state's
economy is tourism people are now
beginning to make their tourism
decisions based on what they can get
access to I live in the North Country in
Sugar Hill between two ski mountains and
many times residents have told me oh
I've driven over to Maine and I'll go to
a cannabis shop in Maine and I'll go
skiing there first and then I'll buy my
groceries and other things and then
maybe I'll come to New Hampshire for a
night or two so if tourism is a major
impact of our economy this could
potentially affect that
so it's time for New Hampshire to pass
intelligent legislation like House Bill
639 and I appreciate your time and I'm
glad to take any questions
representative has a question if you're
willing to take one
thank you Mr chair thank you for your
testimony
um
based on your testimony uh this is I'm
asking you a question about the Advisory
Board it sounds like you might be
familiar with that feature of the bill
the Cannabis Advisory Board it's on page
10 line 29 of the bill could you give us
a little more detail on that Advisory
board if you're if you're familiar with
it
yes
um as most pieces of legislation I I've
experienced in my past as a member of
your house that it will go through a
variety of changes so proposed is the
idea to build an Advisory Board of
professionals who have experience in the
Cannabis industry have experience in
understanding about the impacts of
cannabis to be respectful to those who
are concerned about its use or overuse
or potency but by building an Advisory
Board similar to the state of Vermont or
the state of Maine where those folks can
then suggest Commissioners to the
executive Council
that's an important part of this being
able to build a series of professionals
that have experience from all walks of
life
within the Cannabis industry so that
we're bringing the best professionals
forward to oversee the industry again
the idea that we are looking at Best
Practices from around now over half the
nation having states with legal adult
use cannabis and being able to be sort
of in the uh
positive position to look at
what ways are best to build in a
commission or an Advisory board that can
bring professionals that can make this a
smart
uh
agency that oversees
cannabis retail
representative Terry
thank you do I understand that you're
currently a member of the Cannabis
Advisory Board sir
are you currently a member of the county
I'm currently the chair you're currently
the chair so certainly you're a member
then yes and you're the chair yes so uh
what I've heard from you thus far
primarily what you consider to be the
economic benefits
of uh of this bill we you have been
present to hear the testimony of the
previous speaker with respect to adverse
Health consequences in the states that
have uh that have legalized
um how would you respond to what you
have heard the documented evidence with
respect to massive uh adverse Health
consequences in these states that have
legalized you and the members of the
board or if you've not addressed that
yet as as a board what would be your
personal uh feelings about this
well I think I'd be interested to see
the research that came out of Colorado I
work closely with the Cannabis
certification Council which is a
colorado-based organization working
closely with the California with the
Colorado Department of Public Health and
so I'd be concerned at the quote number
of emergency room visits and whether we
can discern whether that was from legal
don't use cannabis or whether that was
from Black Market cannabis
so I'd be interested to see that data
and see where the proof is there I think
secondarily you know while in this bill
I don't think there's some specifics
around potency that usually become sort
of an agency decision once an agency is
created like we do here in New Hampshire
agencies have some rule-making ability
but I do think Colorado initially had
some very wide open potency levels and
that is something that should be
addressed and making sure that when we
are creating products we're concerned
about that
great thank you very much thank you Mr
chair
uh chair Cullen John uh brimpinsky
New Hampshire Chiefs of police and he's
the chief of Bedford
well good afternoon members of the
committee
um my name is John burfonski I am the
chief of police in Bedford New Hampshire
and I'm here representing the New
Hampshire Association of chiefs of
police uh 160 Chiefs of police
throughout the great Granite State
and we're here in opposition to HB 639
my written testimony is replete with a
lot of facts and information that's
already been discussed and I'm not going
to cover that same ground again
several years ago
when this debate really started to heat
up here and in other places
we used to say that well the jury's not
in with respect to the effects of
legalization of cannabis in the United
States or in Canada for that matter
well today the facts are in ladies and
gentlemen the facts are before you and
that written testimony in the written
testimony of others and the facts are
undeniable
the undeniable fact is is that
legalization of cannabis and the
commercialization of cannabis is
creating a public health hazard is
harmful to both adults as well as our
young people and in the Next Generation
here in the United States it's caused
increased tragedy and Chaos on our
highways just the other day the Colorado
State Police Colonel the state patrol
Colonel indicated that marijuana related
crashes in the state of Colorado in 2022
were up 51 percent
uh that's on top of 120 increase since
the legalization of marijuana in
Colorado so the undeniable fact ladies
and gentlemen and members of the
committee
um who are charged with consumer
prepares and consumer affairs and
protection is that the legalization of
cannabis has been proven by a number of
studies
peer-reviewed studies scientific Studies
by some of the greatest institutions
here in the United States as well as
across the globe that have proven that
legalization commercialization of
cannabis provides significant creates
significant public health risks for
adults and particularly youth you heard
testimony you're ready with respect to
marijuana being one of the primary drugs
involved in completed teen suicides in
the state of Colorado just the other day
you saw an article in our own Manchester
Union leader that talked about the risk
of edibles
particularly causing a public health
hazard in Risk in that article it
indicated that 62 people last year were
treated in medical facilities in New
Hampshire alone
for
consumption of cannabis and then on top
of that 19 of that 62 were children
under the at the age of six or under
let me repeat that 19 of those 62 people
that were treated
in New Hampshire hospitals with respect
to cannabis poisoning were at the age of
six or under just this past week in
Bedford my own officers responded to a
case involving two juveniles both had to
be transported to a medical facility
regarding with as a result of consuming
cannabis edibles
you have a 49-page bill before you
there's a lot of language in there
but all the Chiefs will tell you that no
amount of Regulation no amount of
language is going to change the
undeniable fact that legalization and
commercialization of cannabis will
undeniably increase the prevalence and
use use of cannabis by our youth in the
state of New Hampshire it will result in
Greater Public Health harm to adults
it'll create a cause as indicated in the
written testimony of some 80 million
dollars a year in direct and indirect
Clause you can make money but is this
really about money we believe in the
Chiefs Association that legalization and
commercialization of cannabis is more
about public safety and public health
than it should be about money it's the
men and women in the green uniforms of
the State Police the men and women in
the Brown uniforms of the sheriff's
departments throughout the granite state
and the men and women in the blue
uniforms that have to deal with the
tragedy associated with the use of
cannabis particularly on our highways
2016 a Massachusetts state trooper 44
years of age was killed as a result of a
marijuana
impaired driver just this past year as
you know one of our own was killed in
connection with a crash that may have
involved cannabis use in connection with
that fatal crash and in Bedford alone I
can tell you that in 2019 we handled two
fatal accidents both of those incidents
involved marijuana impaired drivers and
our officers had to make those calls to
those affected families telling them
that their loved ones wouldn't be homes
there is nothing in this bill that
creates a per se limit that would allow
New Hampshire law enforcement to be able
to determine that someone is impaired by
marijuana or cannabis uh the two crashes
that the Bedford Police Department
investigated in 2019 did not result in
charges with respect to impaired
marijuana driving as a result of the Gap
in the law here in the state of New
Hampshire so there's nothing in this
bill that will create an opportunity for
law enforcement to be able to protect
you and your families from marijuana
impaired drivers
the black market which is something that
I've heard about in previous testimony
has undeniably proliferated in every
state every state that's legalized
marijuana in fact the state of Oregon
appropriated more than 25 million
dollars in the past year to address the
black market that's proliferated
proliferated in the state of Oregon
sorry
you know the black marketeers and those
folks who grow marijuana for profit that
are not part of a legalized Society they
don't pay withholding tax they will
always be able to undercut and undersell
every legalized
industry in the state of in the United
States and they have continued to do
that and they will continue to do that
because for them it makes a lot of money
they can understand undercut recent
Boston Globe articles certainly
indicated that the marijuana industry in
Massachusetts is suffering there was a
recent article a month or so ago they
indicated that Colorado was expecting a
100 million dollar shortfall and
expecting massive layoffs in the
marijuana cannabis industry in Colorado
and of course you've read about the
significant problems in chaos in
Oklahoma and California
at the end of this I'll I'll have to say
this
we in the United States were Bamboozled
by the tobacco industry and we're still
paying for that
we were recently Bamboozled by the
pharmaceutical industry with respect to
opioid painkillers and we are paying for
that dearly and the question now is are
we going to be Bamboozled by the
marijuana industry that's a decision
that you all have to make but it's the
men and women of law enforcement that'll
have to pick up the pieces after this is
all done thank you for listening
thank you very much for your testimony
representative petusic you have a
question thank you Mr chairman uh chief
do you know
is there any methodology available today
to test for
marijuana in a DUI situation where
somebody gets stopped from being under
the influence
no there is not there is no roadside
test that's available there's been a
number of experimentations with roadside
testing both in Canada Canada and the
United States but none of that research
has proved a reliable test the
additional problem
representative is that in looking at the
research and studies done in Ohio by a
research institute there
the use chronic use of cannabis has
lingering effects well after the
individual has stopped using marijuana
so it's not simply just using and
applying the same methodology as alcohol
there's a lingering effect that they
have detected and that's again that's
solid research done by one of the
leading researchers in cannabis
thank you very much oh I have a question
representative Sullivan
thank you Mr chairman uh
feedbacking off of that question do you
know or do you have any data uh maybe
somebody else will later on on whether
or not there is actually an increase
traffic fatality rate since these
legalizations have occurred
um I'd be curious to know whether or not
people have substituted away from
alcohol and into marijuana if that's
occurring perhaps that's changing uh the
fatality rates also I'd be curious to
know if there's just been a spike in
accidents that are involved in marijuana
and so that we're seeing higher rates of
accidents higher rates of deaths overall
because presumably if it's as dangerous
as it potentially could be and there's
all these more people using it and
driving and there's no way to test for
it there should be some sort of evidence
of of increased traffic fatality rates
thank you
well if I understand the question right
it relates to an increased
um trafficking did you say
no uh I'm I'm trying to understand if
there's any data to show that traffic
fatalities have increased across the
board in these states that have
legalized versus the ones that haven't
absolutely there is substantial data
both in Colorado there's substantial
data in the state of Washington there's
substantial data in Canada particularly
the
province of Quebec that Associates
legalization with increased fatalities
involving marijuana so there's a and in
addition to that when looking at the
fatalities and the counties surrounding
states that have legalized that have not
legalized marijuana you'll see an
increase in marijuana related crashes
and fatalities as well
I'll have to say that you know while we
may be surrounded by states that have
legalized that doesn't necessarily mean
that the great Granite State who Finds
Its Own Way in most every incidence
should follow us like a bunch of
lemmings across the cliff simply in the
pursuit of dollars I think that when you
look at the fiscal notes of this bill
you'll see that your own administrative
Services folks cannot give anyone a
reliable figure about how much revenue
that this is going to create and in
addition to that there is certainly no
one that's going to be able to tell you
what the public health costs and the law
enforcement costs associated with this
what is the cost of one motor vehicle
fatality that would not have occurred
had cannabis not been legalized there is
no cost that we can put on a human life
representative field has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
chief for your testimony what has been
the increase in traffic accidents in New
Hampshire since all of our neighboring
states have legalized cannabis
would you repeat that question against
what has been the increase in traffic
accidents in New Hampshire since all of
our neighboring states have legalized
cannabis
I'm not sure about that data we we're
struggling a bit to try to get reliable
data here in New Hampshire with respect
to marijuana impaired crashes
um and I can tell you that again the
data that we have
um again Vermont has only been two years
Maine has only been a couple of years in
Massachusetts has been I think less than
five or six years whereas Colorado we're
talking about more than 10 12 years of
data Washington State more than 10 12
Years a data so again that data that has
been out there with respect to the
crashes in those States is undeniable
that crashes do increase we we can
extrapolate using Colorado data to see
that there would be another 50 or so
marijuana involved fatal crashes in the
state of New Hampshire if we if cannabis
is legalized here that's based on what
the percentage increase was in other
states it's had just about a decade of
legalization
oh boy okay Representative Vincent
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question and I just want to
state that I respect you wholeheartedly
and I don't have a opinion on either
side I just want to be able to ask some
of the questions for both sides
so are you saying that having a
controlled environment as having
marijuana Outlets so to speak in the
state of New Hampshire
is I guess my question is is
same question I heard it before right
yeah aren't aren't um
all to our surrounding states and get
it how much more of an increase what
people aren't doing it because it's
illegal
well let me turn that question on this
Edge and tell you that if you legalize
it you will certainly undeniably have
increased use
let me tell you that undeniably black
market for marijuana in the state of New
Hampshire will not evaporate it will not
go away
people that grow marijuana illegally
will come here once it's legalized and
take advantage of legalization as they
have in every other state right which
puts an increased burden on New
Hampshire and law enforcement that
frankly ladies and gentlemen we don't
have the capacity to deal with we don't
have the capacity to deal with what we
have today let alone another 50 fatal
crashes in the state of New Hampshire
attributable to marijuana that's not
something that we can sustain and and
the cost of that is just something that
we can can't sustain in terms of human
tragedy
thank you chief
okay representative
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question you're talking about
um all these crashes throughout the U.S
um can you tell me how many of these
crashes involved
um liquor and marijuana
how many crashes involved in what again
liquor
alcohol
and marijuana I don't have the numbers
for alcohol I'm sure that there is an
ample number of crashes that involve
alcohol but again as in response to your
colleagues question
increasing or legalizing cannabis and
commercializing it will undeniably
increase the number of those accidents
it will undeniably increase the number
of traffic fatalities attributed to
marijuana that's a fact that's
undeniable you can check the data all
across these other states that's what's
going to happen here yeah just a further
question may inquire clarification
um
so are you telling me that all the
crashes that you're talking about were
just marijuana people that were on
marijuana or marijuana and alcohol
no these are crashes that were
attributed to marijuana impaired drivers
that's where the data comes from
representative Ammon
thank you Mr Sharon thank you for coming
and testifying
um and looking over the handout that you
gave us I just had a question about one
of the charts is that okay
I saw on page eight at the top
it talks about the number of Overdose
deaths how many overdose deaths are
attributable to marijuana and how does
this chart relate to your argument
I don't have any data in my head with
respect to marijuana overdose deaths if
you can assign a factor to marijuana
impairment to motor vehicle fatalities
and teen suicides you may be you may be
able to extrapolate a number there but
certainly chronic use of cannabinoids
does factor into the fatalities in motor
vehicle crashes and the team suicide the
data on that is in fact undeniable
just follow
for the question so the chart talks
about a heroin and opioid overdoses and
I was just wondering how that relates to
cannabis legalization that's what the
chart says here
well the opioid overdose is here in the
state of New Hampshire as you're I'm
sure more well aware than anyone
um is not decreasing in fact it's
increased over the last couple years and
so the question I I point to anyone is
and the number of
Ed visits emergency department visits at
least with respect to cannabis that was
tracked for some period of time by the
department of safety here in New
Hampshire increased substantially in
2021 right I don't have the latest data
in terms of Overdose deaths I don't have
overdose death state or with respect to
cannabis use but again there is an
undeniable correlation between
legalization and increased fatalities
and teen suicides
and if you look at the Texas data which
is in my packet
marijuana was the number one controlled
drug that was involved in child fatality
cases in the state of Texas child
fatality cases
so there's another correlation
there's a cost to this and it's not
dollars and cents it's in it's in the
lives
of the people that you represent and
that we serve
I think we're finally done with
questions thank you very much thank you
for taking thank you for everything okay
Ralph don't put two Bill numbers on one
card
foreign
Hillsboro district 14 town of Litchfield
I'm the change I mean my major
testimony will be for the whole house I
just done a couple of statements I want
to make here is I was going to introduce
Sue home alone but she's already spoken
which is good but my main concern is I
just hope the statement that this
committee takes the same
criteria they used against other bills
that were against federal law
for example the home distillation of
alcohol
it was against federal law so is this
against federal law also in the comment
a question that was asked
Ms homila is on the black market
so let's make everything legal so it
wouldn't be on the black market
like cocaine and Fentanyl
the point is the black market will still
exist with us selling legally and it
will be cheaper on the black market so
it's not going to fix anything so thank
you
any questions
see none thank you
okay for another point of view from
Criminal Justice we have Rick van
Winkler
law enforcement Action Partnership
good afternoon Mr chairman honorable
committee thank you very much for taking
my testimony today
my name is Richard van wickler I'm a
lifelong resident of the State of New
Hampshire
I have 33 years of law enforcement
experience here in New Hampshire 27 of
those years as the superintendent of the
Cheshire County Department of
Corrections and I retired in June of
2020.
I'm here today to testify
in support of House Bill 639
in addition to my professional career in
law enforcement I'm also a board member
of law enforcement Action Partnership
they're known as leap
leap is a non-profit group of police
prosecutors
judges
and other criminal justice professionals
who speak from first-hand experience
our mission is to make communities safer
by focusing law enforcement resources on
the greatest threats to the public
and working toward healing
police and community relations
when a drug is illegal we have no
control over it we know that for over 50
years of Prohibition in an attempt to
end the drug war
nobody needs a license to sell it
they can sell it to our children and
they do
nobody oversees the product quality or
the purity
so the products contained dangerous
molds
or other toxins
some sellers in the illegal Market offer
not just cannabis but also pills and
heroin
Fentanyl
tempting buyers with free samples
many New Hampshire adult users and there
are a lot of them
in our state are already visiting
neighboring states for safer consumer
options
then they prefer to patronize a legal
Market they don't want to participate in
a black market
states that have legalized are realizing
significant tax revenues from this
decision job growth and investment
opportunities
I believe that cannabis legalization
would also improve the police community
relations because it no longer forces
police to be the bad guys carrying out a
cannabis arrest that most people
consider ridiculous and unjust
and oftentimes for our youth lifelong
harming
I've testified in favor of cannabis
policy reform for the last 16 years in
this house in the Senate
and when I started no state or country
lawfully supported cannabis
for adult use
in that time
seven countries 21 states four
territories to include our own
Washington DC have legalized cannabis
for adult use
New Hampshire should not consider this
issue because it's popular
and obviously we didn't over the last
several years
but the state should support it now
because it is smart and it is
responsible
you will likely hear many reasons why
this bill should not be passed
marijuana is not a gateway drug as one
example
and there are so many other pieces of
misinformation
that's just far too much misinformation
and opposition
to efforts like these
use by youth will not exclude
states that have legalized cannabis do
not show increase in use because legal
sellers are subject to licensing
requirements
strict regulation
surprise inspections
legalization is not permission or
recommendation to use
we're not here to give permission
we're not here to condone what people do
we're here to admit that we know people
do it a lot of people do it
people who want to do it already do
other states have shown that
legalization is not a doomsday scenario
in his common sense
and it is responsible legislation which
time has proven
to be successful
in summary this comprehensive Reform
Bill would move our state forward an
improvement of Public Safety and healing
police community relations
you know I personally thank you for the
opportunity to share my perspective in
support of House Bill 639
and I want to thank each of you
personally for your service to our state
thank you Mr chairman
thank you any questions sitting done
thank you very much okay
um now we'll have the Department of
Health and Human Services
Michael Holt and Jenny O'Higgins
good afternoon Mr chair members of the
committee thanks for the opportunity to
provide testimony on this legislation my
name is Michael Holt I am the
administrator for the Department's
therapeutic cannabis program
and I'm Jenny O Higgins I'm the
legislative liaison for the division for
Behavioral Health
the department doesn't have a position
on this bill
um however we would like to take the
opportunity to provide some information
to the committee relative to certain
Public Health matters
um associated with the bill
um we first first of all we appreciate
the thoughtfulness that the drafters of
this bill took to approach the state's
therapeutic cannabis program
um and the licensed alternative
treatment centers in the state which
which sell cannabis to therapeutic
cannabis patients however we do have
some issues of concern with the bill and
we have a number of recommendations for
improvement I'll let Jenny start
sure so the bill establishes a substance
abuse and Recovery Fund to be
administered by the department and in
order to be used for Behavioral Health
uses so there's no appropriation in this
particular bill for additional
Department staff that would be needed to
administer that fund there's not a clear
time frame for the disbursement of the
remaining funds in that fund
um and not a separate appropriation for
a preliminary public media campaign in
order to get Upstream on the prevention
prior to the rollout of the adult use
program and and the bill also does not
follow some of the Clean Air acts that
we had discussed in other versions of
this bill and I don't know if you want
to go through some of the other
technical challenges as well thanks
um so one of the issues that we've
identified is that the the bill does not
set a limit on the number of licenses
allowed to be held by a single entity
such limits are considered to be an
important Safeguard against large
corporate interests from dominating the
Kansas cannabis industry in in New
Hampshire and the last issue concern I'd
like to raise is that the bill does not
require that Cannabis Testing
Laboratories be independent the bill
would allow a testing laboratory to be
owned and operated by the same entity
that owns a cultivation manufacturing or
retail cannabis facility creating a
potential conflict of interest between
the testing lab and the products they
are testing
we've identified a number of issues that
are recommendations for improvement of
the bill
um I'd like to just go go through them
I'll provide the written testimony Upon
Our close it has more detail but for
instance the uh the duties of the
Cannabis Advisory board that was
mentioned earlier could be expanded to
require the board to expert exercise its
expertise on certain issues for example
from a public health perspective the
board could be required to consider and
make recommendations on such things as
potency serving size advertising
restrictions and testing requirements
secondly the proposal to transfer the
therapeutic cannabis program from the
Department of Health and Human Services
to the Cannabis commission would be
better made to go to the HHS oversight
committee rather than the standing
policy committees
another issue is that there is no
explicit exemption from taxation or
therapeutic cannabis patients when
purchasing from a retail cannabis store
under the proposed endorsement model nor
is there a clear method for enforcing
the limit on untaxed cannabis for this
population
um
the uh the bill contains an opportunity
for New Hampshire licensed alternative
treatment centers to undergo a
for-profit conversion but this is a
one-time opportunity
um removing the December 31st 2024
deadline would provide more flexibility
for the atcs uh to enter the market
um
there's a Prohibition on certain types
of solvent extraction but no penalty for
violating that there's no prohibition on
vaping cannabis in public
and there's a number of technical issues
with regard to consistency of language
of cannabis and cannabis products
registration and licensure
regulations and rules Etc
um so
there's another uh the the testimony
that I'll hand out um has a little more
detail on this
um we are available to participate in
any subcommittee work with the committee
or uh the sponsors for making
improvements to this bill
we're happy to take any questions any
questions
see none thank you
okay uh chair will call on Matt Simon
from primeatc
Ure what
thank you chairman
this microphone's even shorter than it
looks
for the record my name is Matt Simon I
serve as director of public and
government relations for Prime
alternative treatment centers in New
Hampshire I'm testifying in support of
HB 639 I believe this is the most
thoughtful and well-crafted cannabis
bill that's been before this house
established in 2016 Prime ATC is one of
the non-profit alternative treatment
centers that's licensed to provide
therapeutic cannabis to registered
patients in New Hampshire we have
approximately 55 staff members we
operate a production facility in
Peterborough and dispensaries in
Merrimack and Chichester our ATC has had
only one Focus up to this point in our
existence and that is serving registered
patients here in New Hampshire
prior to taking this job I worked for 15
years on campus policy in New Hampshire
and other states gotten to see how some
of these laws have been implemented and
how some of them have worked out
I want to focus first and foremost on
how this bill would impact New Hampshire
from Prime atc's perspective
so with cannabis legalization there are
essentially two issues some people
really like cannabis legalization
because it expands personal freedom for
adults other people like cannabis
legalization because it presents an
opportunity for Meaningful regulation
and consumer protection so I'm here to
support this bill for both of those
reasons I think successful cannabis
legalization policy both expands freedom
for adults and balances that with
effective regulation that is simply not
possible when the product is produced
transported and sold in an illicit
unregulated Market
so I think this bill does that
some of the concerns we've had about
previous bills that have been considered
uh first and foremost some of them have
not thoughtfully sought to integrate the
therapeutic cannabis program into the
new adult use regime
this bill takes a very thoughtful slow
deliberative approach to that transition
to make sure that patients are not left
behind to make sure that atcs are
required to continue prioritizing
patients if in fact they do expand to
serve the adult use market and
ultimately envisioning a process where
these new businesses could seek a
therapeutic cannabis certification as Mr
Holt mentioned ultimately expanding
access for patients if we don't expand
access for patients there are only seven
dispensaries in the state
if we had 100 adult use stores say and
seven medical dispensaries that would be
much better access for adults than for
registered patients so we don't want to
leave patients behind we want to make
sure that their options improve uh as
options for adults improved and this
required quite a lot of thought that the
Coalition put into this so I would
encourage you to keep that in mind as
you consider any changes
secondly more broadly would this
legislation create a broad distribution
of economic opportunities or would it
only benefit a few corporations or the
state itself
this is a business that has been
prohibited and underground and illegal
for many decades
this I've come to view this as a really
awesome opportunity really a one-time
opportunity to transition from a
prohibited unregulated Market into a
regulated market there are a lot of ways
to get it right and a lot of ways to get
it wrong over taxation is one way over
regulation is one way
I think this bill crafts a very good
approach to that and make sure that
we're not simply transitioning to yet
another industry we're only a few
uh entities get to make money or the
state itself that we're giving people an
opportunity to exceed to succeed in the
New Hampshire cannabis industry
and spreading that opportunity broadly
third point is does the bill repair
damage caused by the war on cannabis
such as including Provisions to an all
past criminal records so we've heard
that cannabis has decriminalized in New
Hampshire that is true up to a point in
2017 the state decriminalized possession
of three-quarters of an ounce or less
replacing a criminal penalty with a 100
fine so anybody caught with three
quarters of an ounce or less is
currently being fined uh anybody with
more than three quarters of an ounce is
still committing a criminal offense so
it's legal to buy an ounce in
Massachusetts if I buy an ounce in
Massachusetts I'm committing a crime
when I cross the border and could be
arrested for that so there still are a
number of arrests happening I think the
ACLU will present the exact numbers
but as we transition to legality we want
to make sure that if businesses are
going to make a lot of money off this
the state's going to make a lot of money
off this there are still thousands of
granted stairs walking around with
criminal records that are holding them
back economically and we want to make
sure that there is fairness restored to
the greatest extent possible
so I think the bill does that at least
to a significant extent and fourth Point
final Point does it create a sensible
transparent regulatory process to
protect consumers and minimize any
potential impacts so I'm here to tell
you cannabis is not harmless not
harmless full stop it's less harmful
than alcohol
and as we've learned from alcohol the
harms associated with alcohol are much
better managed through a regulated
system than they were during the 1920s I
think we should view this issue through
a similar lens this is an opportunity to
transition from the violence and
Corruption and unregulated products of
prohibition and and get to a better
place but I do think the independent
Advisory Board is a key feature of that
other states have found that having
oversight of that implementation process
is really important we're always
learning new things from other states
and the best states I think have been
able to adapt on the fly as they learn
new things
the last point I want to make
we've all heard that cannabis is
available on the illicit market we've
heard that it's available right across
the borders I haven't heard anybody
point out that it's also available in
New Hampshire and I don't mean from the
atcs so hemp cultivation was legalized
by the the farm bill in 2018 which
created a national hemp industry at the
time most people didn't realize that you
could grow a field of hemp harvest the
CBD from that hemp and then chemically
convert it into a THC product
so you can walk into some New Hampshire
gas stations some New Hampshire vape
shops and you will see products that
look like cannabis products and in fact
they are THC products they're derived
from hemp some of them have been not
really tested on humans they're really
kind of very alarming to a lot of us who
are quite comfortable with regular
cannabis one in particular is called THC
acetate or thco which is more
intoxicating by all accounts than
regular THC I got a picture on my phone
from a Sunoco gas station in New
Hampshire where this product is sitting
right there on the counter and I don't
know if people were being carded to buy
these things I know they are an
independently lab tested I know they
aren't regulated these are THC products
they cause impairment any any problem
that could be caused by cannabis itself
could be caused and arguably and then
some by something like
THC acetate so
THC is here cannabinoids are here one of
the features of this bill is it would
put the sale of all GHC products under
the purview of one single cannabis
Commission
thank you for your time
thank you any questions from the
committee
see none thank you very much
chair will call on Beth scare from
Nashua
hi I'm committee members I'm testifying
today because marijuana has devastated
my family
my older brother started smoking
marijuana at a young age and as a
teenager he became a paranoid
schizophrenic
he's been homeless most of the last 50
years of his life
and this happened back in the 70s when
marijuana had a very low level of THC
with the new dangerous high THC products
many more families are suffering the
same Devastation that we have
and on your desk
I handed you this article from Tablet
Mag
and um I read some very scary statistics
in that article how weed became the new
OxyContin
if you've ever smoked a bowl and became
a rationally anxious that everyone is
staring at you and knows you're high
what you experienced was a mild symptom
of cannabis induced psychosis according
to one study about 40 percent of people
react this way
If you experience that paranoia and keep
smoking on a regular basis nonetheless
especially with today's high potency THC
products and especially if you're young
there's a good chance you'll eventually
suffer a full psychotic break
35 percent of young people who
experience psychotic symptoms according
to another study eventually have such an
episode
and if you keep using after that you run
a decent risk of ending up permanently
schizophrenic or bipolar
cannabis has by far the highest
conversion rate to schizophrenia of any
substance higher than meth higher than
opioids higher than LSD
two Danish studies as well as a massive
study from Finland put your chances at
close to 50 percent
one out of every 20 daily users can
expect to develop schizophrenia if they
don't quit
according to Dr Christine Miller an
expert on psychotic disorders
you can read the rest at bitly NH
hb639 that's bitly
nh-hb639 please vote on an expedient to
legislate on hb639 to spare other
families from the same strategy tragedy
thank you very much for your testimony
uh Frank Knack of the ACLU of New
Hampshire
Mr chairman members of the committee
thank you so much for the opportunity to
testify my name is Frank Knack I'm the
policy director with the ACLU of New
Hampshire
um you have my written testimony so I
won't read it verbatim uh if it's okay
with y'all I'd like to First just talk
about some of the issues that have been
raised and some of the questions you all
posed I think the first is regarding the
polling and there was a question around
age groups and particularly older age
groups and support and so I looked at
that UNH poll just to make sure you all
had that information right now
uh according to that same UNH poll that
Senator Whitley
referenced earlier
for age 65 and over uh the support
category was 64 of people 65 and older
supported
um 13 were neutral and 23 opposed for 50
to 64 age group 71 supported 13 were
neutral and 16 opposed and then when you
get down to the youth 18 to 34 or Young
Folks it's 92 percent support four
percent neutral four percent opposed and
again that was a cross I looked at
Regional that was across all regions of
New Hampshire there was strong support
and even among political parties they
even broke it down by a political party
and so among Republicans you were at 60
support 29 opposed Democrats 85 percent
support four percent opposed
independence 80 support 9 opposed so
across all political parties across all
jurisdictions in New Hampshire across
all ages there's strong support for this
legislation and again we're here in
support of hb639
um I also there were some questions
around traffic fatalities and
particularly in um in New Hampshire post
legalization uh starting uh with Maine
and UK and Vermont and Massachusetts and
so first just noting that uh there's
been studies that looked at all the
states
um and I cite this in my in my fact
sheet that I gave you all but that it
appears that marijuana legalization has
had quote little to no effect unquote on
traffic accidents and fatalities and
specific to the question in New
Hampshire after that was asked earlier I
went and looked at the state highway
traffic report for New Hampshire from
the U.S Department of Transportation and
in 2016 when our first neighbor
legalized we were at 136 annual deaths
on the traffic on traffic and traffic
fatalities in 2020 the most recent data
available we're at 104. so from 136 to
104 and if some people might argue 2020
was a covid year less people are driving
if we just go back a year to 2019 where
we were at 101. so substantially fewer
so we're not saying that it is safe but
as Matt Simon talked about we're not
arguing here that marijuana is a safe
product
unregulated but that that's exactly what
this bill is trying to do have a
regulated product
to ensure that we have safer communities
and again there's been a lot of talk
about youth use
and so I want to point specifically to a
study by the Journal of the American
Medical Association where they say
recreational marijuana laws were
associated with an eight percent
decrease in the odds of marijuana use
and a nine percent decrease in the odds
of frequent marijuana use again this is
from the America Journal of the American
Medical Association
um and to get to our main uh our you
know from the aclu's perspective our our
main talking points on this issue you
know I think while we've made great
progress you know we are now we have
decriminalized marijuana but people are
still facing the rest for marijuana we
looked at the FBI UCR data which is the
data that you know agencies in New
Hampshire provide to the FBI so that we
know crime stats in New Hampshire and
arrest stats in New Hampshire
and in 2021 the most recent year
available uh of 1120 people were
arrested and so while the vast majority
of these those people are not going to
jail
they are still having a criminal
conviction on their record
um and that has huge collateral
consequences in terms of their ability
to get employment to get housing
Etc and so it sets people up with
additional hurdles that are completely
unnecessary to live productive and
healthy lives
I think it's really also important from
our perspective to look at this as a
racial justice issue and so the FBI UCR
data portal in 2021 didn't provide the
racial breakdown so we're still
analyzing it from the spreadsheets but
going back to 2020
this is an issue where we know black
people and white people from robust
research use marijuana at roughly the
same rate nationally black people are
about 3.6 times more likely to be
arrested than white people for marijuana
possession
in New Hampshire it's 4.6 times more
likely so we're significantly higher
than the national average and that
disparity has actually gone up from 2.6
times back in 2010 so we've seen a 46
percent increase in the racial
disparities in marijuana arrests in our
state
and also we have to look at this as from
a fiscal perspective so it's not only
the revenue that would come in through
legalization but we also have to think
about what we are spending now on the
enforcement of marijuana possession laws
so each of those 1100 plus marijuana
arrests that we had in the past year
involved Court actors they involved law
enforcement and so the ACLU had done a
report a while back where we calculated
with an economist the cost the average
cost for each marijuana at rest and so
putting that methodology to the current
arrest numbers we're spending about 2.6
million dollars every year in New
Hampshire just enforcing our marijuana
possession laws alone
um so we think it's time for New
Hampshire to move forward we think this
is a responsible bill you know some of
the issues that were raised from folks
about other states this bill is taking
all the best practices from the states
there's robust protections to keep
children from getting access to these
it's a big Bill that has been had a lot
of thought put into it and we would
appreciate your support and happy to
answer any questions
okay any questions
see none thank you very much thank you
chair calls on Liz Barber from Hollis
thank you chairman hunt and the entire
committee for hearing my testimony today
my name is Liz Barber and I'm a resident
of Hollis New Hampshire I'm here to
speak in opposition to this bill
I have grave concerns about the adverse
results of the commercialization of
marijuana on public health and Public
Safety the legislation of marijuana will
normalize its use and tell our
vulnerable teen population that it's
okay to use it it's legal
aren't you concerned that we would lose
more and more of our teens to The
Addictive quality of marijuana
I know that some committee members are
medical professionals to you I ask Will
you share information about The
Addictive qualities of THC and the real
hazards such as THC toxicity and
cannabis use disorder with the committee
let's not normalize marijuana use for
teens regular marijuana use can impair
memory and concentration and may
interfere with learning
it's also associated with lower odds of
completing high school or getting
college degrees
regular use of marijuana linked to
psychological problems and higher chance
of substance use disorder in adulthood
even using marijuana one time can alter
motor control coordination and judgment
this can contribute to unintentional
deaths and injuries
I'd like to tell you a teen addicted
story
Ethan Andrews started smoking marijuana
during his sophomore year of high school
in Colorado to help with his anxiety
his casual marijuana use turned to
smoking potent cannabis flour and
concentrates known as dabs which contain
high levels of THC Andrews said he
smoked every day from morning to night I
couldn't think or sleep without it he
said
two years after becoming an avid
marijuana user Ethan developed cannabis
induced psychosis a condition including
severe hallucinations delusions and
paranoia
I had to quit my job because the voices
in my head were so distracting Ethan
said
in conclusion I ask that you consider my
testimony today along with the testimony
of others who are speaking against the
bill New Hampshire is an island
surrounded by States who have legalized
marijuana and are now spending thousands
of dollars maybe hundreds of thousands
of dollars on additional Medical Care
and Mental Health Care related to
marijuana use
if you support this bill you will need
to explain to us how the dollars balance
out Revenue versus increased Medical
Care and the cost of losing so many
productive lives and Futures to this
highly addictive drug
please let New Hampshire continue to be
The Shining beacon on the hill that puts
our people first and Promises Bright
Futures to our children I humbly ask
that you vote no on this Bill thank you
any questions see none thank you very
much
chair will Colin Powell to me from
Chichester
thank you Mr chairman
um and my background of the former house
legal counsel I'm also a member of the
Coalition that originally put together
the proposals that are in this bill
um and I was a member of the commission
the state commission that studied for
the legalization of marijuana in 2017.
um before I go on I'd encourage any of
you to take a look at that the materials
with that there are some studies that
will answer some of the questions I've
heard today there's a Nitza study on
whether or not being impaired with
marijuana basically it does some things
to you that make you more impaired but
it also makes people drive slower and so
Nissa didn't actually come to any
overall conclusions that being said
nobody should Thrive under any
substances whatsoever
um
I had a I had a prepared statement that
you have that has a lot of sort of
technical things and talks about
amendments but I'd like to talk to a
couple things and be brief about my own
personal experiences about 10 days ago I
had a infection and I was put on an
antibiotic
and after about two days I had a very
bad reaction to it my face started
swelling I had to rush to an Urgent Care
before the doctor's office were opened
they gave me some
advice and then later that night the
swung started going down towards my
throat and I was told get to an
emergency room as quick as you can
leaving church after I drove by the
Epson police station I drove by the
Chichester police station I drove by the
Concord Police Station on the way to
Concord Hospital and it never occurred
to me once to stop and ask a police
officer for medical advice or for health
advice I had many friends that are
police officers I never call them up and
ask them for how to deal with health
problems there will be health problems
if you legalize cannabis you already
have the health problems here and it
comes from the Cannabis that you can buy
legally out of state and the Cannabis
you can buy on the street Which is far
more dangerous because it's not
regulated I heard several people say
well the black market will still
you'll always go lower
um if you make the taxes high enough
that's true but when was the last time
that you saw somebody selling
um bear on the street corners you know
opening up the coat and saying hey you
want to buy some beer they don't do that
because they can't compete with a legal
regulated structure and if you do this
right you will destroy the black market
in the state and that will do make
everybody safer in the state
there are
I was a public defender for many years
and I spent probably 46 years as a
criminal defense lawyer
um I don't haven't done that for the
last five or six years except for when
there are vets that have help problems
with getting housing or jobs because
marijuana cannabis prohibitions the VA
until very recently was very strict on
that so I would do criminal cases for
them
in the 46 years of doing
criminal defense I never had a client
plead guilty to possession of marijuana
simple possession I had people convicted
of all kinds of drug things but nobody
was ever convicted of possession of
marijuana in the last 20 years I have
never seen anybody with a lawyer
convicted of possession of marijuana it
just doesn't happen because prosecutors
don't want to take the time it takes to
actually prove the case so they always
change it to something or they give some
sort of a deal but it goes away nobody
with a lawyer who has the resources to
get a lawyer gets convicted of marijuana
now but people do get convicted and the
people that get convicted are the poor
kids that can't afford a lawyer on their
own and don't want to apply for State
Warrior because they know they're going
to have to pay it back and if they don't
pay it back they're going to go to jail
those kids walk into arraignments
without lawyers and they plead guilty
all the time because they're told that's
the easy way up they don't know the
consequences they don't know what's
going to haunt them for the rest of
their lives they don't know they'll have
problems getting good jobs
all they're basically their future is
taken from them and stolen from them for
something that we you know if you come
from a well to do background you'd never
pay that price that those poor kids paid
you can see it every day in the
arraignments in district courts around
here those are the people that get
convicted of possession of marijuana
that's whose Futures you will be saving
more than anybody else so I urge you
um to to I support the spelling I urge
you to pass it and to stop the one-sided
Madness of trying to treat health
problems as police problems they're not
police problems they're health problems
and we need health professionals part of
this bill puts money towards build
beefing up our
um Health Care system and counseling
system
there is one particular thing I'd like
to talk about which is the problem with
Edibles there have been recent studies
showing that Edibles themselves that
high potency Edibles can potentially be
a real serious problem for very young
children there's different ways to deal
with that and you know one one way is to
try to change the behavior of their
caretakers and teach them to be a little
bit more careful and I'm going to submit
some proposals to do that but you should
also give some careful thought to having
potency limits on Edibles because unlike
the smoke stuff which you you know how
strong it is right away with Edibles you
don't know for hours and people will
keep eating them and eat them and eat
them and then all of a sudden they're
going to have some real serious problem
so I'd ask you to give some thought to
that aside from that I'd ask you to
people listen to people like Kate gray
over there from new Futures to the
marijuana policy project people the ACLU
um
and
with Ben Ross over here from AFP
um they all they all have very good
specific recommendations for amendments
on air juwado listen to them I don't
take questions if you want them
thank you we're all set thank you Paul
uh Bob Dunn
representing the Roman Catholic bishop
of Manchester in opposition
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee I'm Bob Dunn the director of
public policy for the Roman Catholic
Diocese of Manchester and I'm here today
on behalf of Bishop Peter labashi to
register our opposition to HB 639 and
I've provided some written testimony
um I'm not here to present any religious
arguments but I am here to ask you to
take a look at
something that sort of overlaps between
the religious and the secular and that
is the principle of the common good
which as you all know is laid out in the
very first article of the New Hampshire
Constitution as
uh the reason or one of the reasons that
government is instituted as it says it's
instituted for the general good and then
article uh three goes on to say that the
protection of others is one of the
foundational purposes of our society so
that's the way that we're looking at
this and that we ask you to consider as
you deliberate on this
I've um in the written testimony laid
out four questions that we'd ask you to
think about as you undertake your
deliberations
will legalization
Advance the safety of our youth and
improve family life in New Hampshire
number two will legalization improve the
public health
number three will legalization improve
communities
and number four will legalization make
people better workers and strengthen our
business Workforce
now in our view
we think the answer to those questions
is no and that's why we oppose it but I
ask you to think about those as you
Ponder this legislation and for those
reasons we ask you to vote against the
legalization of marijuana thank you Mr
chairman so I have a question for you
Bob yes taking that list
when our forefathers and their wisdom
decided to create the State Liquor
Commission
did it meet those values that you just
said
uh I you know I don't know that Mr chair
one of the things though is obviously
liquor was something that was very much
a part of society at the time that the
it was illegal it was a Prohibition so
the end of the prohibition no I'm
talking about at the time of the
founding without it that's true so uh
um
you know I'm confident that the founding
fathers would have had no problem with
with liquor right I think George
Washington had it with his own whiskey
this Hillary yeah but I was just saying
that it's interesting you read that list
because I would think about what
happened when the prohibition ended and
New Hampshire unlike its other
neighboring states it chose to dress I
think those issues by creating the
Liquor Commission
would you believe it would you believe
representative has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for your
testimony I'm intrigued by question one
particularly in light of other testimony
that we've received today which boils
down to what about the children
what do you think is the role of
families and parents in
protecting children from the alleged
evils of marijuana at what point does it
become the role of families simply to
help their children too
avoid marijuana or to avoid becoming
addicted to marijuana it seems to me
that throughout this discussion we we've
had parental abdication of
responsibility that suddenly we've left
children to the streets to wander and
find marijuana
where do you think parents are in this
discussion
Central role uh absolutely but I think
that the the state government has a role
to play in that right and so at a time
when that we have a severe substance
misuse crisis in the state I think the
state is sending the wrong signal by
saying this is okay I think that the
state owes it to families to make it as
easy as possible for families
to work with their children and to keep
them safe
for the question
as a follow-up do you think children
really pay attention to State policy
what can you say that again
representative I'm sorry do you think
children pay attention to State policy
well I'm the parent of children so
um you know I don't know what children
will pay attention to at any given time
but
um the uh no but their parents do right
and and
um and and kids know what the state says
is okay
and that makes a big difference I think
representative amen has a question
thank you this is a short question uh
from a theological
um perspective since you're from the
diocese uh is it is it uh if if a
parishioner smokes marijuana is that
grounds for excommunication in the
church I'm just curious
uh I I'm not a theologian but I don't
believe that is representative no
okay thank you very much
uh Nathaniel Gurion of New Hampshire
cannabis party
thank you Mr chairman and uh members of
the committee for giving me a few
moments to
chat about cannabis legalization
um I am the executive director of the
New Hampshire cannabis party
which
was endorsed by over a hundred
candidates for Statewide office during
the last election cycle for its um
position on
um
Common Sense smart cannabis legalization
a lot of which is highlighted on our
website
um
I am also the CEO of a fincan which
provides a Banking and Financial
Services to the Cannabis industry as
well as to Banks around the country
um and I also write a bi-monthly column
for the um pardon me for the Conway
Daily Sun covering the New Hampshire
cannabis industry
um
I think probably one of the first most
important points to make is that this is
not a partisan issue this is not a
political issue
this is an economic issue
um this cannabis legalization
is a much more potentially a much more
impactful
um and positive uh
um
Initiative for our economy we could
either have me too legislation that is
relatively similar to the states around
us and other states taken to account
some of the
mistakes they've made and try to improve
on them
and have good legislation
we would um
significantly increase the prosperity of
the state by doing that
or we can lead
and have groundbreaking legislation
that really accomplished a great deal
and turbocharged our economy
um
and created really a gold brush for this
state and for its residents
that would really be generational
um
one thing that I think people may be
aware of is that certainly in the in the
Cannabis economy there are obviously
jobs and prosperity and revenue that
will be created by people who actually
handle a plant they
run dispensaries they manufacture they
cultivate they distribute they test
product and so on
but what has happened in the Cannabis
industry and I think that happens in a
lot of other Industries is that that
core activity is supported by a a
incredibly wide range of
vendors professionals
service providers they can be attorneys
they could be CPAs they could be people
who build social media people who sell
equipment people who sell soil build
greenhouses construction professionals
so the more robust a cannabis economy
that we encourage and that we enable the
more robust many many other sectors of
the economy will become
um
a couple of little details on the bill
that's proposed which the New Hampshire
cannabis party fully supports
several of the people who spoke before
me including
um uh leader Osborne um you know
mentioned that there was a significant
Coalition and collaboration in producing
this particular bill
um of of which I had some input also and
I think that it represents a very very
good start on Smart Common Sense
cannabis legalization
um but a couple of little things on the
bill just to take a note of that's
already in there
um
one is that it makes reference to
cannabis seeds
roughly several months ago maybe four
six months ago the DEA there was a
significant amount of confusion as to
whether cannabis seeds and hemp seeds or
whether they were cannabis whether they
were hemp how they should be regulated
the DEA came out with a very very clear
guidance several months ago that said
that all seeds cannabis or hemp are
otherwise were going to be treated as
hemp and regulated as hemp and I think
that was actually
um
um a pretty rational and good approach
to that and it has created a significant
amount of order in the marketplace my
recommendation would be to do the same
thing and not to try to put cannabis
seeds which contain no THC
um into the same pocket as cannabis and
regulate it that way because the market
is really actually beginning to pick up
some speed
um and and there's really doesn't seem
to be any downside it's all just kind of
a good positive thing
um
there's also um
Provisions in this particular
legislation for tracking inventory and
for close regulation of cannabis
a significant amount of the close
tracking of money and inventory is as a
result of the fact that um
it's uh there's still Federal
prohibition on cannabis uh you know
cannabis entirely and that in 2014 the
U.S department of the treasury came out
with guidelines for banks and for um for
cannabis operators
that would allow them to navigate
legally
um the compliance issues that are
created by that tension between federal
and state law and the only reason I
mentioned that is because at this
particular point that type of Regulation
and that close tracking of the money and
of the inventory is a necessary uh
um I don't know if I'd call it an evil
but it's def definitely a necessary
component to navigate through the
tension between state and federal law
but it would be very important that we
sunsetted a certain amount of that
um
pretty rigorous tracking of money and
inventory when Federal prohibition is
over in the same sense that that type of
Regulation was lifted and eased when
hemp became legal and became no longer a
um
a
federally scheduled narcotic right now
the the regulation over hemp is largely
concerned about making sure that people
selling hemp and hemp related products
stay in an arbitrary sandbox of less
than 0.3 percent THC and of course it's
actually all really the same plant but
at this particular moment because hemp
has been carved out by that definition
as being different a lot of the the
regulatory obligations of
um of anyone in the hemp or cannabis
business or um
all of the anti-money laundering and
careful tracking of inventory and money
has fallen by the wayside when the
federal prohibition on hemp ended
um and I I think it would be important
to
um relax that also on cannabis
when Federal prohibition is over and
these are just little details about the
bill um what I actually want to talk
about more and which I think is a lot
more compelling is what's not in the
bill and probably should be
um
but a couple of other things that um you
know are in the Bill one is that I think
that there's a strong uh sentiment on a
lot on the part of a number of policy
makers to have no cap on licenses
um in New Hampshire as part of this bill
um and I've had conversations with
several leading lawmakers on that
um and um
and uh and at this particular moment it
would not be a good idea to do that
right away because it creates chaos in
the marketplace it creates a glut of
product that people can't really make a
profit on it and they are very tempted
to enter the black market and start
selling it all over the place
and there's a provision in the bill for
labeling testing and child proof
packaging and education and so on and
that's very good
okay I'm being asked to speed it up so
let me let me just mention a couple of
very quick important points that are not
in the bill one is that we should
encourage and incentivize through
Economic Development and tax incentives
um public-private Partnerships between
business and our AG universities for
research this will create a lot of very
good jobs likewise for pharmaceutical
research likewise for technology an
example of Technology would be
developing a sobriety test which
interestingly enough I was organizing an
event a few months ago before the
election where we were going to bring in
a number of different Business Leaders
and so on and two there are two
companies one in um on the west coast
and one in Canada on the west coast that
have developed uh effective sobriety
tests and for example encouraging them
to maybe establish operations in New
Hampshire would be a good thing
um but the other two things that I think
are most important and most compelling
I've saved for last one is that um as
I'm sure most of you guys know
um if you are a user of marijuana
um you uh have to disclose that on a
Firearms transaction uh form
um and if you lie about it which most
people do
um you are obliged when exercising your
constitutionally protected
um Second Amendment rights you are
obliged to commit a federal crime in
order to proceed with that transaction
that is something that we can and we
should fix when we put together cannabis
legislation it's completely doable and
we can protect these citizens and
residents of New Hampshire from
prosecution and
um and any adverse consequences
um with that and I will say that I think
that anyone who really supports that is
likely to make themselves the darling of
the Second Amendment constituent in
constituencies in this state and
nationally
and I think it would be doing the
citizens and residents of New Hampshire
a great service and it would also I
think be the kind of thing that it would
be important to support the other thing
is that what we can do is there is
actually no federal prohibition on
interstate commerce
the Constitution gives Congress the
right to regulate interstate commerce
but they are not regulating it as
regards cannabis at this point however
in deference to that every state so far
that has legalized cannabis has put into
their law that interstate and you know
interstate commerce is prohibited but
the prohibition does not in fact emanate
from the feds it emanates from the
individual states that prohibited
um if we were
to allow interstate commerce and
international Commerce we would open a
open up a Floodgate Of investment and
prosperity for New Hampshire and we
would be leading the nation with that
that is also doable
um it's doable legally
and you know it would really it would
create a situation in New Hampshire
where we would have a an incredible Boon
as a result of this legislation
so um I'm going to mention only uh in
the context of that this is essentially
in support of 639 just to comment on on
544 that uh you know 544 is the
antithesis of that that tends to
suffocate Commerce uh with uh having the
liquor Authority as the sole distributor
of it
um and it would also channel that
suffocated Commerce to a very narrow
band of beneficiaries rather than
broadly in the state anyway that's
what I wanted to say for any questions
very much
I think we're all set
chair Colin Kaylee Glenn
Coalition for the Youth
there we go okay hello everyone
um thank you chair thank you committee
for being here on the snowy day to
listen to me
um I'm Haley mcglenn I'm a 16 year old
senior at Raymond High School and I'm
here to offer a perspective that
otherwise might have gone unseen with
everyone else here
so Through The Eyes of a high school
student in 2023
I park my car in the student parking lot
and walk in try to ignore be it
overwhelming whiff of marijuana
emanating from the cars in the next row
over I've told administrators before but
nothing has been done so now I just keep
walking
flag one the adult complacency regarding
the use of the substance have paved a
path for our youth to be desensitized
from the danger of this drug this was a
place of learning
it is early Monday morning and I walk
into my block one class the girl I sit
next to is stoned out of her mind
giggling to herself
she looks over me and slurred and
incoherently says it's fine oh my God I
just had a little bit of my mom's stuff
this morning
I look over nervously and try to make
some sense out of what I just heard
flag too kids and adults are not mature
enough to understand the effects of
marijuana and are too overcome by the
high it provides so that's just another
thing to do
I wait until 9 30 to use the bathroom
that's usually when all the girls clear
out from their first hangout session and
to my disappointment they're still there
as I wash my hands they are all silent
and I turn to the sink and one of them
speaks you better not tell right I'll
give you a hit
she hands me a dab pen and I politely
decline
whatever but you better not tell still
I turn off the water
yeah sure you're entitled to ruining
your own life
but then I remembered She's Not Just
ruining her own life
is ruining the but these are my peers
and this is the generation of our future
Society
flag four if this doesn't scare you what
does
I want to be able to walk through the
student parking lot and smell nothing
but cold New England air I want our
youth to walk into their block one class
and sit next to a conscious and coherent
classmate our kids need to be able to
use the bathroom without fear Judgment
of tattling due to illicit and illegal
activities on school grounds when did
the bathroom become synonymous with drug
use
sadly many of my peers have not
responded have not received the crucial
support that from the adults in their
life but they can with their help
take the time to talk to the teens
around you and be the adult they can go
to but either way
hb639 cannot be passed without exposing
the youth to these dangers of this drug
And in regards to previous testimony the
government the governor's youth
advisement Council and kid Governor pay
attention to the laws being put into
place
um and I believe that myself today is a
very obvious example that the youth pay
attention to what is happening in our
big enforcement and going on with the
laws today
um thank you and I'm hoping to any
questions inquired
that was a great job thank you very much
okay I have five cards left they're all
in favor so I'll hope these people will
be a model of brevity
uh
uh Brett Scott from Hook said
cannabis Haven
my name is Brett Scott and I'm a vocal
entrepreneur based here out of Concord
New Hampshire I have 17 retail locations
in various industries from tobacco
medical retail cannabis
I don't use retail cannabis and
cultivation
and I just wanted to uh submit my
information
to you know potentially be of assistance
as somebody that's from the end industry
it's a local entrepreneur I have stores
in Maine as I mentioned for medical and
adult use as well as cultivation so this
would be uh happy to assist in any way
if possible so I want to give my
information thank you
awesome thank you very much
chair will call on uh Brogan rod from
Devin's no Gavin's Fall Road doesn't say
where town he's from
rod
coming once going twice
okay
uh Randall kellig from Bristol
afternoon
excuse me I just want to thank you all
for volunteering your time to be here
today also um I know what it's like to
volunteer and uh
sometimes that commitment can be very
time consuming I want to clear up a few
things that I heard today
first of all it's our state constitution
not the Federal Constitution that is
what we're Guided by
second Edibles are not 90 most are not
more than 20 percent and you cannot die
from eating marijuana
as much as that is
expressed it's an impossibility
um you know the state is concerned about
the legalization of cannabis yet we
expanded one of the most addictive drugs
on the planet which a state holds
Monopoly on alcohol
we've expanded that into some of the
most vulnerable communities in America
the lowest income they are the most
susceptible to addiction except this
state when we spend like 70 million
bucks to expand our alcohol distribution
that made sense right
there that had no negative impact on
those communities right
that's what I thought
anyways
but we fall back and the devil's lettuce
is an impossibility to legalize
accept the impacts of it are a lot less
impactful you know I've never seen
somebody or or heard from a police
officer or anybody expressed this
I've seen them beat their wife
what do you mean
when they consumed alcohol
never under the influence of marijuana
alone oh wait a minute they might beat
them to the fridge to get the better
Munchies that'll be the extent of the
violence that is portrayed from the
consumption of cannabis
legalization gives us control
you know you all worry about
Fentanyl and the 20 other things I'm
going to State something I'm a recovered
addict I just put a gram of heroin at my
nose a day
you know what got me off of that
cannabis
you know what straighten my life out
cannabis and you're all looking going
what how
here's some tidbits for you I'm the vice
chair of the planning board in Bristol
I'm the chair of the CIP committee I'm
on the downtown committee I am also on
the Emergency Management committee
is the icing of the cake I'm running for
vice chair the New Hampshire GOP
why because of this narrow-mindedness
it's absolutely absurd this just ices
the cake to some of it that I see
we need to open our minds in this state
to a lot of things
once again we'll expand the alcohol
distribution by 70 million bucks but the
devil's lettuce
I heard some talk about how
statistics are showing there's more
accidents in Colorado and stuff
if someone would have stuck around so I
could have questioned them if you look
at those statistics when you start out
at zero
and then you build those statistics what
do you think is going to happen they
didn't test for marijuana use prior to
its legalization
and marijuana can be in your system for
30 days 30 days
so they could test it no not an inkling
in the world on whether that marijuana
consumption caused that accident that's
a fact
gateway drug my parents never had a
cannabis cabinet that's what I'm going
to say okay there was never any cannabis
in my home
alcohol
that's what got
me on the road to addiction alcohol
but yet the state expanded it by 70
million bucks
imagine that huh
and there's ridiculous
suggestion that ER visits will will and
have increased that's because we've
softened Society to the point of
victimhood
everybody runs to the to the emergency
room if they waited 15 minutes they'll
be okay because that's the only thing
that comes from over consumption of
cannabis is feeling uncomfortable
other than that
15 minutes you're done that's why they
can't get a test score
DUI for cannabis because if I sit by the
time I sit on the road 10 minutes later
I'm ready to rock and roll down the road
because 90 of the high that I consumed
prior to being stopped is gone 15 20
minutes half an hour later
tops
it's absurd the 1956 mentality that we
apply to this it's not what we think it
is
I have Lyme disease
you know what that cures
I mean I don't think you understand the
benefits of cannabis for those who have
Lyme disease
it's off the charts and we talked about
suicide
suicide was created by the covet
lockdowns it wasn't created by the
consumption of cannabis and I know how
many veterans
who have helped their help themselves to
deal with this world because of the
consumption of cannabis I could go on
and on about this I just want this
committee to know that I think we're
thinking about all of this in such a
1956 mentality
and that's people there's actually
people that can do this without ruining
their lives
how many people do you know has a casual
drink every night
they still exist right but if you smoke
a joint
you're Straight to Hell
that's absurd
it's absolutely absurd so please think
about this in a logical manner think
about the people who are innocent people
like myself
that can get arrested and have our whole
Futures ruined or spend thousands of
dollars fighting why
do what
something that only affects me
because the law says it's different
it's absurd
God bless New Hampshire God Bless
America and God bless all of you thank
you thank you
uh Ross Connolly Merrimack
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee uh for the record my name is
Ross Connolly I'm the deputy state
director for Americans for Prosperity
here to enthusiastically offer our
support for HP 639
as we've heard today New Hampshire is on
an island of prohibition surrounded by
States who have legalized for adult use
cannabis
although we are the last state in New
England to look at doing this
there's an opportunity there to see
learn lessons from the states around us
and develop a uniquely New Hampshire
system to address cannabis use
uh and we think HP 639 does just that uh
this legislation was developed uh
through a diverse Coalition of groups
from across the political Spectrum uh
all getting their input
um From afp's perspective we have three
principles that we really look at when
it comes to legalizing cannabis uh
regulations on cultivators uh ensure the
product goes through rigorous testing so
consumers are safe from containments
uh miners cannot access cannabis at
retail stores
and a system with minimal Taxation and
barriers to entry is established to push
out black market influence as much as
possible
the fact of the matter is if you are an
adult in New Hampshire you can go and
buy legal cannabis
they're just going to other states to
buy it and coming back here so any of
the the arguments from opponents uh of
some of the negative consequences we are
either already seeing or they uh have
not materialized
hb639 takes a balanced approach by
providing oversight through a commission
testing requirements for cultivators low
licensing fees for retail stores
this bill opposed to others takes a a
different approach by Levy by expanding
the meals and rooms tax which is 8.5
percent which would generate Revenue
to tackle some New Hampshire's most
pressing issues like paying off of a
pension liability and reducing property
taxes things that would benefit every
Granite stator uh you know there's a
hundred thousand plus Granite Staters
that use cannabis but not everyone would
obviously partake from a appease
perspective we're not saying that this
is a good thing and that everyone should
do it we're saying that it happens
people are using it they're buying it
now and uh if if they choose to use it
we should have a regulated market to
make sure that the the product is safe
but at the same time every Granite
stator can benefit from it uh by by
putting the revenue towards beneficial
areas like pensions and property taxes
uh we think uh one of the big keys in
this bill is private stores are are
critical to the mission to establishing
an industry that can effectively build
up Supply and reduce black market
influence
Granite State or Granite State
businesses who already operate highly
regulated markets like alcohol and
tobacco should be able to easily gain a
license and safely sell cannabis to
adults
it's well past time for New Hampshire to
acknowledge the reality that we're in
as I mentioned before any granite stator
is purchase that wants to is purchasing
it right now the only experience the the
only example you need and I encourage
everyone to do this is go down to
tingsborough or to Maine whatever's
closest to you and and Drive by one of
the the legal cannabis retail stores
there's
the entire parking lot is full with New
Hampshire plates uh and then they're
coming back here so we're basically
exporting an entire industry to other
states where we're letting them decide
what the regulations are what the
oversight is what the system of retail
stores is and we get none of the
benefits a good example is in the state
of Maine they do not require rigorous
testing that's something that's in this
bill to ensure that consumers are
protected from heavy metals or other
containments uh in the product
and and we believe New Hampshire in this
this situation can out-compete our
neighbors by setting up a uniquely New
Hampshire system that protects consumers
minors and reduces the size and scope of
government and and we believe that that
proposal is HB 639 so we encourage the
committee to move this bill ought to
pass I'd be happy to take any questions
if there are
representative Amman has a question
thank you Mr chair thank you for your
testimony um
not to put you on the spot there's a
section in here about Municipal
ordinances it gives local municipalities
the option to prohibit could you speak
to that if you're comfortable because I
don't think anyone's touched on that yet
uh thank you for the question
representative uh it was difficult to
hear you but I I think it was
um the the municipal ordinances uh my
understanding in the bill is you know
planning board zoning boards they they
can surely still decide whether uh wear
a cannabis store is is to go in town I
think that's reasonable there's a
thousand foot limit to being close to
any school and uh towns can vote to opt
out to not allow a cannabis store or
cultivation and cultivation or
manufacturing facility in their towns
and and in our mind that's that's
appropriate uh instead of an opt-in you
know that that's uh pretty consistent
with a lot of other Industries
great thank you
I have one more card here for house
bills 639 and the good news is I only
got five for the next one
not uh
uh former former Commerce member Joe
Hannon
thank you chairman hi
um I almost need theme music to come up
here with that introduction so I
appreciate it
um I'll try to make this brief because I
know it's the end but it probably won't
be brief so I'll just warn you
um stop me when you want
uh I'd like to start off by saying that
the the story of the prohibition the
failure of prohibition is one of the
oldest stories in existence
the former president of Mexico Vincente
fox said uh prohibition didn't work in
the guard Nevada and the in the Garden
of Eden Adam ate the apple this is not a
new problem we're experiencing
prohibiting something is not necessarily
going to stop people from doing it we
heard testimony that there are young
people that are using it in schools and
it's it's a problem with adults and
families these are not new things I've
been recovering from substance use since
1991 so it's about 30 plus 31 plus years
um and I was a teenager when I stopped
using uh illicit substances
I went on to become a doctor took a step
back became a legislator did okay in
life but uh prohibition was one of the
things that could have destroyed my life
had I been arrested for a felony
conviction we've had several presidents
that admitted to using cannabis and
other harder substances
no one got arrested or prosecuted or put
in prison for it they became president
of the United States
although one didn't inhale his defense
um
prohibition uh one of my favorite quotes
about Prohibition was that it has
brought nothing but trouble and my
favorite part about that quote is who
said it and it was Al Capone
you know prohibition has brought more
problems than the actual problems
themselves now I'm not discounting the
the problems with substance use I've
experienced it firsthand I've worked in
the recovery Community harm reduction
communities I've been on uh so many
commissions and panels and task forces
that I can barely count I was one of the
public members for the commission a few
years ago to study the regulation and
taxation of marijuana in 2018
so I I do know about the dangers of any
substance use
but I remember as a State Rep you get to
do some fancy things I got to go to an
opening of a liquor store in Epping when
it was a new store and the chairman I
think was Malik at the time came and
gave a speech about how we're selling
responsible regulated product that we
know what's in it no one's getting an
adulterated product no one's getting you
know unnecessarily sick or dying from it
as a surprise whatever it was it was an
amazing speech if you change the word
cannabis to alcohol it would have been
the same speech
and I kind of wish I'd recorded it for
that reason but I didn't unfortunately
but he did say so if you find him he's
still around asking
um
we have a current system where we have a
group that has a near Monopoly
and they allow some small organizations
to sell some of the product that they
sell they have enforcers they collect
money for uh the protection and
oversight and the regulation of that
industry and they they punish people
they find them and maybe put some people
in jail for not doing what they want
them to do and you may know it as the
Liquor Commission it's based on a Model
that when I heard about this when I
first sat in uh Commerce and they
discussed the Liquor Commission how it
runs how much money they made for the
state which was amazing at the time it
was three point some billion dollars for
the State of New Hampshire I'm like wow
that's amazing every year to go no since
1930 something I'm like okay it's a lot
of money but that money could also be
made in the in the private sector people
could start their own businesses more
money can be made tax money can be gone
can be raised Revenue can be raised we
have a drain of use in this state people
are always complaining all the young
people don't want to stay in New
Hampshire we keep getting older people
I'm slowly becoming one of them I
understand but
this is one issue that will prevent that
from happening not the only that's not
going to solve the problem but that is a
big issue that can solve the problem I
have nephews and nieces hey do you want
to ski yeah where are we going Vermont
yes yes you know now they have some nice
slopes but so do we
um
let's see
you know
the other thing is you know
since prohibition began drugs have
become cheaper they're easier to get and
they're more dangerous
you know nothing is improved with
prohibition you crack down on one
substance it gets smaller they crack
down on heroin they start making
fentanyl it's easier to smuggle fentanyl
a little bit heroin that much to get in
for the same amount to get high from
Cannabis everyone's like oh we're
getting such higher concentrations these
really serious levels of intoxicants to
get people really sick
I've seen liquor stores they sell grain
alcohol in almost every liquor store in
the state so it's not like they don't
have almost Pure or close to Pure
alcohol and it's the same thing with
cannabis during alcohol prohibition and
before alcohol prohibition back in in
the day
most alcohol out there was not nearly as
strong as it was today it became
stronger during prohibition because if
you're going to get caught smuggling
something or you have to smuggle
something as heavy as alcohol you're
going to try and make it more compact
it's easier to get through the Border
it's easier to sell it's easier to be
sneaky about it it's the same thing with
drugs and we've seen this with almost
every type of drug from you know opium
to methamphetamines it's been getting
worse and worse because of prohibition
now I'm not supporting I don't want
anyone to go out and start doing this
stuff I'm supporting legalization I'm
supporting HP 639 I don't plan on
smoking it if you see me smack it out of
my hand I get my permission I don't want
to do it I'm not I don't want anyone
else to be prohibited from doing it but
the main reason is prohibition is the
greater evil we've incarcerated people
we've wasted countless lives resources
and effort and I can guarantee that you
know you're going to hear other bills
every year ad nauseam the Commerce
Committee too because now you're in on
it welcome to the club this is going to
be an annual occurrence you have to sit
through for a long time this needs to be
done the question has always asked why
you know when is the time to legalize
the time is a long time ago the time was
never to do it and I hate the the term
to legalize something we are
re-legalizing something that was legal
for many many years it was only made
illegal in the 30s I believe slight uh
lift of that from us velocity back in
the late 60s and one year later they
made it illegal again
and what has it done it's ruined lives
so I'm asking you I'm begging you please
help New Hampshire stop ruining lives
and start the conversation so we can
have safer interactions with our youth
and be honest with them the worst thing
you can tell a young person is a lie
they're not going to believe you as an
adult as a parent I'm learning that I
have a teenager myself and if I say you
should never do this it's the devil's
lettuce it'll cause you to lose your
sanity and kill people they know I'm
lying they know you're lying when you
say that let's have a real conversation
if it's not illegal and adults can use
it responsibly and safely not all will
but many will it's happened with alcohol
then we can have a real conversation
with our children my kids have an easier
time getting alcohol than they do I'm
getting cannabis than they do getting
alcohol and last thing on the uh when I
was on the Cannabis of the study
commission we had a coalition of Youth
come in and they said oh it's everywhere
kids can't not if they can't avoid it's
in the bathrooms they can't get away
from it it's everywhere it's so easy to
get
so Don't Legalize It because it'll be
easier to get or something like that it
was ridiculous I couldn't believe that
we can't make something more easy to get
than it's so easy to get it's everywhere
so all we're doing is regulating making
it safer and protecting kids by not
being able to sell it to them I've never
bought drugs from harder drugs from
someone in a bar or a liquor store you
know you get you know something if
you're buying cannabis on the street as
a teenager or a young adult you're more
likely to have that same person to sell
you fentanyl or heroin that's not going
to happen in a regulated market whatever
the form is so please support this and
I'd be happy to take any questions or
you can go home
that wasn't you can ask me questions
okay thanks Joe good seeing you too
all right I'm going to close the hearing
on 6 39 and open up the hearing on 5 44
and hear from the prime sponsor
representative Eaton
thank you Mr chairman and unlike many
I'll try to hold of the three limits a
three minute limit I had the fortune to
have lunch with former speaker Jasper
this afternoon and we were reminiscing
how long this has been an issue in 1982
I was a ranking Dem on the Judiciary
Committee uh former speaker Jasper's on
Judiciary and former speaker scitec was
the chair of Judge Drake and during that
term we passed decriminalization of
possession of less than an ounce of pot
on the consent calendar through this
house
didn't survive the other side of the
wall but that's how long we've been
going with this the bill before you is
uh I take no Pride about the ship it's a
theft it is the bill that passed last
session with the addition of uh Edibles
added in because the Senate was the
stress that didn't have Edibles that's
the only difference between the prior
Bill and this one I would suggest that
you don't pass either
the prior bill you heard or this one and
I would strongly suggest that the
committee build a hybrid
I find objection to the prior bill in
trying to build a constituency out of
fund distribution
and you know as well as I do this bill
is probably going to go to Ways and
Means once you get done with it
they're going to decide what the real
fund distribution is and if you've been
on finance you know that it doesn't
matter what fund distribution is because
when the money gets tight you stick in
the word notwithstanding and all the
work you did on trying to decide
percentages and fund distribution
disappear
and it becomes non-existent if you're
going to deal with funding I would
suggest you get 50 for the cities and
towns 50 percent of the general fund and
when they figure out what kind of money
it's bringing in if they want to do a
special allocation let them do it them
uh but to do it now just makes
absolutely no sense I would hope you'd
retain the idea of no more than two
licenses for any individual or
Corporation so that you don't have a
bill that enables a cartel to be created
um
the arguments you've heard today in
opposition to either build
are virtually identical
to what was heard to
avoid coming out of prohibition it had
no value then it has no value that now
and the only thing prohibition does is
what it did
many years ago creates millionaires back
then billionaires today out of monsters
it serves no legitimate purpose we are
surrounded
and if people say this is going to
create a problem they get their heads in
the sand if there is a problem that's
already here but we're not getting any
money out of it to deal with solving the
problem I hope you will take both bills
create a hybrid and get something that
can pass muster across the hall and get
to the governor's desk and I'll be happy
to answer any questions I can a little
hour is late I hope you don't have any
thank you very much
okay uh
so uh we Department of Health and Human
Services they have a card in here uh
Michael Holt and Jenny Higgins you're
down just to you now right and um I
would say I would say that
um The Liquor Commission we do have a
representative here and the Liquor
Commission takes no position so I told
him that he doesn't have to put in a
card if he has nothing to say
okay go ahead guys
hi again Jenny Higgins just as a
reminder I'm the legislative liaison for
the Department of Health and Human
Services Division of Behavioral Health
and again for the record my name is
Michael Holt I'm the administrator of
the therapeutic cannabis program within
the division of Public Health Services
Department of Health and Human Services
once again the department doesn't have a
position on this bill but we would like
to share with you some concerns from a
public health perspective thank you
so there are some issues with house bill
um
544 that we have some concerns we want
to share with you from a public health
standpoint there are some basic cannabis
safety issues that are not addressed in
this bill including requirements for a
child resistant packaging potency and
serving size limit specific advertising
restrictions such as prohibitions on
Billboard advertising and requirements
for a universal symbol that a product
contains THC there are not social
justice and social Equity Provisions in
this bill there are some diversion
issues that are not addressed in that
specific inventory controls and an
electronic seed to sale inventory and
party of sale system is not required
there is no cannabis Advisory board
established which would allow for public
health Public Safety and other concerns
about harm reduction to be voiced and
considered as the adult use program is
being developed and implemented
funding for the preliminary public media
campaign and social media campaigns
about the risks of cannabis use may not
be sufficient to meet the purpose of a
comprehensive campaign
and and there are there are data and
surveillance issues that are not
addressed in the bill that will be
critical for New Hampshire to monitor
impact over time and be able to respond
and to prevention intervention treatment
and Recovery needs and there's no direct
funding to the department from and the
from anticipated Revenue that is set
aside for that prevention treatment and
Recovery issues the source of funds in
this bill is directed directed to these
concerns is from any fines imposed
those are some of our concerns I'll hand
it over to you Mike thanks Jenny
um
any any bill that legalizes cannabis for
adult use in a state that has a very
important therapeutic cannabis program
needs to thoughtfully consider its
impact to the state's therapeutic
cannabis program we have about 14
000 enrollees in our program
um and like I said any legalization
effort needs to consider their needs as
well
um this bill this bill does not
thoughtfully consider its impact to the
Cannabis program it's important that a
therapeutic program be maintained
um I know it's late in the day and I'll
and I'll try to I'll condense this
testimony but
um the the Crux here is that house bill
544 explicitly authorizes The Liquor
Commission to compete directly with the
atc's license in the state in fact the
bill requires state-run dispensaries to
sell therapeutic cannabis two
therapeutic cannabis patients
and essentially requires them to
function as alternative treatment
centers without the requirement for them
to be a non-not-for-profit entity
and that's important page 10 lines 8-13
it shall be the duty of the commission
to sell cannabis for therapeutic
purposes as authorized under RSA 126x
um
at best it sets up a dual regulatory
structure a duplication of effort where
uh the Department of Health and Human
Services and the Liquor Commission are
regulating the same uh the same entities
um but at the worst it jeopardizes the
the viability of the state's atcs
um and the access of 14 000 patients to
the therapeutic cannabis program
um there were a number of Provisions in
the previous bill that we heard
um that require and allow a soft Landing
if you will for the therapeutic canvas
program including uh collaboration and
consultation with the Department uh in
in making these large changes
um day one on this bill uh the the state
liquor stores will be able to sell
therapeutic cannabis the therapeutic
cannabis patients
um without the same regulatory structure
in place as for uh for um for the atcs
so again we are available and willing to
work on any legislation
um that this committee wants to uh put
put forward to address some of these
these needs I appreciate your time thank
you
any questions
seeing none your testimony you guys can
you make sure we get cups thank you good
thank you
okay sorry Kate you're you got stuck in
the wrong pile
so Cape fry for new futures
and it was being because I actually
filled out both bills on a card so I
apologize for doing that I will be very
brief and I have written testimony my
name is Kate fry I'm the vice president
of advocacy for new futures
um I'm actually providing testimony on
544 and 639 new Futures is a non-profit
non-partisan organization that Advocates
educates and collaborates to improve the
health and wellness of all New Hampshire
residents we work with policy makers
stakeholders and prevention Partners to
prevent and reduce alcohol and drug
problems in our state at e Futures we
believe that it is imperative to get
cannabis commercialization policy right
from the start optimal policy for our
state must utilize best available
scientific evidence to reduce public
harm limit Youth and problematic use and
Advance social justice and equity in the
state we've created principles for
cannabis policy and regulations and we
track each bill based on how it aligns
with these principles these include
protecting Children and Youth promoting
social justice and opportunities for
Equity protecting public and population
health and ensuring appropriate funding
from revenue from Cannabis is directed
to efforts to reduce Harms
uh based on these bills uh new features
uh opposes both hb639 with and 545
because they both were 544 excuse me
because they failed to include our
organization's principles
um what I have for you today is a copy
of our principles along with how each
bill which is very different
um aligns up with our principles I'll
provide that to you and our testimony as
well and a study um from the American
Pediatrics Association are at the
increase in cannabis exposures which
backs up uh the reason for a lot of the
policies and principles we have uh today
in front of you
great thank you any questions from the
committee members
Cena thank you very much
uh Matt Simon from Prime ATC
thank you Mr chairman I'll be very brief
this time for the record Matt Simon
representing Prime ATC
on the previous bill I asked four
questions and the answer was yes to all
four of them on this bill the answer is
not yes to all four of them does the
bill take a thoughtful approach to the
therapeutic cannabis program no you've
already heard from Mr hold on that so I
won't repeat his comments
would the legislation create a broad
distribution of economic opportunities
again no
the economic opportunities would be
realized by the state
does the bill repair damage caused by
the war on cannabis such as including
Provisions to annul past criminal
records no it does not it would simply
set up the state to start making money
off the sale of cannabis without
redressing
past Harms
Ford is the bill create accessible
transparent regulatory process to
protect consumers and minimize any
potential negative impacts again I'm
going to know for reasons that Mr Holt
and the Scribe already said and I will
conclude my testimony uh glad to hear
that we're not seriously talking about
passing that same bill again
thank you
okay thank you
Joseph Hart
how you all doing tonight
I support both these bills
um I know I speak it on 544 but I I
support the last bill as well
um but I have a couple questions
um I don't know what the police are
going to are going to do when everyone
has weed right they're gonna have
nothing to do because they just arrest
everyone and throw them in jail and I'm
just wondering how are their kids going
to eat at night if you get that bill
passed now they just got nothing to do
and a bunch of people gonna be out free
smoking weed on the streets you know uh
I got a whiff of weed the other day
driving by this house and next thing you
know I'm stuffing down a Big Mac
who's going to pay me back for that Big
Mac no I really want to know like you
know we got to take care of these people
we we can't just let them smoke weed
peacefully in their homes I prefer they
go out drinking with the legal uh
alcohol that the state sells and uh you
know maybe we'll get into a fight or two
and that's way better the solution than
legalizing cannabis and allowing us to
you know smoke weed in our home maybe
get a little hungry and maybe eat too
much that's horrible obesity is like one
of the biggest problems in America not
you know drinking and driving and buying
alcohol from the state that is okay I'm
okay with that we should allow that and
you know the police have something to do
as long as people are drinking right put
smoking weed at home that is not okay
uh God forbid with you know sales go up
and you guys generate enough Revenue to
uh you know support the police at that
point but you got to think about the
police kids because next thing you know
the kids are going to be uh smoking a
little bit of weed and getting hungry
but the police don't have any money to
pay for their kids food so
we should think about this and um
yeah I'm sorry I'm just a little
paranoid here don't ask why but
um I came here and I was still able to
speak and you know hopefully you guys
you know hear me out and you know a
little bit of weed can go a long way and
don't knock it until you try it right so
maybe you smoke a little bit and find
out what it's about then you can decide
if it should be illegal or not just like
you do when you're going home tonight
and you have a you know a nice Scotch
okay thanks guys appreciate it
thank you very much
uh chair we're calling Nathaniel Goran
of New Hampshire
common man's part no maybe not it's just
a different party now
I wanted to ask you is does marijuana
supposed to be good for your eyes
because this is the smallest political
card handwriting I've print I've ever
seen I I said maybe this is only for
young people that like old people can't
read this or you know well you know I
actually they misprinted a smaller
version smaller
um anyway okay thank you for uh this
opportunity
um I um I apologize I may have been out
of order in expressing a view on 544 as
part of my previous presentation but um
I did so I'm certainly not going to
repeat it
um so um thank you
okay that was fast okay I have no more
cards
I have no regards uh the blue sheet
which I uh the last one the blue sheet
was 93 for for it and 20 were opposed to
it and this one here I've got
um
let's see uh I got one two three four
five six seven opposed one two three
four five for it
and online was 12 support 14 pose and
one neutral
so that is it so
um just for the committee uh at this
point they have not announced canceling
anything tomorrow so stay tuned on that
um we will have our subcommittee on you
know on the uh
Wednesday morning
we'll you know uh next Wednesday morning
tomorrow we tomorrow is 10 o'clock by
the way just
tomorrow's 10 o'clock the only reason it
was nine today was because I had all
these bills that I these are all early
bills so I I'm you know was feeling
under pressure to get get them out and
get them hurt
and that's why you were showed up okay
okay
it's nine o'clock for you tomorrow
morning
okay
um so otherwise we'll we'll be working
on those bills uh on the next Monday uh
Friday anything that we're actually able
to come to conclusion with
um next
Wednesday morning
the speakers just asked that we would
have a session Thursday February 2nd
after our uh session evidently they
don't have a lot on the calendar so we
will have a committee exec session
Thursday afternoon
and but that'll be based upon whatever
we discussed in on Wednesday morning
it'll be in the calendar everything will
be in the calendar but I just thought
you should all know so be there for this
second
okay so and this is really important to
everybody if you're not going to be
there Anita and I need to know you know
because we need to have you know we you
know we need to be balanced and make
sure we do it right out of committee
okay otherwise the snow doesn't look it
look bad for a moment there but but it
stopped so we're all good thank you guys
for very much it was great